THIS ISN'T YOU IT'S TIME TO GET
OFF THE BUS.
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO DO AN
OVERVIEW OF THE GOVERNOR'S
EDUCATION BUDGET PROPOSALS --
AND THAT'S WHAT IT IS WE HAVE A
SERIES OF PANELS THAT --
WILL CALL OF IN SEQUENCE TO
DISCUSS THE VARIOUS BUDGET
PROPOSALS.
AND FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
INTERESTED AND FOR THE RECORD
THIS IS ITEM. SIX ONE ZERO ZERO
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION SIX
EIGHT SEVEN ZERO CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND WE ARE ON
AND WE WILL START WITH ISSUE
NUMBER ONE OVERVIEW OF
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT AND TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET
PROPOSALS THIS IS AN INFORMATION
HEARING THERE WILL BE NO ACTION
ITEMS.
OF FOR THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO TAKE
SELF.
WITH THAT WHY DON'T WE START
WITH OUR FIRST PANEL THOSE OF
YOU WHO KNOW WHO YOU ARE PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
HOPEFULLY WE HAVE ENOUGH CHEERS
ON THE BUS.
LET ME ASK YOU TO IDENTIFY
YOURSELF FOR THE RECORD STARTING
WITH MY LEFT YOU'RE RIGHT SIR.
I NEED TO BRUSH FROM EXECUTIVE
VICE PRESIDENT AND CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
YEARS OR YOU RT'S OAKLEY CHANCER
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES PLEASURE TO BE HERE YES
A GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
LUPITA CORTES APALACHEE DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT FOR
SUPERINTENDENT TONY THURMOND
GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
GOOD MORNING TIM WHITE GEN
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY THANK YOU FOR COMING
CHANCELLOR.
OKAY.
WHO WANTS TO START FIRST MA'AM?
THANK YOU THE CORTES ISLAND
ALLOW THE HALF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND THANK
YOU FOR INVITING ME HERE TODAY.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CHAIR
SENATOR ROTH FOR GIVING ME A
CHANCE TO DISCUSS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET.
THANK YOU --
BIG THANK YOU TO THE GOVERNOR
FOR HIS ATTENTION A COMMITMENT
TO EDUCATION IN THE BUDGET WE
HAVE AN UNPRECEDENTED
OPPORTUNITY TO DO MORE WITH MORE.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD A
COMPREHENSIVE EDUCATION SYSTEM
THAT SERVES ALL CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES PREPARING CALIFORNIANS
A TO MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THE WORK FORCE
FOR THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY AND
BEYOND.
SO WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR
FOR PLAY I ALREADY ON EDUCATION
AND LOOK FORWARD TO A STRONG
PRODUCTIVE PARTNERSHIP WITH HIM.
IN THE END THE LEGISLATURE AS
WELL AS ALL STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
NEXT FEW YEARS THAT WILL LIFT
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS BY IMPROVING
OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM AND
INCREASING THE RESOURCES THAT GO
TO OUR SCHOOLS.
WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR AND
FOCUSING THE CONVERSATION ON THE
NEEDS OF THE EARLIEST LEARNERS.
AND STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
EARLY EDUCATION AS YOU KNOW IS
CRITICAL THIS CLOSING THE
OPPORTUNITY AND ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
AS EARLY IDENTIFICATION AND
SUPPORTS FOR STUDENTS.
AND PARTICULAR THOSE STUDENTS
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS SO WE KNOW
THAT 90% OF BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
OCCURS BEFORE THE AGE OF FIVE SO
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT OUR
EDUCATION RESOURCES PROMOTE.
A HEALTHY START FOR CHILDREN IN
MEETING THE NEEDS OF THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY LIVE.
IN ADDITION ONE OF THE
SUPERINTENDENTS HIGHEST
PRIORITIES --
IS TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE HIGH
QUALITY SCHOOLS THAT ARE BETTER
EQUIPPED TO FOR TO SERVE THE
STUDENTS AND SO THOSE ARE KNOWN
AS COMMUNITY SCHOOLS THE SCHOOLS
WILL WORK WITH THEIR COUNTIES
AND LOCAL PARTNERS WORKING
TOGETHER TO ADDRESS THE VERY
REAL NEEDS OF STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
THESE THESE IF LEFT UNMET CREATE
ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES FOR OUR
SCHOOLS THE TOWNS THAT HAVE
BECOME EVIDENT IN THE RECENT
DISTRICT CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS
WITH LA UST IN OAKLAND.
AND HERE IN SACRAMENTO A
SIGNIFICANT ASPECT OF THOSE
NEGOTIATIONS CENTERED AROUND THE
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS
LIKE COUNSELORS SCHOOL NURSES
AND LIBRARIANS.
WE NEED TO CREATE A MEANINGFUL
STRUCTURE STRUCTURES AND
STRATEGIES AND RELATIONSHIP TO
PROVIDE LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES --
AND CONDITIONS TO ACCESS VITAL
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS THAT MIGHT
NOT OTHERWISE BE AVAILABLE BOTH
IN AND OUT OF SCHOOL COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS WILL USE THIS INTEGRATED
APPROACH TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
NURSES COUNSELORS AND SOCIAL
WORKERS CREATING PLACES WHERE
CHILDREN.
AND THEIR FAMILIES HAVE EASY
ACCESS TO THE SERVICES NEEDED TO
CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP IMPACT
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN IS
SPONSORING LEGISLATION AB ELEVEN
NINETY SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON TO SUPPORT THE CREATION
OF COMMUNITY SCHOOLS.
PROVIDING THE SUPPORTS WILL HELP
OUR STUDENTS BE READY AND BE
ABLE TO MEET THE ACADEMIC
OPPORTUNITIES PRESENTED TO THEM
IN CLASS.
CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
REQUIRES ACCESS TO TOOLS
INCLUDING ACCESS TO STEAM AND
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
OUR TEACHERS INCLUDING THOSE
WORKING WITH OUR YOUNGEST
LEARNERS CANNOT BE EXPECTED TO
DO THIS ALONE WE NEED TO PROVIDE
HIGH QUALITY EVIDENCE AND
PRACTICE BASED PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. TO ENSURE THAT THEY
HAVE THE TOLS AND TRAINING
NEEDED TO MAKE SURE ALL STUDENTS
WE ARE READING BY THE THIRD
GRADE.
LITERACY IS A HUGE PRIORITY FOR
THE SUPERINTENDENT AND IS
FUNDAMENTAL TO THE ACADEMIC AND
LIFE SUCCESS IT'S A KEY TO
SOLVING THE PROBLEM TO THE
SCHOOL TO PRISONPIPELINE.
WE NEED TO ENGAGE OUR FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES TO CREATE A
CULTURAL CULTURE OF LITERACY IN
READING THAT INSTILLS THE LOVE
OF LIFELONG.
LEARNING TO PREPARE STUDENTS FOR
THE CAREERS OF THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY.
SO SPEAKING OF A PARENT OR
COMMUNITIES WE NEED TO INVEST IN
AFFORDABLE WORK FORCE HOUSING.
THE OTHER EDUCATORS CAN LIVE IN
THE COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY WORK
IT'S VITAL THAT ARE DISTRICTS
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND COUNTY
OFFICES RECRUIT THE BEST AND
BRIGHTEST TEACHERS FOR STUDENTS.
BUT IF WE INVEST IN OUR TEACHERS
THEY WILL THEN BE ABLE TO INVEST
IN OUR CHILDREN BY PROVIDING OUR
TEACHERS AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND THE COMMUNITY THEY TEACH AND
THEY CAN TAKE THEIR TWO HOURS OF
COMMUTE TIME INVESTED IN A
BUILDING STRONGER CONNECTION TO
THE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE.
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO IMPROVE
THE WORKING CONDITIONS FOR
EDUCATORS THEY DESERVE BETTER
AND OUR STUDENTS DESERVE BETTER.
TO REITERATE THE
SUPERINTENDENT'S FIVE TOP
PRIORITIES COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
EARLY EDUCATION AND LITERACY
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
WORK FORCE HOUSING.
BEHALF THE SUPERINTENDENT
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN THE MONTHS
AHEAD AND MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
HERE TODAY --
FOR THIS IN PRESIDENT
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD A
COMPREHENSIVE EDUCATION SYSTEM
THAT SERVES ALL CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES MEETING THEM IN THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY LIVE IN
PREPARING THE STUDENTS. FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION AND THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY WORKFORCE THANK
YOU SO MUCH MA'AM --
I NORMALLY WOULD HOLD QUESTIONS
BUT IF --
RATHER PANELIST WOULD ALLOW ME
AN OPPORTUNITY TO JUST ASK A
COUPLE QUESTIONS OF COURSE MAYBE
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE WANTED TO AS
WELL.
YOU KNOW IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN WE SPENT A GREAT DEAL
OF TIME.
WITH THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA.
AND THE LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLANS AND PUTTING
THAT PROCESS IN PLACE --
HOW HOW EFFECTIVE DO YOU THINK
THE REVIEW PROCESS IS FOR THE
LOCAL CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY
PLANS BECAUSE I HAVE SOME
CONCERNS?
AND I THINK THAT WITH THIS NEW
ADMINISTRATION IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ASSESS THAT --
I THINK WE'VE HEARD BOTH SORT OF
SIDES TO IT THAT YOU KNOW
THEY'RE THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA A SERVE A
PURPOSE TO ALLOW FOR THE
GREATEST AMOUNT OF FLEXIBILITY
BUT WE'VE ALSO HEARD AND SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT IT'S
MEASURING.
AND WHERE RESOURCES ARE GOING
AND A HOME AND SO THIS
ADMINISTRATION WITH US --
SUPERINTEND THURMAN WE'RE GOING
TO EVALUATE THAT AND REALLY
LISTEN TO SEE WHAT'S WORKING
WHAT'S NOT WORKING AND IF IN
FACT THE STUDENTS --
AND TEACHERS ARE REALLY --
USING THESE ROADS RESOURCES IF
THEY'RE BEING USED EFFECTIVELY
FOR THE NEEDY STUDENTS AND SO I
THINK THAT STILL SOMETHING THAT
WERE ASSESSING A COUPLE OF
MINUTES A COUPLE MONTHS INTO THE
THIS ADMINISTRATION.
AND YOU MENTION NURSES AND
COUNSELORS WE HEAR CONCERNS
ABOUT THOSE --
THOSE POSITIONS AND THE ISSUE
FROM CONSTITUENTS WITH SOME
REGULARITY.
HOW DO WE ENSURE HOW DO WE FORCE
THE CONVERSATION DURING THE
PREPARATION OF THE LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN? TO FORCE
THE DISCUSSION BETWEEN THE
DISTRICTS AND THE STAKEHOLDERS.
ABOUT THE ALLOCATION OF FUNDING
THROUGH THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA WITH REGARD.
TO GETTING POSITIONS FOR SCHOOL
COUNSELORS OR SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS WE HAD A PRIORITY
TO THE TO THE EIGHT THAT ALREADY
EXIST IN THE EL CAP PROCESS OR
DO WE ED LANGUAGE UNDER SCHOOL
CLIMATE TO FORCE THE
CONVERSATION.
SO THOSE ARE REALLY GREAT
QUESTIONS AND I THINK THAT IT'S
IT'S LIKE BEING KIND OF A FORCED.
TO MAKE UP A REALLY HARD
DECISION RIGHT.
WHAT WHAT DO YOU USE THE FUNDING
FOR YOU KNOW ARE YOU TO TAKE IT
AWAY FROM THE INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS IN THE PROFESSIONAL
DON'T THAT DAHLE IF IT'S GOING
CURRENTLY GOING ON?
OR DO WE REALLY NEED TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION ABOUT INCREASE
FUNDING RESOURCES FOR SCHOOLS
THE WORD JUST AT THE MINIMUM
PROP NINETY EIGHT ADMINISTERS
THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE AND I
THINK ONE OF THE SUPERINTENDENT
PRIORITIES REALLY IS.
LOOKING AT OF DIFFERENT
RESOURCES ARE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES --
WHETHER IT'S READING A REAL
LOOKING UP THE PROP THIRTEEN THE
SPLIT ROLE LOOKING AT TO SEE A
SOME OF THE TAX CREDITS THAT'S
BEEN THAT SPENT THAT --
NINETY EIGHT ALSO LOOKING AT
OTHER --
BUDGET RESOURCES AND FISCAL
RESOURCES --
AND LEVERAGING SOME HEALTH
RESOURCES AS WELL TO HELP WITH
THE NURSES AND SOME OF THE
COUNSELOR NEEDS THAT ARE HAVING --
A GREAT IMPACT ON THE STUDENTS
SO I I THINK WHAT YOU'RE ASKING
IS WE CAN'T DO MORE WITH LESS OR
WITH THE SAME AMOUNT IF WE WANT
TO DO MORE THAN WE HAVE TO
INVEST.
IN THESE THE SCHOOL DISTRICT SO --
THE RESTOCKING THE SAME THAT IS
NOT GOING TO GET YOU LESS OF
SOMETHING.
WE'LL IN TYING INTO THAT ON A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT IN A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT DIRECTION AN ISSUE
THAT IS DIRECTLY.
BUDGET RELATED IS THE IS A
SUPPLEMENTAL IN CONCENTRATION
GRANT PIECE OF LOCAL THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
TODAY YOU CAN HAVE DISTRICT ONE
THAT HAS --
MORE THAN 55% ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS FREE AND REDUCED LUNCH
FOSTER KIDS.
AND DISTRICT.
TWO CONTINUOUS NEXT TO IT THAT
HAS LESS THAN 55% THE LINE GOES
DOWN THE MIDDLE YOU CAN HAVE A
SCHOOL ON ONE SIDE THAT HAS 90%.
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS CENTER
AND THE SCHOOL ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE LINE THAT HAS 90%.
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS BUT IN
DIFFERENT DISTRICTS AND ONE GETS
50% MORE.
OF THE BASS GRANT ABOVE THAT
PERCENTAGE.
AND THE OTHER DOES NOT.
AND IT COST ASSEMBLY TO EDUCATE.
THAT BODY OF STUDENTS INFO
SCHOOLS IS IT TIME TO EXPLORE
THE CONCENTRATION GRANT AND
PERHAPS DEAL WITH THAT IN A
DIFFERENT WAY.
I THINK IT'S DEFINITELY TIME TO
EXPLORE --
IN EQUITY --
IN THOSE DISTRICTS AND SO WE'RE
DEFINITELY GONNA BE LOOKING AT
THAT.
PERFECT.
WELL I'VE EXHAUSTED MY KNOWLEDGE
AND MY QUESTIONS COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
FAIRLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
A GOOD MORNING TO ALL THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE THE PIZZA I FIRST
HAVE TO DO A SHOUT OUT TO OUR
SUPERINTENDENT TONY THURMOND HE
WAS IT WOULD CREST YEAR HIGH
WITH ME LAST FRIDAY.
IN ONTARIO AND I JUST THINK
THAT'S FANTASTIC AND GOES TO HIS
CHARACTER AND SHOWING HOW HANDS
ON HE IS.
THE STUDENTS LOVED HIM ALBEIT
THEY MAY NOT KNOW WHO THE BUT
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION DOES BUT YOU DON'T
GET OUT THERE TELL THEM THEY'LL
NEVER NOW.
SO VERY MUCH APPRECIATE HIM
DOING THAT I HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE STATE --
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM AND THE EXPAND.
CONSIDERING THE PRESCHOOL SLOTS
GO UNUSED EVERY YEAR --
WILL NON ELLIE GAYS BE ABLE TO
FILL THE TEN THOUSAND SLOT.
SEVEN THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
SERRA NOBLE MORGAN IS HERE
ANSWER THAT VERY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS OVER I AS THE CHAIR OF
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS I WOULD BE
REMISS IF I DID NOT ASK THESE
QUESTIONS.
THEN AS YOU KNOW IT ALSO
INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR'S%
PROPOSAL IS I JUST NOT FINDING
FOR FACILITIES AS WELL AS WORK
FOR SUPPORT.
I THINK AS WE INVEST EXPANSION
OF THE SYSTEM WE ALSO HAVE TO
SUPPORT IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF
THE SYSTEM AND SO THOSE MAKE A
LOT OF SMART.
I'M CHOICES WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THE NON TOWARDS COMMUNITY BASED
PROVIDERS SINCE WE HAVE INVESTED
IN THE ALLEY A SIDE QUITE A BAT.
THE BALANCES THAT OUT AND
ENSURES THAT WORKING FAMILIES
BUT HAVE GREATER ACCESS TO IT
BECAUSE THEY OFTEN PROVIDE MORE
OF THE FULL DAY FULL YEAR.
FOUGHT.
OKAY VERY GOOD I HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION MIGHT BE RIGHT UP YOUR
ALEY --
WOULD WE WANT TO GIVE PRIORITY
TO KIDS THAT HAVE BOTH PARENTS
WORKING BECAUSE THEY MIGHT NEED
MORE THAN A CHILD WITH ONLY ONE
PARENT WORKING SO WHAT WE WORRY
ABOUT IS.
YOU KNOW IF IF YOU'RE FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO BE IN A FAMILY WHERE
ONE PARENT STAYS HOME.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WHEN BOTH
PARENTS HAVE TO WORK COOL.
AND THAT'S WHEN AT THAT TIME FOR
QUESTIONS SO WE ALWAYS LOOK AT
SINCE WE HAVE THAT'S THE CITY OF
THE CHILD CARE DEVELOPMENT FUNDS
THE ELIGIBILITY AND THEY NEED
SECTION OF AT WHICH ARE THERE
RIGHT NOW.
AS WE LOOK TOWARDS FULL DAY FULL
YEAR IT TYPICALLY MAKES SENSE TO
SUPPORT THOSE WORKING FAMILIES --
BUT THERE ARE UNIQUE FAMILY
CIRCUMSTANCES SO IT'S REALLY
HARD TO SAY THAT THE TWO PARENT
WITH ONE PARENT WORKING.
AND THERE MIGHT BE OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCES AROUND THAT.
THAT'S FAIR I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
MAKE SURE WE THINK ABOUT THT.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
REALLY.
WELL QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WELL GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING --
THANK YOU CHAIR ROTH AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
FOR HAVING US TODAY --
ME LAWYER TEASE OAKLEY AND I
HAVE THE GREAT PRIVILEGE OF
LEADING THE NATION'S LARGEST
SYSTEM OF HIGHER EDUCATION THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE WITH
YOU.
THIS MORNING.
IT'S BEEN.
A LITTLE OVER TWO YEARS NOW
SINCE THE CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE
COLLEGES.
COMMITTED TO OUR VISION FOR
SUCCESS --
AND WE CONTINUE TO BE GUIDED BY
THAT VISION.
A AND TO CONTINUE TO CHALLENGE
THE STATUS QUO AND CONTINUE TO
RAISE ISSUES ABOUT EQUITY AND
ENSURING THAT OUR SYSTEM OF
HIGHER EDUCATION IS PREPARING
OUR STUDENTS AND WORKING ADULTS.
FOR THE JOBS OF THE FUTURE.
WE'RE COMMITTED TO FOLLOWING OUR
NOR START WHICH IS CLOSING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS THAT WE HAVE
ACROSS THE STATE AND ACROSS THE
REGION'S.
BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND WE
CONTINUE TO CHARGE FORWARD IN
THAT DIRECTION.
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS WHAT
YOUR STRONG SUPPORT WE ARE
FOCUSED ON RESTRUCTURING OR
COLLEGES SO THAT THEY CAN BE
MORE STUDENT READY --
THE LEGISLATURE'S BEEN A KEY
PARTNER IN THAT WORK AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN YOU PROVIDED-CRITICAL FUNDING FOR THE GUIDED
PATHWAYS FRAMEWORK THE COLLEGES.
ARE CREATING MUCH CLEARER
PATHWAYS TO EMPLOYMENT AND TO
FURTHER EDUCATION.
AND THEY'RE HELPING EVERY
STUDENT CHOOSE AND ENTER A
PATHWAY AND STAY ON THAT PATHWAY.
YOU ALSO APPROVED THE ASSEMBLY
BILL --
SEVEN OH FIVE WHICH GROUP WHICH
<c.blue>NSURES A STUDENT INTO REMEDIAL</c>
COURSES THAT MAY DETER THEM.
IN THEIR PURSUIT OF AN
EDUCATIONAL GOAL --
UNLESS THERE IS CLEAR EVIDENCE
THAT SUGGESTS THAT THEY NEED
THOSE COURSES.
THAT SAME YEAR --
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE WE
ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
PROMISE.
THE COMPONENTS THAT PROGRAM --
HIGH --
RESONATE VERY CLEARLY WITH ME --
FROM MY EXPERIENCE IN LONG BEACH --
WITH THE LONG BEACH COLLEGE
PROMISE.
WHERE IN LONG BEACH SCHOOL
LEADERS FROM LONG BEACH UNIFIED
WORK WITH FACULTY AND STAFF FROM
CAL STATE LONG BEACH IN LONG
BEACH CITY COLLEGE? TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE PROMOTING A COLLEGE
GOING CULTURE IN THAT COMMUNITY.
SO NOW THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
PROMISE.
IS MAXIMIZING ACCESS TO EXISTING
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS AND
ENCOURAGING COLLEGES TO ENGAGE
IN EVIDENCE BASED STUDENT
SUCCESS STRATEGIES.
IT AUTHORIZES FUNDING TO BE USED
TO SUPPORT ONE YEAR FREE TUITION
FOR ALL FIRST TIME FULL TIME
STUDENTS.
AND WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE FORTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS CURRENTLY
INTENDED FOR THAT PURPOSE.
THE EDITORIAL AWAY FEES IS ALSO
LINKED TO SOME SPECIFIC
CONDITIONS AT COLLEGES MERCED
HERE.
TO THEY MUST EXPAND PARTNERSHIPS
WITH SCHOOLS WE THINK THIS IS
CRITICAL WORKING WITH LOCAL K.
TWELVE DISTRICT WITH LOCAL CAL
STATE CAMPUSES IS CRITICAL TO
THE SUCCESS.
USING MULTIPLE MEASURES FOR
ASSESSMENT EMPLACEMENT
CONSISTENT WITH A. B..
SEVEN OH FIVE PARTICIPATINGTHE
GUIDED PATHWAYS FRAMEWORK.
ENSURING THE STUDENTS COMPLETE
THE FEDERAL AND STATE FINANCIAL
AID APPLICATIONS WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT STUDENTS ARE GAINING
ACCESS TO THE AID THAT THEY
DESERVE.
AND THAT THEY'RE PARTICIPATING
IN THE FEDERAL STUDENT LOAN
PROGRAM.
I KNOW HOW SIGNIFICANT THE
CHANGES THAT WE MADE LAST YEAR
WERE.
WITH THE ENACTMENT OF THE
STUDENT CENTER FUNDING FORMULA
AND THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE NEW
ONLINE COLLEGE IN AND AGAIN I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN
THOSE ENDEAVORS.
THOSE CHANGES WILL REINFORCE
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE TO MAKE
PROGRESS ON THE GOALS.
AND TO CREATE IMPORTANT YOU
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR ADULTS WHO
NEED THE SKILLS THEY NEED TO
RESPOND IN THIS ECONOMY
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE WORKING
ADULTS --
THAT ARE STRUGGLING WITH THE
CHALLENGES OF AUTOMATION AND THE
CHANGES IN THE ECONOMY.
I'M PROUD TO SHARE THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES OF THE CALIFORNIA
ONLINE COMMUNICATIVE DISTRICT
NAME HEATHER HYLES. TO BE THE
COLLEGE'S FIRST CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER.
HEATHER IS AN INNOVATOR SHE'S AN
EDUCATOR.
AND A SUCCESSFUL ENTREPRENEUR
WITH A DEEP COMMITMENT TO EQUITY
IN EDUCATION.
INTO CREATING ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES FOR UNDERSERVED
PEOPLE.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
OPPORTUNITY OF INTRODUCING
HEATHER TO ALL OF YOU IN THE
VERY NEAR FUTURE.
ALSO.
APPRECIATE THE CONFIDENCE A
GOVERNOR'S SOME PLACES IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE COLLEGES IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
TO THAT BILLS ON THE PRIOR
REFORMS.
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED EXPANSION OF
THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE.
BECAUSE IT BUILT ON THE
FRAMEWORK CREATED UNDER AB
NINETEEN WHICH STAB THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT WE
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THIS
FRAMEWORK IN AB NINETEEN MUST
REMAIN IN PLACE.
IF THE PROGRAM IS GOING TO HELP
US ACHIEVE OUR GOALS IN THE
VISION FOR SUCCESS.
THAT PROPOSAL IS PART OF A
BROADER THEME IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
ADDRESSING COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY
SO THAT MORE CALIFORNIANS CAN
GAIN THE SKILLS AND CREDENTIALS
NEEDED IN TODAY'S ECONOMY.
LET ME UNDERSCORE THE URGENCY OF
THIS WORK. TO ACHIEVE THE VISION
FOR SUCCESS BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THE REFORMS
THAT WE'VE UNDERTAKEN. TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES MUST BE
COUPLED.
WITH CHANGES TO THE FINANCIAL
AID SYSTEM THAT ADDRESS THE TRUE
COST OF ATTENDING OUR COLLEGES
FOR ALL STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR BACKGROUNDS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET EXPANDS
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM FOR
STUDENTS WHO RELY AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THE MOST.
WE APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS FOR NEW CAL GRANTS FOR
STUDENTS WITH DEPENDENT CHILDREN.
AND FOR THE NEW COMPETITIVE CAL
GRANT AWARDS.
WE'RE INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL. TO
SENATOR LEYVA. FOR AUTHORING
SENATE BILL. TWO NINETY ONE TO
ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM.
WE'RE VERY PROUD TO BE CO
SPONSORS OF THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION.
THE BILL IS ALSO CO SPONSORED BY
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IN ITS SUPPORTERS REFLECT A
BROAD COALITION INCLUDING OUR
STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF.
MANY OF WHOM WORK WITH THE
STUDENTS EVERY DAY OF THEIR
LIVES AND IN ADDRESSING THE
BASIC NEEDS.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THOUGH THE
ABOUT THE PRINCIPLES THAT
MOTIVATE THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS
PARTICULARLY AS A REFERS TO THIS
FINANCIAL A PROPOSAL.
WE BELIEVE THAT ALL CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
SHOULD BE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
FINANCIAL AID REGARDLESS OF
THEIR AGE REGARDLESS OF THE TIME
OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL OR THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL GRADES.
WE BELIEVE THAT A STUDENT'S
FINANCIAL AID SHOULD BE LINKED
TO THE TRUE COST OF ATTENDING
COLLEGE NOT JUST TUITION AND
FEES BUT ALSO HOUSING.
FOOD TRANSPORTATION AND SUPPLIES.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT STUDENTS
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO FINANCIAL
AID REGARDLESS OF THE STUDENTS
EDUCATIONAL GOALS THAT IS
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY'RE
PURSUING A DEGREE.
A CERTIFICATE OR SHORT TERM
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAM FINANCIAL AID SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE EQUITABLY.
I WANT TO RECOGNIZE MY
COLLEAGUES --
IN THE UC CERTAINLY TRANSFER
WHITE.
PRESIDENT APOLLO TANO AND HER
TEAM FOR ANY FINANCIAL AID AS
WELL WE ARE ONE SYSTEM OF HIGHER
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA.
IN OUR OUTCOMES ARE
INTERCONNECTED IN LENGTH AND WE
MUST FOCUS ON STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY ATTEND
TODAY.
BECAUSE THEY MOVE THROUGHOUT OUR
SYSTEMS AND WE WANT ENSURE THEIR
SUCCESS.
I BELIEVE THAT.
THE PRINCIPLES AT ALL THE
SYSTEMS HAVE --
ARE CONSISTENT WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND I BELIEVE
THAT THERE CONSISTENT WITH SB --
TWO NINETY ONE WE BUILD ON ON
THE NOTION OF OF DOING NO HARM.
MAINTAINING CAL GRANTS FOCUS ON
TUITION COVERAGE MAINTAINING
COLLEGES FOCUS ON THE TOTAL COST
OF ATTENDANCE AND EXPANDING THE
REACH OF THE STATE'S FINANCIAL
AID.
MOVING FORWARD I WILL WORK
TIRELESSLY TO COMBAT THE
ASSUMPTIONS.
THAT ARE OFTEN MADE ABOUT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
THEIR NEEDS AND THEIR VALUE.
I HAVE HEARD SOME SAY EVEN SOME
IN THIS BUILDING.
THAT INVESTMENT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS IS NOT A
WORTHWHILE INVESTMENT AND I
COULDN'T AGREE MORE.
DISAGREE MORE SORRY [inaudible]
YES.
DISAGREED VEHEMENTLY DISAGREE.
BUT OVER THE COURSE.
LIKE OTHER STUDENTS COMMITTEE
BECAUSE STUDENTS TO FACE --
ENORMOUS CHALLENGES LIKE THE
COST OF FOOD HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION 40% OF COMMITTEE
BECAUSE STUDENTS ARE OVER THE
AGE OF TWENTY FIVE MANY OF YOU
KNOW THE STATISTICS ALREADY.
THERE THERE'S A SURVEY THAT WAS
RELEASED TODAY AND THE RESULTS
OF THAT SURVEY.
SUGGESTS THAT HALF OF THE
STUDENTS ATTENDING COMMIT
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE TROUBLE AFFORDING BALANCED
MEALS OR WORRY ABOUT RUNNING OUT
OF FOOD.
AND NEARLY ONE IN FIVE ARE
EITHER HOMELESS OR DO NOT HAVE A
STABLE PLACE TO LIVE.
THAT IS CERTAINLY TRUE OF OUR
SISTER INSTITUTIONS AS WELL.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
ALREADY PAY.
ALREADY WORK TO PAY FOR THEIR
EDUCATION NO THOSE AT STUDENTS
WHO WORK EXCESSIVE HOURS --
ALSO UNDERMINE THEIR OWN
EDUCATIONAL PROGRESS.
AND FINALLY WE JUST BELIEVE THAT
OUR STUDENTS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS DESERVE ACCESS THE FORT
CALIFORNIA'S FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM.
SB NINETY ONE SB TWO NINETY ONE
SPECIFIES INTENT THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS BE
INCLUDED IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
FOR THE PROGRAM I LOOK FORWARD
TO PARTNERING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE TO ENACT THAT
APPROPRIATION.
IN CLOSING I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT A FEW OTHER ISSUES.
WE ARE MINDFUL THAT --
THERE ARE CONSTRAINTS CREATED BY
MORE LIMITED GROWTH IMPROPER.
NINETY EIGHT THEN WE HAVE
EXPERIENCE IN RECENT YEARS.
WITH THE SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S CONTINUED
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE STUDENT
CENTER FUNDING FORMULA.
I SHARE THE CONCERNS OF THE
GOVERNMENT THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
RACE ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE CONFIDENCE IN THE QUALITY
OF THE DATA BEING USED IN THE
FORMULA.
AND WE ARE CONDUCTING A
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF THE DATA.
WHICH WILL BE COMPLETED IN MAY
AND HOPEFULLY INFORM YOUR
DELIBERATIONS ON THE BUDGET.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE RELIEF ON
PENSION COSTS.
PENSION COSTS IN OUR SYSTEM
SIMILAR TO THE K. TWELVE SYSTEM
OR HAVE AN ENORMOUS IMPACT ON
OUR COLLEGES ABILITY.
TO DIRECT RESOURCES WHERE
THEY'RE NEEDED THE MOST IN THE
CLASSROOM SO ANY RELIEF THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE ON THE PENSION COSTS
WOULD BE VERY MUCH APPRECIATED.
FINALLY WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S.
INCLUDING CAPITAL OUTLAY FUNDS.
FOR THE FUNDING TO SUPPORT
FIFTEEN CONTINUING PROJECTS IN
TWELVE NEW PROJECTS.
WITH THAT SAID I CONTINUE TO
BELIEVE TAT IN ENACTING PROP
FIFTY ONE VOTERS CALLED FOR
GREATER INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
OR BOARD OF GOVERNORS APPROVED A
TOTAL OF NINETEEN CONTINUING
PROJECTS IN THIRTY NINE YOU
PROJECTS OUR OFFICE WILL BE
WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND
WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
A TO GET FUNDING OF FOR THOSE
PROJECTS.
SO -- THE
LAST THING I WILL RAISE IS AT
THE GOVERNOR HAS ALSO PROPOSE A
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO THE
SUCCESS OF ALL STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA --
YOU WILL TALK ABOUT THIS IN YOUR
SECOND PANEL BUT I WANT TO
EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE PROPOSAL.
UP I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND BE MY PLEASURE TO ANSWER ANY
OF YOUR QUESTIONS THANK YOU
ELEVEN QUESTIONS.
YES THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN.
I AM A BIG FAN OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THAT'S WHERE I STARTED
AT MOUNT SAN ANTONIO COLLEGE
MOUNT SAC BACK IN THE DAY WILL
TAKE HOW LONG AGO SOME YOU MIGHT
THINK I'M YOUNGER THAN I AM --
AND I WOULD I'VE YEARS AGO MAYBE
YEAH YEAH COULDN'T LOVE IT.
A BIT I HAD THE BEST ENGLISH
CLASS OF MY WHOLE COLLEGE CAREER
AT MOUNT SAC.
AND WHEN I HEARD THAT PAYING
MORE FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE THEN
THEY WERE TO ATTEND THE UC OR
SEE ISSUE JUST STRICTLY BECAUSE
OF FINANCIAL AID WASN'T
AVAILABLE TO THEM I JUST THOUGHT
THEY WERE SOMETHING WE SHOULD DO --
SO WHATEVER --
I CAN CONTINUE TO DO TO BE
SUPPORTIVE I WILL I HOPE THAT WE
CAN GET SB TWO NINETY ONE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK THERE'S AN OLD
SAYING THAT SAYS DON'T TELL ME
WHAT YOUR PRIORITIES ARE SHOW ME
WHERE YOUR SPEND YOUR MONEY AND
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT YOUR
PRIORITIES.
ARE SO WE SAY THESE ARE OUR
CHILDREN ARE OUR FUTURE AND NOT
ALWAYS CHILDREN A COMMUNICABLE
JUST BUT IF WE REALLY DO WANT
THEM TO SUCCEED THEN WE NEED TO
PUT OUR MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH IS.
IN THE MEANTIME --
BEFORE WE HOPEFULLY GET THAT
BILL TO THE GOVERNOR AND GET IT
SIGNED.
HOW DO YOU SEE HOW DO YOU THINK
YOU'RE USING THE DOLLARS MOST
EFFICIENTLY ARE YOU TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT EVIDENCE BASED
STUDENT SUCCESS?
SO CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THAT HOW YOU'RE USING
THE MONEY IN THAT AND AND THE
EVIDENCE BASED STUDENT SUCCESS
YES.
SO -- YOU
KNOW WITH HIGHER EDUCATION --
AND WITH THE COMMUNICATIVE
SPECIFICALLY ME WE HAVE THE
GREAT PRIVILEGE IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE COLLEGES OF
ACCEPTING THE TOP 1100% OF
STUDENTS.
EVERY STUDENT WHO HAS A DESIRE
TO ACCESS CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY IN THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE COLLEGES.
WITH THAT SAID THAT MEANS THAT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
NEEDS THAT APPROACH --
COLLEGES ON ANY GIVEN DAY.
AND SO --
FIRST WE WANT TO TRY TO DIRECT
THE PRECIOUS RESOURCES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS APPROPRIATED. TO
AREAS THAT HAVE THE GREATEST
IMPACT ON OUR STUDENTS IN
BECAUSE OUR STUDENTS OR THE
GATEWAY TO HIGHER EDUCATION.
TO STUDENTS OF COLOR IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT --
THAT WE ARE HALF WAY FOR THEM.
US SO THAT WE CAN REDUCE THE
TIME TO COMPLETION FOR THEM --
OUR STUDENTS COME BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO IMPROVE THEIR ECONOMIC
AND SOCIAL MOBILITY --
AND WHILE OUR COLLEGES DO
EVERYTHING IN THEIR POWER EVERY
DAY TO DO THAT IN MANY CASES THE
WAY THAT WE STRUCTURE
ORGANIZATIONS.
A KEEPS OUR STUDENTS IN OUR
CLASSROOMS IN OUR CAMPUSES FAR
LONGER THAN THAN THEY NEED TO BE.
AND SO WE ARE TRYING TO REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OFCREDITS THAT OUR
STUDENTS ACCUMULATE THAT DON'T
LEAD TO THEIR EAT EDUCATIONAL
GOAL.
OF WE HAVE ENACTED REFORMS THAT
TO ALLOW OUR STUDENTS THE
ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
TRANSFER LEVEL COURSES AS SOON
AS THEY GET OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL.
USING THE MULTIPLE MEASURES
PLATFORM TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT HIGH SCHOOL GPA HIGH
SCHOOL TRANSCRIPTS IS A BETTER
PREDICTOR OF SUCCESS THAN
STANDARDIZED PLACEMENT EXAMS --
WE'RE ALSO --
WORKING WITH OUR COLLEGES --
IMPLEMENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE PROMISE IN ENSURING THAT
NOT ONLY ARE WE WAIVING FEES AND
I THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
POINT BECAUSE CALIFORNIA HEARING
COLLEGES HAVE THE LOWEST FEES IN
THE COUNTRY --
THE COST OF ATTENDING COLLEGE IN
THE CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE
COLLEGES NOT TO WISH WHICH IS A
LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN OUR SISTER
INSTITUTIONS.
ON THE COST OF ATTENDING COLLEGE
IN CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE CAUSES
ACOSTA TRANSPORTATION BOOKS
SUPPLIES.
THE COST OF NOT HAVING TO WILL --
AND BEING ABLE TO TAKE A FULL
LOAD AND GET TO THEIR
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES GROWTH IS
POSSIBLE SO WE'RE WORKING WITH
OUR COLLEGES TO ENSURE THAT.
THE FUNDS UNDER A. B. NINETEEN
THAT WERE APPROPRIATED GO TO
SUPPORT A STUDENT'S ABILITY TO
NOT ONLY GAIN ACCESS TO OUR
COLLEGES.
WITHOUT PAYING A FEE BUT TO GET
THROUGH OUR COLLEGES AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE SO THAT'S A UP A
SMALL SLICE OF SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE DOING SO TO
REDUCE COMPLETION TIME.
IS THAT OFFERING MORE SECTIONS
OF A PARTICULAR SUBJECT --
IN AND THEN WE TALK ABOUT
REDUCING CREDITS THAT --
STUDENTS TAKE BEGIN HAVE BEEN OF
CLASSES THEY DON'T REALLY NEED
DO THEY END UP TAKING THOSE
CLASSES BECAUSE WHAT THEY REALLY
NEED ISN'T AVAILABLE AND IT JUST
TRYING TO STAY.
IN THE RHYTHM SO TO SPEAK BUT
HOW HOW DO WE REDUCE THAT TIME
SPECIFICALLY SAID OPENING MORE
SECTIONS.
I THINK THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION --
SO STUDENTS COME TO COMMITTEE
COLLEGE AND THEY HAVE A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT EDUCATIONAL GOALS
BUT LET'S JUST SAY STUDENT COMES
THE OMMUNICANTS.
WANTING --
TO TRANSFERRED TO THEIR CSU
CAMPUS AS AN ENGLISH MAJOR.
OUR GOAL IN THE GUIDED PATHWAYS
FRAMEWORK IS TO ENSURE THAT FROM
DAY ONE THE DAY THEY HAD THE
CAMPUS THEY HAVE A CLEAR ROADMAP.
TO HOW TO MAKE THAT TRANSFER
HAVE -- SO
FROM DAY ONE WE ARE HELPING
GUIDE THEM WITH THE ROADMAP I
GUIDED PATHWAYS TO ENSURE.
THAT THEY'RE NOT STRAY FROM IT
NOW.
THAT DOESN'T PREVENT A STUDENT
FROM WANTING TO TAKE AN
ADDITIONAL COURSE BECAUSE THEY
FEEL LIKE TAKING AN ADDITIONAL
COURSE BUT IF THEY'RE RECEIVING
FINANCIAL AID AND THEY HAVE TO
HAVE AT LEAST TWELVE UNITS TO
RECEIVE FULL AID.
THEN THEY'RE NOT HAVING TO FIND
COURSES THAT DON'T TRANSFERRED
TO THEIR TO HELP THEM TRANSFER
IS AN ENGLISH MAJOR. TO OUR
COLLEGES REALLY HAVE --
TO RESTRUCTURE THE CLASS
SCHEDULE REALLY THINK ABOUT HOW
TO MAKE THE STUDENT WHERE
THEY'RE AT AND ALSO --
BECAUSE OF AB SEVEN OH FIVE MOVE
THE STUDENT TO A TRANSFER LEVEL
CORES -- IN
ENGLISH AND MATH WITHIN THEIR
FIRST YEAR --
SO THAT IS --
MAY BE A DIFFICULT TASK FOR SOME
OF OUR COLLEGES --
BUT IS A NECESSARY TASK AND IT
DOVETAILS VERY WELL WITH THE
WORDS HAPPY IN THE CSU AROUND
THEIR OWN REMEDIATION REFORM SO
WE HAVE CLEAR EVIDENCE THAT
REMEDIAL EDUCATION THE WAY THAT
WE'VE BEEN APPROACH AND IT DOES
NOT WORK HAS A DETRIMENTAL
IMPACT ON STUDENTS OF COLOR AND
LOW.
INCOME STUDENTS SO WE'RE WORKING
HARD TO ADDRESS THAT AND GET
STUDENTS TO THEIR EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOME AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
VERY GOOD SO I DON'T WANT TO
BELABOR IT BUT DO YOU FEEL LIKE
EVEN IN THE CAMPUSES WHERE IT'S
GOING TO BE DIFFICULT THAT YOU
ARE CHANGING THE STRUCTURE THERE
AND YOU HAVE A PATHWAY FORWARD.
I AM VERY CONFIDENT BECAUSE
WE'VE SEEN TREMENDOUS EVIDENCE
FROM CAMPUSES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
IN A PARTICULARLY AND I KNOW THE
INLAND EMPIRE IS WELL
REPRESENTED ON THIS --
THE COLLEGES IN THE DISTRICT IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE DOING
TREMENDOUS WORK IN THIS REGARD
AND I HAVE FULL CONFIDENCE --
THAT -- THE
WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING IS GOING
TO LEAD TO THOSE IMPROVED
OUTCOMES VERY GOOD THANK YOU
CHANCELLOR OAKLEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THERE WERE ONLY QUESTIONS.
CHANCE TO THE COLLEGE PROMISE
PROGRAM.
THIS IS DESIGNED TO ELIMINATE
THE ENROLLMENT FEES FOR THOSE
STUDENTS WHO PARTICIPATE.
THAT'S CORRECT RIGHT.
THAT'S CORRECT DO YOU HAVE OTHER
PROGRAMS IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM THAT WAIVE FEES
FOR STUDENTS.
SO -- ALL OF
THE FEE WAIVERS ARE CAPTURE IN
THE UMBRELLA OF WHAT WE CALL THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE NO
THERE ARE TWO COMPONENTS THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE.
THERE ARE WHAT WE CALL THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEG PROMISE.
GRANTS WHICH ARE FORMALLY KNOWN
THE BOARD OF GOVERNOR FEE
WAIVERS SO WE WAIVE FEES FOR ALL
LOW INCOME STUDENTS OF STUDENTS
SHOW THAT THERE'S A FINANCIAL
NEED THEY QUALIFY FOR THE FEE
WAIVER THAT WAS IN EFFECT BEFORE.
AB NINETEEN WHAT WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF STUDENTS IN THE SYSTEM.
NEARLY 50% PARTICIPATE IN THAT
FREEWAY FROM THE WAY HOME THEN
THERE'S THE OTHER 50% AND THEN
THERE'S THE OTHER 50% WHICH A.
B..
NINETEEN AUTHORIZED THE USE OF
STATE FUNDS TO WAIVE FEES FOR
ALL FIRST TIME FULL TIME
STUDENTS AND THIS IS WITHOUT
REGARD TO NEED.
THIS IS WITHOUT REGARD TO NEED
HOWEVER TO HAVE NEED WILL
AUTOMATICALLY HAVE THEIR FEES
WAVE SO IN ADDITION TO THOSE LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AB NINETEEN
ALLOWS THE COLLEGES. TO DIRECT
THOSE FUNDS TO WAIVE FEES FOR
STUDENTS WHO DID NOT MEET THAT
THRESHOLD.
THE SECOND THING I WOULD SAY
WHICH IS IMPORTANT IS THAT IF A
COLLEGE FEELS THAT THERE IS AN
ADDITIONAL TYPES OF NEED AT
THEIR COLLEGE THEY CAN USE THOSE
SAME FUNDS AND NOT WAIVE FEES
BUT YOU SOME FOR ANOTHER PURPOSE
THAT THEY FEEL.
WOULD BENEFIT THEIR STUDENTS --
EVEN MORE ALTHOUGH NOT SO THAT
THE MONEY IS NOT RESTRICTED TO A
WAIVER OF ENROLLMENT FEES IT IS
ONLY RESTRICTED TO EITHER A A
FEE WAIVER OR SHOWING EVIDENCE
THAT THAT MONEY IS BEING USED --
TO IMPROVE A STUDENT'S ABILITY
TO SUCCEED SO PRESENTATION
VOUCHERS FOR YES SO FOR EXAMPLE
IF A COLLEGE --
HAS A VERY HIGH A LOW INCOME
COMMUNITY --
WHICH ALREADY QUALIFIES FOR THE
FEE WAIVER.
THEY CAN USE THOSE AB NINETEEN
FUNDS -- FOR
SUPPLEMENTAL SUPPORT IKE
TRANSPORTATION VOUCHERS LIKE
BOOK VOUCHERS --
PROVIDED SOME ADDITIONAL
FINANCIAL LITERACY SUPPORT SO
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT WAYS
IT CAN BE USED BUT ITS PRIMARY
FUNCTION.
IS TO REDUCE THE BARRIER OF FOR
STUDENTS GETTING INTO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE --
REDUCE THE FINANCIAL BARRIER.
SO IT IT SOUNDS LIKE THEN THE
PURPOSE.
IN THE IMPLEMENTATION YOU'RE
GONNA BE DIRECTING THIS MONEY
TOWARD.
THOSE STUDENTS.
WHO HAVE NEED?
THOSE STUDENTS WHO HAVE NEED AND
THE BECAUSE THAT WOULD WHEN YOU
READ IT ON ITS FACE RIGHT IT
SOUNDS LIKE.
THE NEEDY STUDENTS GET WHAT USED
TO BE CALLED THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS WAIVER RIGHT.
AND THEN THOSE WHO DON'T NEED
ANY ASSISTANCE QUALIFY FOR THE
COLLEGE PROMISE PROGRAM MONEY IS
ON THEIR FIRST TIME AND FIRST
TIME STUDENT FULL TIME IN FIRST
FIRST TIME.
BUT NOT NECESSARILY CAN YOU CAN
YOU CAN DIVERT THAT MONEY FOR
TRANSPORTATION VOUCHERS AND THE
LIKE TO THE MOST NEEDY YOU COULD
YOU COULD AND THE OTHER REASON
FOR THE FLEXIBILITY IS THAT
THERE ARE COMMUNITIES --
FOR EXAMPLE YOU KNOW --
LONG BEACH AND STUDENTS AND
BURNED A DINO --
HAVE RECEIVED SIGNIFICANT
PHILANTHROPIC SUPPORT SO WE WANT.
COLLEGES TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO LEVERAGE THEIR PHILANTHROPIC
SUPPORT SO.
WHERE I CAME FROM LONG BEACH THE
COMMUNITY SO AB NINETEEN ALLOWED
LONG BEACH CITY COLLEGE TO ADD
AN ADDITIONAL YEAR?
OF FREE TUITION SO THERE ARE
NUMBER OF WE WANTED TO ENSURE
THAT COMMUNITIES HAD SOME
FLEXIBILITY DEPENDING ON THE
LOCAL SITUATION AND WHO MAKES
THE DECISION AS TO HOW THAT
MONEY IS USED IN THE COLLEGE
PROMISE PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE WHO
DECIDES.
THAT -- ONCE
THE NEEDIEST STUDENTS OR OR
TAKING CARE OF THROUGH THE WHAT
USED TO BE CALLED THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS WAIVER.
THAT THE MONEY IS NOT GOING TO
GO TO THE THE THE TOP 25% IN
TERMS OF ASSETS BUT INSTEAD IS
GOING TO FUND TRANSPORTATION
VOUCHERS AND BOOK OF FEES AND
THE LIKE WHO MAKES THAT DECISION --
THE LOCALLY ELECTED BOARDS OF
TRUSTEES.
IN THOSE AREAS.
NOW WITH RESPECT TO METRICS WHAT.
DOES PROGRAM'S BEEN IN EXISTENCE
THE FIRST YEAR.
YES SO THE THE PROGRAM WAS
FUNDED IN THE LAST BUDGET SO IT
IS.
STILL IN ITS FIRST YEAR --
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE EVIDENCE FROM
PROGRAMS THAT ALREADY BEEN
EXISTENCE OF FOR MANY YEARS THAT
SUGGESTS THAT.
IT HAS A A SIGNIFICANTLY
POSITIVE MOUNT OF HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS --
ATTENDING COLLEGE RIGHT OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL DO YOU HAVE A SET OF
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES THAT WE
HOPE TO ACHIEVE WITH THE PROGRAM.
SO THE ANSWER IS YES PRIMARILY
THE GOALS ARE TO SATISFY THE
GOALS OF THE VISION FOR SUCCESS
SO WE SEE THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
PROMISES A COMPONENT --
AS A VERY POSITIVE --
A STEP IN THE VISION FOR SUCCESS
SO THE VISION FOR SUCCESS HAS
SOME SPECIFIC GOALS FOR EXAMPLE
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
CREDENTIALS EARNED.
A AT A COLLEGE CAMPUS BY A 20%
ANNUAL ANNUALLY INCREASING
TRANSFER BY 35% ANNUALLY --
AS WELL AS CLOSING THE
IT WITHIN TEN YEARS SO.
WE SEE THAT CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
PROMISES A COMPONENT OF THAT
STRATEGY AND WE WILL BE
MEASURING THE IMPACT --
BASED ON THOSE METRICS AND AND
IS THE DATA BEING COLLECTED
CENTRALLY BY YOUR OFFICE OR
HOUSE YES.
IT IS COLLECTED CENTRALLY BY OUR
OFFICE AND REPORTED TO THE BOARD
OF GOVERNORS.
NOW WITH RESPECT TO THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM [inaudible]
WHAT?
WHAT'S MAYBE WE COULD BE MORE
SPECIFIC AS TO THE ISSUES THAT
YOU SEE WITH THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM YOU'VE MENTIONED.
THAT OF COURSE THE COST OF
EDUCATION IS NOT JUST A FEES
INVOLVED BUT THE ASSOCIATED
LIVING EXPENSES AND THE LIKE.
I'M A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT I
GRADUATE I DON'T KNOW WHAT I
WANT TO DO --
A COURSE AROUND FOR A COUPLE
YEARS AND I FINALLY THREE SOUND
LIKE ME.
TELL ME.
I FINALLY FIGURE OUT THAT I'M
GONNA NEED TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL.
TO BE ABLE TO GET A CREDENTIAL
AND GUESTS AND ARE LIVING.
AND I AND ROLL BUT SORT OF CAL
GRANT OPPORTUNITIES DO I HAVE A
ZERO POINT.
SO IF YOU GO TO A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AFTER --
BEING AT A HIGH SCHOOL FOR MORE
THAN ONE YEAR YOU BEGIN TO LOSE
ELIGIBILITY OR IF YOU GO TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AFTER.
A CERTAIN AGE YOU LOSE
ELIGIBILITY --
SO THERE ARE AS WELL AS IF YOU
DON'T HAVE --
HIGH ENOUGH GPA RIGHT I AT
SCHOOL YOU MAY LOSE ELIGIBILITY
SIR AND THEIR NUMBER OF BARRIERS
IN THE WAY AND THAT'S WHY.
PARTICIPATION THE CAL GRANT
SYSTEM FOR COMMITTEE COLLEGE
STUDENTS IS LESS THAN 10% --
SO IT'S BEEN A CHALLENGE --
BECAUSE WE PRIMARILY SERVE
ADULTS STUDENTS AVERAGE AGES
TWENTY FIVE IN OUR SYSTEM --
AND ALSO BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN A
ANYA WE ARE CERTAINLY AT FAULT
FOR CREATING THIS MYTH THAT IS
INEXPENSIVE TO GO TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
BECAUSE OF THE LOW COST OF
TUITION.
BUT OF THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE
ACCESS AND SUCCESS IS DONE
SEVERAL STUDIES THAT SHOW THAT
THE COST OF ATTENDING COLLEGE
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
PARTICIPATION.
IN THE CAL GRANT AND IN THE
FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM.
IT HIS BECOME MORE EXPENSIVE FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT TO
ATTEND.
AND SO THE OTHER REASON IS YOU
COMING OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL IF YOU
CAN'T GET ACCESS TO THE CAL
GRANT SYSTEM.
YOU TEND TO HAVE TO WORK --
OR IF YOU HAVE A FAMILY YOU HAVE
TO CONTINUE TO WORK IN GO PART
TIME SO THAT EXTENDS THE TIME
THAT YOU'RE IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SO. FOR ALL THOSE
REASONS WE FEEL IT'S IMPORTANT
TO RE LOOK AT THE CAL GRANT
SYSTEM AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THEY WOULD REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT.
IN THE CAL GRANT SYSTEM BECAUSE
WERE CERTAINLY NOT TALKING ABOUT.
REDIRECTING FUNDS IN THE CAL
GRANT SYSTEM WE WANT TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO THE CAR BECAUSE IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING IF I JUMP RIGHT
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE OF HIGH
SCHOOL OR MAY BE WAS CERTAINLY
WITH ANY OF YOUR THAT I'M.
AUTOMATICALLY ENTITLED TO A CAL
GRANT OF ONE FLAVOR OR ANOTHER.
YOU YOU ARE CERTAINLY ENTITLED
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE CAN
COMPETITIVE CABINET I MEAN.
AND IF I WAIT TWO OR THREE YEARS
I FALL INTO THE COMPETITIVE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM DONA.
IDIOM AND AGAIN THE NUMBER OF
THOSE IS WHAT THIRTY THOUSAND IN
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM OR SO --
I DON'T HAVE THAT NUMBER OF
THOUGHT MY HEAD BUT IS SOMEWHERE
IN THAT RANGE AND SOMEONE
SUGGESTED TO ME THAT THE NUMBER
OF APPLICANTS. FOR THAT
PARTICULAR CATEGORY THE
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT PROGRAM IS
SOMEWHERE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND THAT'S
PROBABLY AN ACCURATE NUMBER SO
THE THE POPULATION THAT WE ARE
ATTEMPTING AND HAVE BEEN
FOCUSING ON APPEAR IN SACRAMENTO
FOR SOME TIME WITH.
CAREER TECH EDUCATION.
TAKING PEOPLE WHO WERE INSTALLED --
OCCUPATIONS AND AND ALLOWING
THEM TO RE TOOL SO THEY CAN
PARTICIPATE IN THE IN THE MARKET
PLACE IN A IN A BETTER WAY FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
WE HAVE ESSENTIALLY CUT THEM OUT
OF THE TRAFFIC PATTERN WHEN IT
COMES TO CAL GRANT PARTICIPATION
UNLESS THEY FALL WITHIN THE 10%
THAT HAPPENS TO GET.
YES AN AWARD YES AND WE HAVE
VERY LOW PARTICIPATION IN THE
CHARACTER AND SYSTEM.
IN ADDITION TO YOU KNOW IT IS WE
HAVE TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY AS
WELL AS A SYSTEM WE HAVE NOT --
LOOK TO FINANCIAL AID IN THE
SAME WY THE UC AND CSU LOOKS AT
IT I MEAN YOUR OF YOUR STUDENT
GOING TO UC.
YOU'RE IMMEDIATELY ASSAULTED BY
THE OPPORTUNITIES TO BE PACKAGE
FOR FINANCIAL AID AND WE HAVE TO
DO SOMETHING SIMILAR --
WE HAVE TO TAKE FINANCIAL AID
VERY SERIOUS IN OUR IN OUR
SYSTEM AND THAT'S WHY.
WE'RE NOT ONLY ASKING FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE ACCESS
TO THE CAL GRANT SYSTEM BUT WE
ARE ALSO COMMITTING TO
INCREASING.
OUR CAPACITY IN OUR FINANCIAL
FINANCIAL AID OFFICES IN OUR
EXPECTATION THAT WE PACKAGE
STUDENTS AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
FROM DAY ONE WELL I'M NOT BEING
CRITICAL OF YOU OR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM BUT AS A AS A
LEGISLATURE AND CERTAINLY AS THE
ADMINISTRATION I THINK IF WE IF
WE MEAN.
WHAT WE SAY WITH RESPECT TO
HEALTH EDUCATION AND CAREER TECH
EDUCATION AND?
LIFTING PEOPLE OUT OF THESE
STALLED THE OCCUPATIONS IN
CAREER FIELDS AND GIVING THEM.
A LEG UP TO BE SUCCESSFUL WERE
GONNA HAVE TO DO A BETTER JOB.
ON THE CAL GRANT SIDE BY
ALLOWING THEM TO HAVE A HAVE
MORE THAN A 10% CHANCE RIGHT --
TO GET SOME SOME MADE OUT OF THE
SYSTEM TO CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS --
ABSOLUTION ROW HI I CENTER I
WENT TO A CITRUS COLLEGE LOVED
IT A GREAT SCHOOL --
TOOK FIFTEEN UNITS.
A SEMESTER AND THEN AND THERE IN
THE SUMMER SCHOOL I WOULD.
TRY TO TAKE A FEW MORE HOURS.
FORTUNATE TO GET THROUGH IN TWO
YEARS AND I WORK THIRTY TWO
HOURS A WEEK RIGHT YOU KNOW.
ON THE U. KIND OF MAKE IT SOUND
LIKE A NEGATIVE THING I'M TRYING.
TO RIGHT COULD YOU WALK ME
THROUGH THERE BECAUSE BACK IN
THOSE DAYS THEY DIDN'T HAVE
THESE PROGRAMS AND I DON'T THINK
IT WAS A HARDSHIP MAYBE IT
DEVELOP CHARACTER AND ME I'M.
SURE BUT IF YOU WOULD.
SO -- IF THE
FIRST THING I'D SAY IS AT I ALSO.
WORK MY ENTIRE TIME THROUGH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND IT UC
IRVINE --
RAISING A FAMILY AS WELL SO THE
ISSUE IS AND WHETHER OR NOT.
OUR STUDENTS SHOULD --
FIND WAYS TO CONTRIBUTE TO THEIR
EDUCATION THE ISSUE IS THAT THEY
ARE.
PREDOMINATELY ALL OUR TO THE
DETRIMENT OF THEIR OWN EDUCATION
BECAUSE OF THE COST OF ATTENDING
COLLEGE TODAY --
WE HAVE A HUGE --
HOUSING AND SECURITY PER FOOD
AND SECURITY PROBLEMS IN THE
STATE THE COST OF LIVING HAS.
RISEN TREMENDOUSLY CERTAINLY
MORE THAN MY TIME GOING TO BE A
COLLEGE AND AND YES --
MANY OF OUR STUDENTS DO EXACTLY
WHAT YOU DO TODAY.
THE THE CONCERN THAT WE HAVE IS
THAT -- THEY
DO NOT CURRENTLY HAVE ACCESS TO
ADDITIONAL FORMS OF FINANCIAL
AID THAT ALLOW THEM TO WORK AND
TO RECEIVE SOME SUPPORT SO THEY
CAN GET THROUGH AS QUICKLY.
AS POSSIBLE --
SO -- YOU
KNOW. FOR FOR FOR US --
I MEAN WHETHER YOU'RE IN
COMMITTEE COLLEGE --
CS YOUR UC THERE IS AN
EXPECTATION THAT THE FAMILY OR
THE INDIVDUAL OR CONTRIBUTE TO
THEIR EDUCATION WE'RE NOT ASKING
FOR OUR STUDENTS TO BE TREATED
ANY DIFFERENTLY.
WERE ASKING IS THAT THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO ADDITIONAL AID TO HELP
THEM FINISH THEIR EDUCATION AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE A AND TO BE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
ECONOMY AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
WE THINK THAT THAT'S A WISE
INVESTMENT BECAUSE IF THEY'RE IN.
THE WORK FORCE WITHIN THREE
YEARS NOT SIX YEARS THEN THEY'RE
CONTRIBUTING IN A MEANINGFUL WAY
TO THEIR FAMILIES THE OTHER
ISSUE IS.
YOU KNOW WE WERE WERE LIVING%
ENVIRONMENT TODAY WHERE THEIR
DEMAND FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
CREDENTIAL IS MUCH GREATER THAN
IT EVER HAS BEEN IN THE HISTORY
OF OUR ECONOMY --
6465% OF ALL ANGEL.
AND SO WE'RE ASKING A LOT MORE
PEOPLE.
THE COME BACK TO COLLEGE.
IN THE WAY THAT CENTER ROUGH IS
INDICATED AND GET SOME SORT OF A
CREDENTIAL --
SO -- WELL.
WE WE BELIEVE IN AND CERTAINLY
IT'S A CASE BASED ON ALL THE
DATA THAT WE SEE.
THE MAJORITY OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
WORKING IN ARE CONTRIBUTING TO
THEIR EDUCATION BUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS NOT PROVIDING ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR THEM --
IN A SITUATION WHERE THE COST OF
LIVING WHETHER IN THE BAY AREA
AND INLAND EMPIRE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO GROW
EACH AND EVERY DAY.
I THINK.
FOR LET ME SHOULD JUST LET ME
SHIFT TO CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS.
IT'S A SORT OF A PET PEEVE WITH
ME -- OKAY
TO TWELVE OBVIOUSLY HAS SORT OF
A REGIMENTED PERHAPS ANTIQUATED
CUMBERSOME PROCESS --
FOR BUT FIRST IN TIME FIRST IN
LINE I GUESS --
FOR PROJECT MONEY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN THE CAPITAL OUTLAY
OF PROCESS IS A LOT SEEMS TO BE
A LOT DIFFERENT.
AND IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE MUCH
RHYME OR REASON. TO HELP
PROJECTS ARE --
ULTIMATELY SELECTED.
I REALIZE YOU'RE YOU'RE JUST A
COG IN THE WHEEL BUT PERHAPS YOU
COULD.
ADDRESS THAT FOR ME.
WELL -- THE
FIRST IS THAT SOMEONE WHO CAME
FROM A COLLEGE IN WHOSE JOB IT
WAS -- TO
FIND WAYS TO FINANCE CAPITAL
PROJECTS --
YOU KNOW --
WE BECOME VERY ADEPT AT PLAYING
THE GAME OF CAPITAL PER --
AND IN MANY WAYS IT IS SO YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A FORMULA IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICABLE JUST
THAT IS -- A
VESTIGE FROM THE K. TWELVE
SYSTEM -- WE
GO THROUGH A PROCESS EVERY YEAR
TO RANK PROJECTS THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM WE PRESENT THEM TO
OUR BOARD OF GOVERNORS A PERCENT
THEM TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND DETERMINES WHAT
CRITERIA THEY'RE GOING TO USE --
AND WHICH MAY OR MAY NOT.
BE CONSISTENT WITH THE CRITERIA
THAT WE HAVE OUR COLLEGES
WORKING ONAND THEN THAT GOES
BEFORE THE COMMITTEES IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THEN THERE IS A
PROCESS OF ANGLING.
MEMBERS ON COMMITTEES TO TRY AND
ENSURE THAT THEIR PROJECTS ARE
PUT ON THE LIST OR ENSURE THAT
THEY SURVIVE ON THE LIST SO IS A
VERY -- A
DIFFICULT PROCESS ART SO YOU
MEAN.
FOR AS A SYSTEM.
YOU AND YOUR BOARD.
RANK PROJECTS YES USING A
CRITERIA THAT PRESUMABLY RELATES
TO THE CORE MISSION OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SOME FASHION
YES AND THAT LIST IS SUBMITTED.
AND THEN SOMEONE OTHER THAN
EDUCATORS.
RE ORDERS THE LIST YES.%
EARLY HAVING NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE COST OF THE PROJECTS OR THE
BOND MONEY AVAILABLE.
WELL OUT OUT I WON'T I WON'T
COMMENT ON THE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES TO PERSPECTIVE.
FRIENDS I AT WE ACTUALLY.
BUT YES THERE ARE MULTIPLE
PLACES WHERE THOSE PROJECTS ARE
RE ORDERED --
IN WEEK WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS ONCE
THEY GET INTO COMMITTEE HERE
THERE'S ANOTHER REORDERING OR
POTENTIAL REORDERING.
HOW MANY --
SO THE BUDGETS PROPOSING THREE
HUNDRED FORTY ONE MILLION AND
PROP FIFTY WENT ONE FUNDS.
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROJECTS.
I FORGET HOW MUCH MONEY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WAS ALLOCATED
OF THE PROP FIFTY ONE WAS A TWO
TWO BILLION --
SO I'D HAVE TO DOUBLE CHECK ON
THAT NUMBER I DON'T RECALL IT ON
MY HEAD IN ANY EVENT YOU KNOW
HOW THE THE TOTAL NEED IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM VOB THE
PROP FIFTY ONE BOND FUNDS
AVAILABLE --
WELL I KNOW THAT --
THE NUMBER OF PROJECTS AT THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS APPROVED IN
TOTAL IS THE TOTAL WOULD ADDRESS
THE TOTAL AMOUNT AVAILABLE IN
PROP FIFTY ONE WE CAN CERTAINLY
GET YOU THAT THAT.
THAT DOLLARS DOLLAR NUMBER BUT
THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS APPROVED
EVERY PROJECT THAT SHOULD BE
FUNDED BASED ON THE VOTERS
INTENT IN PROFIT.
THANK YOU WE NEED TO WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON THAT WILL FOCUS ON THAT --
I ASSUME A LITTLE LATER IN THE
PROJECT AND I HAVE ONE MORE.
QUESTION AND THEN WE'LL MOVE TO
OUR NEXT PANELIST.
YOU REFERENCE THE ONLINE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
WHAT WHAT LINK WHAT LINKAGE ARE
YOU DEVELOPING BETWEEN YOUR
ONLINE EDUCATION EFFORTS?
AND THE EMPLOYER COMMUNITY RIGHT --
TO DETERMINE THAT WHAT JOB
SKILLS ARE NEEDED.
OUT THERE.
AND MAKE SURE AND ENSURE THAT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROGRAMS
IF YOU'RE DESIGNING.
MEET THOSE NEEDS BECAUSE I THINK
WE'VE DISCUSSED THIS BUT THAT'S
ONE OF MY FRUSTRATIONS OVERALL
WITH THE CREW TECH EDUCATION
SYSTEM IN OUR STATE.
IS.
ALTHOUGH IT'S SOMEWHAT ANECDOTAL
BUT THE EDUCATION CONSORTIUM.
SEEM TO BE WORKING WELL.
BUT THERE SEEMS TO BE A
DISCONNECT REGIONALLY WITH THE
EMPLOYERS AND JOB SKILLS
INVENTORY TO CONNECT JOB SKILLS
NEEDED WITH THE EDUCATION
CONSORTIUM THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
BEING DESIGNED.
SO MY QUESTION RIGHTS TO DO WITH
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IN THE ONLINE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AND I AGREE WITH YOUR ASSESSMENT
SENATOR AND AND OBVIOUSLY MY
MAILLET A SOLUTION TO THAT FOR
LITTLE BIT A CAUSE ME A LITTLE
BIT HE LAST YEAR BUT BUT I DO
BELIEVE THAT --
WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY --
INITIATIVES IN PROCESS ONE AS
YOU JUST MENTIONED IS IS A NEW
ONLINE COLLEGE WHICH IS --
AIM TO BE A COMPANY BASED
PLATFORM THAT PULLS TOGETHER
BOTH HIRING MANAGERS AND THE
INCUMBENT OR DISPLACED WORKERS
SO.
THE WAY THAT WE ARE ADDRESSING
THAT WITHIN THAT CONTEXT AND
WITHIN THAT CONTEXT IT IS OUR
INTENT TO THEN EXPANDED
THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM.
IS IN I'LL TAKE ONE EXAMPLES --
IN HEALTH CARE --
WE HAVE BROUGHT TOGETHER A
COALITION OF HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS LIKE DIGNITY OPTUM
KAISER AND OTHERS.
pSEIU -- AND
THE UNITED HEALTHCARE WORKERS
AND PUT THEM AT THE SAME TABLE --
LOOKED AT THE JOB SAID IN THE
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER THE
EMPLOYER IS EITHER --
WHERE THERE'S A GAP OVER THE IN
FUTURE YEARS AND THEN --
WORKING BACKWARDS LOOKING AT THE
SKILLS THAT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
AND THEN BUILDING A MODULE FOR
THE WORKER AND THEN TESTING THAT
OUT WITH THE WORKER.
AND ALONG THE LINE ENSURING THAT
THERE IS A CLEAR SIGNALING
MECHANISM BETWEEN.
THE EDUCATION THAT THE WORKERS
BEING PROVIDED AND DEMONSTRATING
SUCCESS IN AND THE HIRING
MANAGER NICE A HIRING MANAGER
BECAUSE YOU KNOW HR OFFICES
AREN'T ALWAYS HIRING MANAGERS
HIRING MANAGERS OF PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND SUPERVISORS MANAGERS WHO
ACTUALLY MAKE HIRING DECISIONS
AND HAVE.
A NUMBER OF BIASES THAT WE NEED.
TO TO SMOOTH OUT SO THE LINK THE
THE CHALLENGE THAT WE SEE IS THE
TIME IT TAKES FOR THAT SIGNALING
TO OCCUR AND IN MANY CASES ARE
OUR CURRENT PROGRAMS ARE NOT
EITHER SIGNALING CLEARLY OR
TAKING TOO MUCH TIME. TO CATCH
UP WITH THE SKILLS THAT THE
EMPLOYERS ARE LOOKING.
FOR THE ECONOMY IS MOVING MUCH
FASTER TODAY THAN IT DID FIVE
TEN YEARS AGO.
SO WE'RE USING THE ONLINE
COLLEGE TO BUILD OUT --
A CASE STUDY FOR HOW IT COULD BE
DONE FASTER AT ALL HUNDRED
FOURTEEN OF OUR COLLEGES SO AND
THAT'S HOW WE'RE GOING TO
APPROACH THIS.
WELL THAT COULD IMPROVE OUR
REGIONAL COURTEOUS EDUCATION
EFFORTS AS WELL I LOOK FORWARD
THE RESULT.
SO DO I THANK YOU [inaudible]
CAUSING FURTHER.
THANK YO THANK YOU CHESTER
WHITE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
I WAS GONNA SAY GOOD MORNING BUT
IT'S ALMOST WELL GOOD GOOD MID
MORNING EVEN A BETTER ONE OF
MIKE SUBCOMMITTEES BEFORE.
WE SERVE DINNER.
ORTEGA CHICKEN SALAD PLEASE AND
GLASS OF RED WINE.
THANK YOU CHAIR OFF INTO THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YOU TODAY I THE GOVERNOR'S WAS
FIRST BUDGET PROPOSAL REPRESENTS
A BOLD AND HISTORIC COMMITMENT.
TO INVEST IN HIGHER EDUCATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY.
WE ARE APPRECIATIVE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL INDICATES IS
RECOGNITION OF OUR CAREFUL
STEWARDSHIP OF STATE FUNDS.
IN THE SUCCESSES THAT WE'VE BEEN
HAVING WITH RESPECT TO STUDENT
ACCESS TO A QUALITY PROGRAMS AND
TO GETTING STDENTS SO TO DEGREE
COMPLETION.
BUT MORE THAN AND INVESTMENT I
THINK HIS PROPOSED BUDGET
REFLECTS A SHARED VISION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY AND
IN ITS CRITICAL ROLE.
IN HELPING CALIFORNIA COULD
CREATE AND REALIZES BRIGHTEST
FUTURE.
DIVISION THAT HAS BEEN
CONSISTENTLY SUPPORTED BY THIS
COMMITTEE AND I THANK YOU FOR
THAT.
TODAY I AM PLEASED TO REPORT
THAT -- CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY IT IS VISION IS
BEING REALIZED IN REALLY
CREATIVE IN AND INDEED HISTORIC
WAYS.
OF MANY EXAMPLES LIKE IT'S WE
JUST FOCUS ON ONE THAT IS A
GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IT PROVIDES
PERHAPS THE MOST COMPELLING
EVIDENCE HE WE LAUNCH THISIN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WITH.
AGGRESSIVE AMBITIOUS GOALS WITH
RESPECT TO IMPROVING STUDENT
GRADUATION RATES WELL
ELIMINATING EQUITY CRAPS AMONG
OUR STUDENTS PARTICULARLY FROM
THOSE WHO COME FROM UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES.
AND WHO ARE CAL GRANT RECIPIENTS
COMPARED TO OTHERS.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN WE INVESTED SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN OUR
GREAT INITIATIVE.
WHICH RESULTED IN A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY ADDITIONAL TENURE TRACK
FACULTY. TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED ADDITIONAL COURSE
SECTIONS ONE HUNDRED ADDITIONAL
ACADEMIC ADVISORS.
AS WELL AS THE DEVELOPMENT OF
NEW STUDENT ACADEMIC SUPPORT
PROGRAMS.
SAID ANOTHER WAY JUST GOT NINETY
THOUSAND MORE REAR ENDED SEATS
DURING THAT SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
YEAR.
WE ANTICIPATED TO SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION THAT YOU PROVIDED US.
LAST YEAR FOR THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
WELL OUR CAMPUSES TO CONTINUE
THESE TRENDS.
THANKS TO THIS STRATEGIC
INVESTMENT OF OF FUNDS IN AN
UNWAVERING RELENTLESS FOCUS ON
OUR INITIATIVE.
SOME KEY CHANGES ARE EDUCATION
POLICIES IN OUR OUR AMBITIOUS
GOALS ARE ACTUALLY PROVING TO BE
ATTAINABLE.
IN THIS LAST JUNE IN OUR LAST
MAJOR GRADUATION WE GRADUATED --
THE LARGEST NUMBER OF STUDENTS
IN THE HISTORY OF THE UNIVERSITY.
OUR SYSTEM WHY GRADUATION RATES
ARE ALSO AT ALL TIMES HIGHS IN
THE HISTORY OF THE UNIVERSITY.
ARE FOR YOUR GREAT HAS INCREASED
FOR FIRST TIME FULL TIME
STUDENTS BY SIX PERCENTAGE
POINTS.
A TWO YEAR GRADUATION RATE FOR
TRANSFER STUDENTS FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES JUMPED BY 7%
AND I THANK YOU LLOYD AND HIS
COLLEAGUES FOR GIVING US SO WELL
PREPARED STUDENTS.
AND THE NUMBER OF BACHELOR'S
DEGREES AWARDED IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WAS ALSO A RECORD
NUMBER ONE THOUSAND AND FIVE
FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE AT
AN INCREASE OF SIX THOUSAND SO
OVER LAST THE YEAR BEFORE.
AND THIRTEEN THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN DEGREES OVER
THE YEAR BEFORE THAT.
ME NEITHER STUNNING NUMBERS WHEN
YOU STOP AND THINK ABOUT IT IN
WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT DEGREES WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT DEGREES WERE
ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT DREAMS.
DREAMS FOR THE STUDENT IN YOUR
FAMILY IN OUR COMMUNITY.
EQUALLY IF NOT IMPORT MORE
IMPORTANT WE'RE STARTING TO SEE
SIGNIFICANT DECREASES IN THE
EQUITY OUT.
IN VERY SIGNIFICANT WAYS.
IN THE PAST YEAR ALONE THE GAP --
FOR UNDERSERVED STUDENTS OF
COLOR HAS SHRUNK BY NEARLY TWO
FULL PERCENTAGE POINTS OF THIS
IS A BIG LEFT IN A TO WORK IN
PROGRESS --
WE HAVE A MUCH MORE TO DO BUT IS
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
AFTER THIS RELENTLESS FOCUS --
LIMóN DECREASING THAT EQUITY
GAP AT A TIME THEY WERE ACTUALLY
IN ROLLING MORE MORE STUDENTS
WHO COME FROM UNDERSERVED
BACKGROUNDS AND OUR PELL GRANT
RECIPIENTS.
SO IT'S REALLY QUITE A
REMARKABLE ACHIEVEMENT IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE.
THIS IS INDEED HISTORIC PROGRESS
THE MORE THAN ADDED MOMENTUM.
MOMENTUM MADE BY OUR VERY
SKILLED AND DEDICATED AND
PASSIONATE FACULTY AND STAFF.
THE HARD WORK OF OUR STUDENTS IN
THE CAMPUS LEADERS ACADEMIC AND
AND AND BUSINESS LEADERS ARE
HELPING MAKE THIS HAPPEN.
IT ALSO SHOWS A RETURN ON THE
INVESTMENT ON A DIVIDEND REALLY
TO THE INVEST WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
HAS MADE IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY.
NO THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET WILL ALLOW THIS MOMENTUM
TO BUILD.
OF THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION IN
RECURRING FUNDING HE IS PROPOSAL
ALLOWS TO PROVIDE FAIR
COMPENSATION TO ARE MORE THAN
FIFTY THOUSAND FACULTY AND STAFF
WHO WORK AS I JUST SAID SO
DILIGENTLY TO HELP STUDENTS
SUCCEED.
AND PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY
LEARNING IN IN DISCOVERY
ENVIRONMENT.
IT'LL EXPAND ACCESS TO SERVER IN
ADDITIONAL SEVEN THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED STUDENTS.
AND IT WILL CONTINUE TO INVEST
IN THE PROVEN RESEARCH SUPPORTED
EVIDENCE BASED STRATEGIES OF
STUDENT SUCCESS THAT UNDERPIN
OUR GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
IN THE TWO HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDS FOR OUR CAPITAL NEEDS WILL
HELP ENSURE THAT.
WE CONTINUE TO MAKE PROGRESS ON
A PROVIDING STUDENTS WITH TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY CLASSROOMS AND
LABORATORIES.
WE CAN DO MORE AND QUITE FRANKLY
WE MUST DO MORE IN CALIFORNIA.
A NEARLY HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOL GRADS A
DIVERSE GROUP OF APPROXIMATELY
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND YOUNG
CALIFORNIANS.
WAS SATISFIED THIS YEAR'S USE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SYSTEM
WIDE WE HAVE THE PHYSICAL
CAPACITY.
IN HONEY IN ART TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES FOR AN ADDITIONAL SIXTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS.
AND WE'RE THIS BUDGET TO INCLUDE
THE INVESTMENT OF SEVENTY
MILLION. SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
REQUESTED FOR A GRAD INITIATIVE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAS FORTY
FIVE MILLION TAKEN NOT.
SEVENTY FIVE WE ARE CONFIDENT
THAT WE COULD CONTINUE TO
DEMONSTRATE EXTRAORDINARY
RESULTS I HAVE HIGHLIGHTED A
JUST A FEW MINUTES AGO.
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY REMAINS
FIRMLY COMMITTED TO PROVIDING
ALL QUALIFY CALIFORNIANS THE
OPPORTUNITIES MADE POSSIBLE BY
HIGHER EDUCATION.
IN ON A MASSIVE SCALE WOULD
PROVIDE PEOPLE TO MAKE
MEANINGFUL CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
STATE'S ECONOMY AND FUTURE
PROSPERITY.
THE SCOPE OF OUR MISSION
REQUIRES A ROBUST FINANCIAL
COMMITMENT FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
REPRESENT JUST SUCH A COMMITMENT.
AND WE FULLY SUPPORT HIS BUDGET
RECOMMENDATION.
BUT BE CLEAR WE ALSO STAND READY
AND WOULD WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO ADMIT EVEN
FURTHER ADDITIONAL STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR USED TO FULLY
FUND OUR ENROLLMENT GROWTH IN
GRADUATION INITIATIVE BUDGET
REQUESTS.
AND I DON'T WANT US TO LEAVE MY
BY TWENTY THIRTY WERE LOOKING IN
CALIFORNIA AT A DEGREE DROP US A
MILLION DEGREES BACCALAUREATE
DEGREES SHORT OF WHAT THE
ECONOMY AND SOCIETY WILL NEED.
IN.
TWENTY THIRTY IT AND IF WE IN
OUR SHARED TO CSU IS HALF THAT
NUMBER SO WE HAVE TO UP OUR GAME
BY HAVING THE ABILITY TO PRODUCE
AN ADDITIONAL.
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND BASHERS
DEGREES BETWEEN NOW AND TWENTY
THIRTY MY QUESTION REALLY IS A
POLICY QUESTION FOR YOU.
SENATOR IS IF WE DON'T INVEST
NOW IN A STRONG ECONOMY WE
CERTAINLY WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
ANSWER THIS CLARION CALL.
A TO THE DETRIMENT OF CALIFORNIA
INTO THE DECK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YES I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE GRATEFUL
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND IS OF BREATH OF
FRESH AIR IN THE HIGHER
EDUCATION --
ARENA THIS YEAR GRATEFUL IS NOT
A TERM WE HERE ON THIS BUILDING
VERY OFTEN SO WE DO APPRECIATE
THAT WITH RESPECT TO THE
ENROLLMENT INCREASE --
AND THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
SIXTY TWO MILLION AN INCREASE OF
SEVEN THOUSAND STUDENTS AND SEE
ISSUE WHAT WHAT WERE YOUR PLANS
FOR THE OR YOUR BOARDS PLAN WITH
RESPECT --
TO ENROLLMENT INCREASES IN THE
COST OF THAT MAYBE YOU MENTIONED
AND I MISS MISS I DID MENTION IT
SPECIFICALLY NUMERICALLY WE WE
SOUGHT TO INCREASE OUR ROOMS BY
5% INSTEAD OF A AND THE GOVERNOR
IS PROPOSING 2%.
SO IF WE WERE --
TO A BENEFIT BY OF FOR THIS
THINKING IN CONVERSATION ABOUT
THAT HE WOULD ADD. TO GO FROM
ULD
ABOUT NINETEEN A APPROPRIATIONS.
OF FOR EVERYONE PERCENT WE HAD --
THREE THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED STE
THE STUDENT FULL TIME STUDENT
SAID FTS AND THAT WOULD TAKE IT
FROM. SEVEN THOUSAND TO ABOUT A
LITTLE OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND
YEAR THIS YEAR AND GO FROM SIXTY
TWO MILLION TO NINETY MILLION TO
GET YOU WHERE
YOUR STRATEGIC PLAN SAYS YOU
NEED TO BE IN ORDER TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF OF THE JOB
MARKET IN THE FUTURE.
IT WOULD IT WOULD ADD NINETY
MILLION TO THE SIXTY TWO SO HAS
NINETY MILLION YES IT'S A DISK
IT'S FOR EVERYONE PERCENTAGE
ROUGHLY THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS.
THE FOOD WAS 4% IT WOULD YOU
KNOW SO WHATEVER WE END UP BEING
ABLE TO DO WERE.
OUR FACULTY ARE PHYSICAL
CAPACITIES READY WILLING AND
ABLE TO DO THIS WE JUST NEED TO
PERSONNEL THE FACULTY AND
ACADEMIC SUPPORT FOLKS. TO BE
ABLE TO DELIVER TO THAT --
TO THAT LEVEL SO SIXTY TWO
MILLION FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY TWO
MILLION VERSUS SIXTY TWO MILLION
GIVE OR TAKE YES AND WE CAN GET
PRECISE NUMBERS. TO TO YOU AND
YOUR STAFF.
NOW WITH RESPECT TO THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
THE BUT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGETS
FORTY FIVE MILLION IN YOUR
STRATEGIC PLAN I GUESS TALKS
ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE MILLION WHAT
WHAT WOULD SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DO VERSUS THE FORTY FIVE MILLION.
AND MAYBE YOU MENTION THAT MY
MISTER APOLOGIZE TO THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE IS A WAY
IN WHICH WE BUILD CAPACITY AGAIN
BY MORE FACULTY ACADEMIC SUPPORT
MORE COURSES.
MORE EXTRACURRICULAR ACADEMIC
EXPERIENCES IN LIKE --
SO WHEN WE MODEL WHEN WE
LAUNCHED THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN WE DID A VERY
SOPHISTICATED ANALYSIS OF EACH
OF THE TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES
HISTORY.
AND CAPACITIES.
WE WENT DISAGGREGATED THE DATA
NEEDED BY CAMPUS BY CAMPUS.
THE GOOD SAN LUIS OBISPO LOOKED
AT STANFORD OR DEAL WITH THE SAN
DIEGO XTERRA.
AND THEN WE ADD INS CREATED
STRETCH GOALS THAT WITH THE
RIGHT LEVEL OF INVESTMENT.
EVERYBODY AGREED COULD BE MET.
SO WE'VE BEEN AGGREGATED THAT
BACK UP AND THAT'S THE GRANT IS
SHOULD WE TALK ABOUT MOVING FOR
YOUR RATES FIVE YOUR RATING
CENTER TO THE NUMBERS YOU KNOW
ABOUT.
BUT IT WAS ALSO A SIX YEAR
INVESTMENT THAT EVERY YEAR OVER
THE COURSE OF SIX YEARS WE WOULD
INVEST SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
IN ORDER TO MEET THAT.
AND SO WE'RE NOW --
SEEKING YEAR THREE OF THE SERIES
OF INVESTMENTS TO TO REACH THAT
GOAL.
IF WE DON'T.
GET SEVENTY FIVE MILLION FOR THE
PROJECT.
THEY'RE NOT AN ISSUE WILL BE
DOWN REGULATED.
IN A SORT OF SUCCESS THAT I'VE
BEEN SPEAKING ABOUT ON A
GRADUATION RATES --
EQUITY GAPS WILL BE DIMINISH.
YOU MEAN YOU MAY NOT HAVE THE
DATED TODAY BUT I WOULD LIKE --
I'M SURE SOMEONE CAN --
CAN PUT TOGETHER SOME DATA OF
SOME IMPACT DATA.
UNDER THE LEASE PROJECT IMPACTED
ON THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN FORTY
FIVE MILLION SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION WITH RESPECT TO THE
IMPACT ON THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE I THINK THAT WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL.
INFORMATION TO HAVE SO.
THAT THE FOLKS OF THE TO FOLKS
AROUND HERE IN THE FOLKS
DOWNSTAIRS CAN DO A COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS ON THAT INVESTMENT.
YEAH THEY'RE TO BE CLEAR
CONSEQUENCE ELEVEN YEARSTWO
THINGS IN THE GRANT INITIATIVE
TO COME TOGETHER.
AND WE'LL WE'LL PUT AN ANALYSIS
TOGETHER OF FOR YOU AND OTHERS.
IT'S NOT ONLY FOR US TO DO OUR
HEAVY LIFTING ON IMPROVING
GRADUATION RATES.
BUT IT'S ALSO BY GIVING MORE
STUDENTS IN THE UNIVERSITY WHO
BENEFIT BY THAT EFFORT. TO THE
MATHEMATICAL.
RESULT OF DOING BETTER IN TERMS
OF TIME TO DEGREE AND DEGREE
COMPLETION.
TIMES MORE STUDENTS AVAILING OF
THAT OPPORTUNITY THAT LEADS TO
THE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS BY.
TWENTY THIRTY THAT THE STATE
NEEDS AND SO YOU KNOW WE COULD
DO THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE AN
INCREASE OUR GRADUATION RATES.
AS WERE DOING THE WILL HAVE MORE
STUDENTS TO BENEFIT BY THAT WILL
MISS THE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
TO TREAT ACOMBINATION OF THE
TWO AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE.
OF PUT FORWARD A 5% REQUEST FOR
ENROLLMENT AND WE PLAN TO DO
THAT FOR THE NEXT FOUR YEARS IN
A ROW I ACTUALLY GREW THE
UNIVERSITY OVER 20% UNDERSTAND
IT'S AN INTEGRATED PROCESS HERE.
IT IS AN INTEGRATED PROCESS THAT
WITH WAS MAYBE YOU'VE TOUCHED ON
THIS AS WELL I SEE THE BUDGET --
THE BUT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
HAS A RATHER.
SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY GIVEN THE
ISSUE. TO REVIEW A OF A
POTENTIAL --
NEW CSU CAMPUS --
AND I I KNOW ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES AS AN INTEREST IN.
ANOTHER SEE ISSUE CAMPUS IN
ANOTHER PART OF THE STATE.
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS WITHIN
[inaudible]
SEE ISSUE.
CAN YOU CAN YOU TALK BRIEFLY
ABOUT THAT TO ME. TO PUT IN
PERSPECTIVE.
OUR FACILITIES A COUPLE JUST
GOOD SOUND BITES WE CAN GET YOU
MUCH MORE DETAIL YOUR OFFICE MAY
ALREADY HAVE IT.
I THINK OF 60% OF OUR BUILDING
INVENTORY IS THIRTY YEARS OR
OLDER.
AND I THINK SOMETHING LIKE 50%
OR OVER FORTY FIVE YEARS OLD.
IF YOU IF YOU WANT TO VISUALIZE
HOW MANY BUILDINGS WE HAVE.
IMAGINE A FOOTBALL FIELD.
IMAGINE ONE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED FOOTBALL FIELDS.
THAT'S THE SIZE OF THE
FACILITIES AT THE UNIVERSITY --
SO THE OLD AND THERE'S A LOT OF
IT -- OUR
STAFF UNDER EXECUTIVE ICE YET TO
REALLY A AND VICE SAN JUAN.
HAVE A BIG ANALYTICAL UP.
MACHINE ROLE LOOKS AT THESE
FACILITY NEEDS LOOKS AT THE
USAGE OR AGE.
ALL THE OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
DION GLAMOUR STUFF OF EACH BACK
IN.
WATER IN GENERAL.
SO WE HAVE A HUGE LIST OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF THINGS THAT NEED
ATTENTION.
AND IF YOU ADD UP THE DOLLAR
AMOUNT FOR THAT IN TODAY'S
DOLLARS IT'S FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS.
FOR BUILDING A TO BE.
AND SO WHEN WE WHEN WE MAKE
REPLIED TO GET TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TOWARDS
THAT.
WE HAVE A MUCH BIGGER HILL TO
CLIMB HERE.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT ALSO FOR A
FOR ALL OF US POLICY ISSUE FOR
THE STATE IS.
THESE ARE ASSETS OF THE STATE IS
INVESTED IN OVER.
OVER A LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
AND IF YOU LEAD A BUILDING GET
TO SUCH A POINT WHERE YOU CAN'T
RE HABIT IT'S MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE OF COURSE TO REBUILD
THOSE BUILDINGS IT. EIGHT
HUNDRED OR NINE HUNDRED DOLLARS
A SQUARE FOOT.
SO OF THERE ARE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE'RE HAVING WITH RESPECT
TO THINKING ABOUT A GENERAL
OBLIGATION BOND OR SOMETHING OF
THIS NATURE.
TO ACTUALLY TAKE ON THE FACILITY
ISSUE BECAUSE OUR STUDENTS.
A NEED DESERVES THE STATE
EXPECTS US TO HAVE LEARNING AND
DISCOVERY FACILITIES THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY SOURCE TUNE TO
LEARNING IN.
IN IN THE RIGHT ENVIRONMENT.
SO -- ONE
TIME FUNDING IT DID WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED IS HELPFUL
BUT THERE'S A MUCH BIGGER ISSUE
HERE THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
WORKING WITH YOU AND OTHERS ON
TO FIND A SOLUTION TO WELL AS
YOU KNOW THE CAR UNFORTUNATELY
CALIFORNIA BUDGET GOES UP AND
DOWN.
AND GENERAL FUND AVAILABILITY
GOES UP AND DOWN HAS IS.
ZERO THE STRIKE TEAM THAT'S BEEN
FOR I'M SURE INSIDE YOUR
ORGANIZATION YOU YOU STUDY THESE
ISSUES AND DEBATE THEM AND TRY
TO FIGURE THEM OUT BUT IS THERE.
BEEN A LARGER STRIKE TEAM FORMED
TO DISCUSS.
HIGHER EDUCATION INFRASTRUCTURE
IN THE STATE TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE HOW WE GET THE MONEY
THAT WE NEED TO DO AND OVER WHAT
PERIOD OF TIME IN ORDER TO FIX
THE INFRASTRUCTURE PROBLEMS THAT
WE HAVE NOT ONLY AT C. ISSUE BUT
I'M SURE.
YOU RECEIVE CALIFORNIA HAS THE
SAME WELL LIT THE SECTORS HAVE
BEEN WORKING AND TALKING
TOGETHER NON PRESIDENT AWAYS
FROM THIS ISSUE --
WERE OF THE THREE OF US ARE ALL
PART OF A GROUP CALLED THE
EDUCATION ROUNDTABLE THAT.
CAME OUT OF THE GOVERNOR BROWN
ADMINISTRATION WERE WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT OF ALL THE THINGS
CAN ALONG WITH.
WITH THE TO PRINT AND THURMOND
UP ALONG WITH ALL OF THE THINGS
ARE CONFRONTING THE EDUCATION
ECOSYSTEM AND FACILITIES. FOR
THE UC AND CSU HE'LL HAVE --
NOT HAD A GENERAL OBLIGATION
BOND FOR EXAMPLE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX SO WE HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN THEN DIVERTING
OPERATING FUNDS TO DEBT SERVICE.
TO DO THE NECESSARY MAINTENANCE
ON THE WORST OF THE WORST.
THAT IS NOT A SUSTAINABLE PLAN
FOR US UP.
ONLY SUSTAINABLE FOOD IF WE
DECREASE OUR ENROLLMENT AND STOP
THIS GRADUATION IS WOULD TAKE
CARE OF OUR BUILDINGS OPERATING
FUNDS.
SEEMS TO US THAT'S NOT IN THE
BEST LONG TERM OR EVEN MEDIUM
TERM INTERESTS OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S WHY THE IDEA DISCUSSION
WITH CENTER GLAZER WITH OTHERS
WITH RESPECT TO A BOND IN THE
NEAR FUTURE MAKES SENSE TO US
THAT IS A WORK IN PROGRESS.
THERE IS INTEREST BOTH POLITICAL
AND ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONAL
INTEREST IN DOING SOMETHING HAS
ONCE HAVE YOU BEEN DISCUSSING
THAT ISSUE WITH FIRST
[inaudible]
FOUR YES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHANCELLOR.
I WANTED IF I MAY JUST.
ONE I WISH.
TO SENATOR MORALE WAS HERE YOU
KNOW TALKING ABOUT BUILDING
CHARACTER WHEN WE WERE STUDENTS --
I WAS GOING TO COMMENT THAT HE
WAS A CHARACTER BUT I DECIDED I
BETTER NOT HE'S PROBABLY
LISTENING TO USE.
SO BACK IN THE DAY. HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS A MONTH. TO
LIVE.
IS A STUDENT. FIFTY DOLLARS A
SEMESTER IN TUITION AND FEES CAL
STATE.
OF MY BOOKS I JUST ACTUALLY KEPT
A COUPLE IN THERE MYMY SCIENCE
BOOKS WERE.
SEVEN NINETY FIVE HE HAVE OF
FIVE BOOKS TO TERMS SO.
AND IN GAS WAS TWENTY CENTS A
GALLON.
AND FOOD WELL FOOD AND BEER WAS
THREE AND A BOTTOM.
MR C. ADD UP --
ALL AT MONEY IN AND YOU SAY OKAY
I GOT A JOB FOR TWENTY HOURS A
WEEK IT'S THREE DOLLARS AN HOUR.
NINE HUNDRED BUCKS I WOULD PAY
FOR WHAT I JUST SAID.
YOU DO THE SAME MATH TODAY SAME
TWENTY HOURS WORKING SAY IT'LL
TEN OR ELEVEN DOLLARS AN HOUR.
EVEN FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR
WOULD YOU PLUG IN THE COSTS THAT
I JUST DID.
YOU'RE AT ABOUT THE 30% COVERAGE
LEVEL.
INTO THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN.
TODAY'S WORLD AND THE WORLD IN
WHICH YOU AND I GREW UP IN.
SO THE THE TO THE NOTION OF
THESE ADDED COSTS AND AND PEOPLE
THAT ARE WORKING HARD IS THIS
REALLY SORT OF A METHOD.
WE GET FROM OUR OWN EXPERIENCES
WHICH ARE NOT RELEVANT FOR THE
MILLENNIALS TODAY ABSOLUTELY GAS
WAS THIRTY FIVE CENTS A GALLON
AND MY FOOD BUDGET IN LAW SCHOOL
WAS FORTY DOLLARS A MONTH.
NOT SO TODAY YOU'RE PRETTY YOUR
YOUR OVER THE TOP AND YOU'RE
LIVING THE HIGH LIFE.
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU
CANCER SIR THE MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE --
AGAIN I'M NOT A NATION BROS FROM
THE CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER FOR
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA I
AM VERY PLEASED TO BE HERE WITH
CANCERS WHITE IN OAKLEY --
TO DISCUSS HIGHER EDUCATION
SPECIFICALLY THE BUDGET FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
ARE THE MASTER PLAN ENVISIONS
UNIQUE ROLES FOR EACH OF THE
THREE PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEMS IN CALIFORNIA AND YET --
TODAY HAS MORE IN COMMON THAN
EVER FOR US TO WORK TOGETHER AND
I AM PLEASED TO REPORT THAT THE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH --
CHANCES WHITE IN OAKLEY IN THEIR
TEENS --
CONTINUE TO STRENGTHEN AND
DEEPEN OR ALL COMMUNITY
COLLABORATION ON POLICY --
STRATEGY AND OPERATIONS --
TO ENHANCE YOU KNOW EDUCATION
RESEARCH AND PUBLIC SERVICE
OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA.
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU CHAIR ROTH
AND YOUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
SENATE FOR THE INCREASE FUNDING
ARE THE UNIVERSITY HAS ENJOYED
IN RECENT YEARS --
THE FUNDS PROVIDED BY THE STATE
SUPPORT OUR KEY PRIORITIES THAT
WE ALL SHARE --
EDUCATING MORE CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS CONDUCTING GROUND
BREAKING RESEARCH ENHANCE
KNOWLEDGE AND SUPPORT INVASION
AND PROVIDING A PUBLIC SERVICE.
ARE WE ARE ENCOURAGING
APPRECIATIVE AS MY COLLEAGUES
ARE OF GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S BUDGET
INTRODUCTION --
WHICH IS A SOLID DOWN PAYMENT ON
UC'S CON YOU DREAM.
I YESTERDAY EVENING --
ARE PRESENT CHEN AN APOLOGY AND
ANNOUNCED SHE WILL NOT SEEK A
TUITION INCREASE FOR THE
NINETEEN TWENTY ACADEMIC YEAR
FOR THE UC BOARD OF REGNTS --
THIS MARKS THE SEVENTH YEAR IN
THE PAST --
EIGHT WITHOUT IN STATE TUITION
INCREASE AT YOU SEE.
ARE KEEPING YOU SEE AFFORDABLE
FOR OUR STUDENTS WHILE UPHOLDING
THE PROMISE OF A QUALITY
EDUCATION REQUIRES A PARTNERSHIP
IN STATE INVESTMENT --
I DO WANT TO REMIND THE
COMMITTEE THAT HOLDING TUITION
FLAT.
MEANS THAT YOU SEE HAS LESS
INSTITUTIONAL AID TO DISTRIBUTE
TO OUR OUR LOWEST INCOME
STUDENTS FOR THEIR LIVING
EXPENSES AS CANCER WHY JUST
ARTICULTED.
CURRENTLY WE TAKE A ONE THIRD OF
OUR TUITION REVENUE AND WE
RETURN IT AS H. R. NEEDIEST
STUDENTS.
AND THIS AMOUNT IS NOT GROWING.
AND THIS EIGHT PRIMARILY COVERS
COSTS ABOVE AND BEYOND TUITION
INCLUDING THE RISING COSTS FOR
HOUSING.
FOOD TRANSPORTATION AND AND
SUPPLIES.
I JOIN OUR MOST RECENT ACADEMIC
YEAR A 57% OF ALL OF OUR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATES RECEIVE GRANT OR
SCHOLARSHIP ASSISTANCE OF FULLY
COVERED.
THEIR TUITION AND MANDATORY
SYSTEM WIDE AYE AYE CHARGES SO
THIS SUB --
EXTRA MONEY IS USED TO SUPPORT
THOSE I TUITION.
HOLDEN TWITTER FLAT FOR THIS
MANY YEARS HAS ALSO PRESENTED
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES TO OUR TO
OUR CAMPUSES.
I SINCE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
TWELVE TUITION YOU SEE HAS
INCREASED BY ONLY TWO AND A HALF
PERCENT --
WHILE THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
PRICE INDEX IS IT HAS INCREASED
18%.
SO WE ALL NEED TO WORK TOGETHER
TO ENSURE THAT YOU SEE HAVE
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO ENSURE
THAT OUR STUDENTS CAN SUCCEED.
THIS MEANS EITHER COMMITTING TO
MODERATE --
PREDICTABLE TUITION INCREASES OR
COMMENSURATE AMOUNT OF ON GOING
STATE FUNDING WITH ROBUST
FINANCIAL AID.
TODAY I'D LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU
AN EFFORT WE HAVE BEEN UNDER HAD
UNDER WAY TO DEVELOP OUR VISION
FOR WHAT YOU SEE --
COULD BE AND SHOULD BE IN THE
FUTURE INFORMED BOTH BY THE
STATE'S NEEDS AND OUR ROLE IN
FULFILLING THOSE NEEDS AND
STRATEGIES FOR REALIZING THAT
THAT VISION.
ALONG WITH OUR CHANCELLORS AND
IN CONSULTATION WITH A BOARD OF
REGENTS WE HAVE BEEN DEVELOPING
A MULTI YEAR FRAMEWORK WHICH
LAYS OUT A VISION WHERE WE COULD
INCREASE DEGREES BY OVER.
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND ABOVE AND
BEYOND THAT ONE MILLION THAT WE
ALREADY FORECAST WE ALSO WORK TO
REDUCE THE TIME IT TAKES A SOON
TO GRADUATE.
AND THEN BOTH GROW AND DIVERSIFY
OUR PROFESSORIAL TO BETTER
REFLECT THE POPULATION WE SERVE
AND ARE ABLE TO SUPPORT AN
INCREASE IN.
IN GRADUATION RATES.
WE BEGUN TO SHARE A MULTI YEAR
PLAN WITH MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION.
FACULTY AND STUDENTS AND WE'RE
EAGER TO RECEIVE YOUR YOUR
FEEDBACK.
A CENTRAL THAT PLAN IS A DESIRE
TO PIVOT FROM YEAR TO YEAR
BUDGETING AND PLANNING TO ONE
THAT IS AIMED AT LONG TERM
PLANNING ACHIEVING BOLD
ASPIRATIONAL GOALS.
WE ALSO WANT TO MOVE FROM A
FOCUS PURELY ON ENROLLMENT TO
VISION MORE INFORMED BY OUTCOMES.
WE MUST DO ALL WE CAN TO HELP
OUR STUDENTS GRADUATE IN A
TIMELY MANNER ESPECIALLY
CONTINUE TO CLOSE GRADUATION
GAPS IN TIME TO DEGREE GAPS FOR
LOW INCOME AND FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS.
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WILL
CONTINUE TO DO OUR PART IN
MAKING THIS DREAM A REALITY FOR
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF YOUNG
PEOPLE.
A BOLD VISION THE GOAL IS TO
TAKE RESOURCES TO ACHIEVE. FOR
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY ARE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OR DEDUCTION
PROVIDED YOU SEE WITH TWO
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
NEW ON GOING FUNDING.
THIS IS SIX POINT 9% BASED
BUDGET INCREASE MORE THAN ANY OF
THE JANUARY BUDGET INTRODUCTIONS.
THAT HAVE BEEN PROVIDED TO YOU
SEE IN RECENT YEARS.
WE ARE VERY PLEASED WITH HIS
INTRODUCTION REQUEST THE
LEGISLATURE TO APPROVE THESE
FUNDS FOR THE UNIVERSITY.
SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN ARE YOU SEE
HAS ADDED MORE THAN FOURTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES GREATLY EXCEEDING
OUR INITIAL TARGET OF TEN
THOUSAND NEW STUDENTS BY.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THROUGH THIS
ENROLLMENT GROWTH WILL CONTINUE
TO SERVE A NUMBER OF
HISTORICALLY REPRESENTED AND
FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS.
REYES WHO KNOWS YOU SEE STUDENTS
ARE ROLLED FROM MORE THAN ONE
YEAR AND OUR CAMPUSES NEED
ONGOING FUNDS TO SUPPORT THEM
AND THE NEXT CLASS OF STUDENTS
TO REPLACE THEM. TO THEIR
COLLEGE EDUCATION. TO SUPPORT
THIS INCREASE ENROLLMENT BECAUSE
WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
MORE ACCESS WE ARE REQUESTING A
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS.
ON TOP OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
AND THAT'S YOUR STATE BUDGET
THIS SENATE SUBCOMMITTEE
APPROVED PERMANENT FUNDS FOR UC.
THESE FUNDS WERE PROVIDED
INSTEAD OF A TUITION INCREASE
AND TO SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS ARE WE HAD ALREADY
ENROLLED.
THIS ALLOWED US AGAIN NOT TO
ENCRYPT INCREASED TUITION THIS
ACADEMIC YEAR.
BUT ULTIMATELY THE FINAL BUDGET
BILL PROVIDED YOU SEE --
WITH NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME MONEY.
THIS ONE TIME MONEY WILL GO AWAY
IN TWENTY NINE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INTRODUCTION
DOES NOT INCLUDE FUNDS REPLACE
THIS AMOUNT.
BUT SIMPLY MORE THAN HALF OF THE
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO MILLION
DOLLAR REQUEST IS THAT THIS
FUNDING BE CONVERTED FROM ONE
TIME FUNDS TO PERMANENT FUNDS.
JUST AS TUITION WOULD HAVE BEEN
A PERMANENT REVENUE SOURCE.
DOING THIS IS CRITICAL TO
SUSTAINING UC'S INVESTMENTS IN
INSTRUCTORS TEACHING ASSISTANTS
GRADUATE STUDENTS AND CAMPUS
BASED PROGRAMS.
WITHOUT THESE FUNDS ARE STUDENTS
MAY NOT GET THE SUPPORT THEY
NEED TO SUCCEED IN A TIMELY
MANNER.
THE OTHER HALF OF THE HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO MILLION WITH SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL AND ROAMING GROWTH OF
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES.
AND A THOUSAND GRADUATE STUDENTS
AND RECRUIT AND RETAIN THE
FACULTY AND STAFF REQUIRED TO
SUPPORT PREVIOUS ENROLLMENT
GROWTH EXCEEDED BUDGET AMOUNTS.
AS WELL AS DEBT SERVICE TO
SUPPORT OUR CAPITAL INVESTMENTS.
I'M NOT HERE TO SIMPLY ASK FOR
MORE FUNDING I WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE OUR PROGRESS IN BOTH
REVENUE GENERATION AND AND COST
CONTAINMENT AS WELL.
WE'VE DONE A LOT IN RECENT YEARS
TO BOTH REDUCE OUR COSTS AND
GENERATE SIGNIFICANT ALTERNATIVE
REVENUE.
WE HAVE A A PROCUREMENT A
PROCESS UNDER WAY THAT SAVING
THE UNIVERSITY WELL OVER THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
I WE ACTUALLY WORKING IN
COLLABORATION WITH CAL STATE IN
A PROGRAM KNOWN AS CAL YOU
SOURCE -- TO
EXPAND THIS PROGRAM.
WE ALSO HAVE OUR SELF INSURANCE
PROGRAM CALLED THAT IS NOW
SAVING ROUGHLY TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR AND LOWERING THE
COST OF OUR ON GOING INSURANCE.
AGAIN WE ALSO COLLABORATING WITH
THAT WAS CSU ON THIS --
CAPTIVE INSURANCE PROGRAM.
WELL WE ENDED FINANCIAL AID FOR
NON RESIDENT STUDENTS IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN THAT'S LED TO FORTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN ANNUAL
SAVINGS.
AND WE IMPLEMENTED ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS WHICH HAVE
YIELDED A TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR DOLLARS IN COST
SAVINGS.
AND WE CONTINUE TO LOOK AND WORK
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES FOR NEW WAYS TO
STREAMLINE OPERATIONS INCREASE
EFFICIENCIES.
IN CLOSING I WANT TO THANK YOU%
AND ASK YOUR PARTNERSHIP AS WE
SUSTAIN AND GROW THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM. FOR THIS GENERATION OF
STUDENTS AND GENERATIONS TO COME.
THANK YOU SIR LET ME JUST TOUCH
ON A COUPLE OF THE BUDGET ITEMS --
HE MENTIONED ENROLLMENT SO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET CURRENTLY
PROPOSES TEN MILLION FOR AN
ADDITIONAL THOUSAND STUDENTS AS
I READ IT.
YOU'VE INDICATED THAT IF YOU ADD
NINETY MILLION ROUGHLY TO THAT.
YOU CAN ADD AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
FOUR HUNDRED STUDENTS.
COULD OUT AND NO LET ME LET ME
BREAK THAT OUT BECAUSE IT IS
CONFUSING SO THE TEN MILLION
IT'S PUT IN OUR FOR EXISTING
STUDENTS --
FOR OVER IN ROME AT THAT WE HAD
IN PRIOR --
BUDGET YEARS --
WHAT WE ARE SEEKING --
THIS YEAR WOULD DOLLARS FOR OUR
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED NEW STUDENTS
THAT WOULD BE --
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES IN A THOUSAND
GRADUATE STUDENTS THE THE
REMAINING OF THAT THE REMAINDER
OF THAT --
UP TO SEVENTY FIVE MILLION IS --
FOR ENROLLMENT OVER ENROLLMENT
THAT WE'VE HAD IN THE PAST FOR
EXAMPLE WE HAVE NINETEEN HUNDRED
MORE STUDENTS AND WE HAD
BUDGETED.
FOR IN THIS CURRENT YEAR IT'S
ALSO FOR FINDING THE PRIME
PROGRAMWHICH I THINK ARE YOU
KNOW THIS IS OUR MEDICAL
STUDENTS THAT ARE WORKING IN.
UNDERSERVED IN LARGELY RURAL
AREAS IN IN CALIFORNIA.
SO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS IT
PRESENTLY STANDS DOES NOT
INCLUDE ANY MONEY FOR ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS FOR NEW ENROLLMENT IT
DOES NOT OKAY AND SO YOU'RE
REQUESTING FORTY THREE MILLION
FOR THE THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
THAT'S CORRECT [inaudible]
NOW.
WITH A BY THE WAY I WAS PLEASED
TO SEE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROVIDES THE FORTY
MILLION.
IN ONGOING SUPPORT FOR THE PROP
FIFTY SIX MEDIC MEDICAL
RESIDENCY PROGRAM SO WE DON'T
HAVE.
TO THANK YOU GOVERNOR WE DON'T
KNOW WE WERE VERY PLEASED ABOUT
THAT AS WELL WE DON'T HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THAT.
NOW ARMED CONFLICT AGAIN.
WITH RESPECT TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES A FIVE POINT THREE
MILLION AS I UNDERSTAND IT ON
GOING TO HER SOME ADDITIONAL.
CLINICIANS.
WAS THAT A BCP FROM UNIVERSITY.
THIS WAS.
OUR REGION SAID VOTED SEVERAL
YEARS AGO TO COMMIT --
50% OF INCREASES IN STUDENT
SERVICES FEES THESE ARE FEES
ABOVE AND BEYOND TUITION --
AND THEY HAD APPROVED 5%
INCREASES EVERY YEAR TWO AND A
HALF PERCENT OF THAT --
WAS ALWAYS SLATED TO GO --
FOR FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND
ACTUALLY SEVERAL OUR CAMPUSES
HAD BORROWED AHEAD OF TIME
BECAUSE OF THE SEVERE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS --
ON OUR CAMPUSES AS I'M SURE
CANCERS WHITE NO QUICK AND ALSO --
TEST BECAUSE WE HAD PUT IN I NOT
TO RAISE EITHER TUITION OR THE
STUDENT SERVICES FEE THIS WAS
PUT INTO AYE TO MEET THAT --
EXPENDITURE --
AT OUR CAMPUSES AND IS FIVE
POINT THREE MILLION SUFFICIENT
TO MEET THE NEED FOR CLINICIANS
WHAT WHAT. TWO PART QUESTION ONE
AND WHAT DOES YOUR STUDY
SUGGESTS --
IN OUR STUDY SUGGESTED THAT
THERE IS A OVERWHELMING NEED FOR
A MENTAL HEALTH I THINK UCLA
ALONE I'M THAT --
ONE OF THE CO CHAIRS OF OUR SOON
HEALTH INSURANCE PROGRAM UCLA
HAS SAID THAT THEY ARE GETTING
ROUGHLY.
TWICE AS MANY REQUESTS FOR
MENTAL HEALTH --
A WE HAD A LIKE A FIVE YEAR
PROGRAM TO BUILD UP THOSE
RESOURCES I TO MEET THOSE NEEDS
YOU KNOW I WOULD I WOULD NOTED
THE SAME TIME WE HAVE BEEN
ADDING ENROLLMENT SO --
YOU KNOW WHETHER THOSE ARE
SUFFICIENT --
I CAN'T SAY BUT WE IN WE WE DO
PUT OUT A REPORT THAT I WILL
pMENTAL HEALTH.
WELL I THINK IT PROBABLY GOES
WITHOUT SAYING OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH OF STUDENTS THAT AT ALL
LEVELS A FEW.
TWELVE COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN THE
ISSUE AND YOU SEE --
IS A VITAL WAS OF VITAL CONCERN
TO MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN THIS
BUILDING SO.
I WOULD BE INTERESTED IN
RECEIVING ANY ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT YOU WILL HAVE
BOTH THE TO SEE ISSUE AND YOU
SEE AND FRANKLY.
YOU -- TO
CHESSER OAKLEY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM AS TO WHETHER THE FUNDING
IS SUFFICIENT --
I WOULD NOT CENTER OFF THE DEBT
THE GOVERNOR ALSO DID DID PUT IN
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
BASIC NEEDS.
AND WHILE WE DO WE HAVE CRITICAL
NEEDS -- FOR
THE FOOD INSECURITY IN HOUSING
IT SECURITY WHICH WE WILL BE
USING THESE FUNDS TO MEET THE
STUDENT COMMITTEES THAT PUT THIS
TOGETHER ALSO INCLUDE MENTAL
HEALTH AS A BASIC NEED AND SO.
AS THIS IS ONGOING FUNDING YOU
KNOW IN THE THIS COULD ALSO BE
RESOURCES THAT MIGHT BE
AVAILABLE FOR MENTAL HEALTH
PERFECT.
LET ME SEGUE INTO DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND FACILITY NEEDS
TO USE THE ACTION THAT I BELIEVE
THAT IT COULD YOU GO INTO A
LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL THE
BUDGET CURRENTLY PROVIDES A
HUNDRED AND EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTY
EIGHT MILLION A ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND.
WHAT'S THE NEED.
SO THAT IS VERY MUCH APPRECIATED
A HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
ADS YEAH I KNOW YOU'RE GRATEFUL --
TO IT WE HAVE A PROGRAM UNDER
WAY THAT IS TRYING TO
STANDARDIZE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE --
ACROSS OUR CAMPUSES --
IT'S CALLED AYE CAMP --
AND IT IS IT LOOKS AT AS IS
CHANCE WHITE WAS SAYING --
THE AGE OF THE BUILDINGS WHAT
INVESTMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE THE
TYPES OF SYSTEMS THEY HAVE --
YOU KNOW THE EQUIVALENT
CONTINUES OCCUPANCY OF THOSE
BUILDINGS AND TRYING TO GET BOTH
A OVERALL NUMBER.
BUT ALSO A A PRIORITIZATION
HARDLY TRIAGE --
HOW WE'RE GONNA SPEND THAT TO
GIVE US MORE --
YOU KNOW WE HAVE WE'RE NOT
FINISHED WITH THAT BUT IF YOU
EXTRAPOLATE THE NEED FOR STATE
ELIGIBLE BILLINGS IS ABOUT FOUR
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS --
WE HAVE A SIMILAR AMOUNT FOR NON
STATE ELIGIBLE BUT WE HAVE OTHER
REVENUE SOURCES YOU KNOW HOUSING
REVENUES MEDICAL CENTER --
REVENUES OTHER AUXILIARY
REVENUES TO HELP SUPPORT THAT SO --
WE YOU KNOW I I I SHARE --
CHANCE OR WITH --
WHITE VIEW THAT --
THESE -- ONE
TIME FUNDS ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO US BUT WE ALSO TO
GET AHEAD OF THE THE ISSUE --
WOULD BE LOOKING FOR A GEO BOND
ON THE BALLOT AND THAT'S NOT
JUST TO SERVE --
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BUT ALSO --
WE ALSO DOING NEW SEISMIC
STUDIES ADVANCES IN ENGINEERING
CODES WE DO NEED O UPGRADE --
A LOT OF THOSE BUILDINGS AS WELL
SO THE NON STATE OWNED OF
FACILITIES THE MEDICAL CENTERS I
ASSUME THEY HAVE A REVENUE
STREAM THAT.
CAN SUPPORT --
AS AS MANY OF OUR AUXILIARIES IN
SUMMER RESEARCH THAT YOU KNOW IS
SUPPORTED BY INDIRECT COST
RECOVERY NOT STATE FUNDS BUT THE
PRIMARY FOCUS IS A FOUR POINT
FOUR BILLION ON THE STATE OWNED
EXACTLY.
WESLEY --
THE TUITION INCREASE IN OR NO
TUITION INCREASE THAT'S FOR IN
STATE STUDENTS THAT'S IN STATE.
SO.
I ASSUME THAT WITH RESPECT OUT
OF STATE STUDENTS.
TUITION INCREASE COULD BE
IMPLEMENTED WE HAVE A ON THE
MARCH A BALLOT WE HAVE A TUITION
INCREASE FOR NON RESIDENTS UP
WILL TUITION.
THAT'S A PEGGED AT INFLATION A
TWO POINT 6% --
INCREASE.
ON THE MARCH A MARCH REGIONS --
GENDER YEAH I'M SORRY IN THE
BALLOT.
SO.
THAT DOES CREATE SOME FUNDING
DISPARITY AMONG THE CAMPUSES
CORRECT GIVEN THE PERCENTAGES OF
OUT OF STATE STUDENTSTHAT SOME
HAVE VERSUS THE PERCENTAGES THAT
OTHER CAMPUSES HAVE.
THAT IS CORRECT YEAH NON
RESIDENT TUITION STAYS ON THE
CAMPUS WHERE IT'S GENERATED IS
THERE ANY.
IS THERE ANY THOUGHT TO REVISIT
THE WAY THAT MONEY IS ALLOCATED --
TO DEAL WITH THOSE CAMPUSES THAT
DON'T --
AREN'T ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM
WHATEVER IT IS 20% --
THE STATE'S STUDENT ENROLLMENT
YEAH WE HAD A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT --
DIFFERENT AND AS SOON JUST NOT
TO INTERRUPT I JUST DID --
BUT TO I SING THAT REALLY
RELATES --
TO YOU KNOW YOU SEE MERCED
PERHAPS.
MAYBE THERE'S ANOTHER ONE IN
THERE SOMEWHERE.
YEAH ACTUALLY IF YOU LOOK AT IT
NOW -- YOU
KNOW WE DOCTORED THE CAP ON
ANDREAS ENROLLMENT AT 18% TWO
YEARS AO THERE ARE FOUR
CAMPUSES IRVINE SAN DIEGO --
BURKE IN UCLA THAT WERE ABOVE
THAT CAPS OR IN THE LOW --
20% RANGE DAVIS JUST HIT THE 18%
CAP.
ARE THE OTHER THREE THAT YOU
WOULD MENTION ARE ARE BELOW ARE
THERE FOR SANTA BARBARA IS HER
MID TEENS AND THEN THE OTHER
THREE ARE --
IN SINGLE DIGITS WITH MERCED AT
BASICALLY AT AT ZERO EITHER A
LOT OF DISPARITIES IN IN --
NONTRADITIONAL --
REVENUES --
AT OUR CAMPUS IS IT'S NOT JUST
NON RESIDENT TUITION ITS PATENT
REVENUES IT'S INDIRECT COSTS
REVENUES FROM RESEARCH IT IS --
MED CENTER REVENUES --
AT A DIFFERENT INSTITUTION AND I
I WORKED ON A EFFORT TO TRY TO
NORMALIZE THAT FUNDING WAS
CALLED RE BENCHING. EIGHT YEARS
AGO OR SEVEN YEARS AGO.
YEAH -- BUT
I IT BY DOT YOU KNOW I THINK A
LOT OF PEOPLE THINK IT IS TIME
TO REVISIT THAT GIVEN YOU KNOW
THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF GROWTH IN
THOSE OTHER REVENUE SOURCES.
AND YOU KNOW AND KEPT WISHIN
FLAT SO CAMPUS LIKE RIVERSIDE IS
MORE TUITION DEPENDENT THAN
ALMOST ANY CAMPUS WE HAVE.
AND I WAS JUST I MEAN THERE'S A
LOT OF PRESSURE HERE PRESSURE
OUTSIDE THE BUILDING. TO KEEP.
IN STATE TUITION FLAT.
AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THE REASONS.
FOR BUT THE THEN THAT CREATES
THIS FUNDING DISPARITY.
THAT IN SOME WAYS AND SOMETIMES
IN SOME CASES THE STATE CAN'T
SIMPLY MAKE UP. TO THESE
CAMPUSES THROUGH AN INCREASE OF
THE GENERAL FUND AND THERE YOU
ALL REALLY ON A TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT AND SEE IF AS A POLICY
MATTER THAT IS APPROPRIATE NOW.
HOW DOES RETURN I I THINK AS A
POLICY MATTER I MEAN I WOULD
JUST REMIND THE COMMITTEE?
YOUR 57% OF OUR STUDENTS PAY NO
TUITION.
AND TUITION IS A PRIME WHAT WE
CALL RETURNED EIGHT THROUGH WE
KEEP TUITION FLAT THAT BASIC THE
KEEPS THE FINANCIAL AID POOL
FLAT. FOR ALL THE OTHER --
NON TUITION --
COST YOU KNOW AS AS CHANCER SO
CLEAN WHITE NOTED THE COST OF
HOUSING THE COST OF BOOKS ACOSTA
FOOD.
AND SO YOU KNOW IN ESSENCE --
OUR FINANCIAL AID --
POOL IS GOING DOWN WE WHEN WE DO
THAT AND WE THINK UP.
YOU KNOW IF YOU LOOK AT THE
HISTORY OF JEWISH AT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA WE GO
THROUGH LONG PERIODS OF KEEPING
IT FLAT AND IT'S DOUBLE DIGIT
AND WE THINK A A BETTER POLICY
APPROACH WOULD BE HAVING A YOU
KNOW --
INFLATION BASED MODERATE TUITION
WHERE YOU KEPT.
THE REAL COST OF EDUCATION FLAT
BUT JUST GREW UP WITH INFLATION
WELL I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND
THAT AND YOU KNOW WE FEEL A LOT
OF PRESSURES FROM A LOT OF
DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS WHEN YOU
WORK IN THE SPELLING OF AND ALL
I'M ASKING WITH RESPECT TO THIS
PARTICULAR POINT IS PERHAPS.
THE REGION'S COULD TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT GIVEN THE CURRENT
POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT IN WE'RE
CERTAIN PIECE OF THE STUDENT
POPULATION.
YES SUBJECT TO A FEE INCREASE IN.
THE RESTAURANT NOT AND YOU HAVE
THESE WIDE DISPARITIES AMONG TWO
CAMPUSES AS TO HOW MANY OTHER
STATES STUDENTS.
THEY HAVE AN OLDER OR ARE ABLE
TO ENROLL --
ANYWAY QUESTIONS THE RIVER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR BUT NOT
REALLY A QUESTION MORE OF AN
IDEA -- SO
IT SEEMS THE CROSS ALL OF OUR
OUR CAMPUSES FOOD AND HOUSING
AND SECURITY IS A PROBLEM.
AND I THINK THAT YOU KNOW TO MY-COLLEAGUES POINT THAT YOU KNOW I
I ALSO WORK FULL TIME WHEN I WAS
IN SCHOOL BUT THAT DOESN'T WORK
FOR EVERYONE --
AND I ALSO LIVED AT HOME I
WASN'T SUPPORTING MYSELF IT WAS
MUCH DIFFERENT.
SO I THINK WE REALLY NEED TO
LOOK AT THAT BUT I ALSO --
ONE I WANT TO SHOUT OUT TO THE
GOVERNOR SO MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
HE PUT THE MONEY AND BEFORE WE
HAD A REALLY LOBBY HIM HARD
WHICH IS PRETTY AWESOME SHE DOES
FEEL THE SAME WAY.
BUT I WOULD ALSO LIKE US TO
THINK ABOUT --
AFTER THIS MY FIFTH YEAR IN THE
LEGISLATURE AFTER ABOUT COUPLE
YEARS I SAID TO MY STAFF I SAID
HOW COME THE C. ISSUES COME
EVERY YEAR AND ASK US FOR MONEY.
WHY HAVEN'T WE FIGURED OUT A
FUNDING STREAM FOR THEM YET?
SO I FEEL LIKE WE REALLY NEED TO
DO SO I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU GUYS
PLAN YOUR BUDGET WONDERING EVERY
YEAR WHAT IT'S GOING TO BE --
WHEN I WAS IN THE LABOR MOVEMENT
AND WE NEGOTIATED CONTRACTS EVEN
THE EMPLOYERS WHO DIDN'T LOVE
BEING UNDER UNION CONTRACTS SAID
WE APPRECIATE KNOWING THREE OR
FOUR YEARS WHAT OUR COSTS ARE
GOING TO BE?
SO I WOULD JUST LIKE TO THROW
OUT THERE WE AS A COMMITTEE AND
AS THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD LOOK
AT HOW DO WE FIND.
FUNDING OR MAYBE EVEN A FOR TWO
OR THREE YEARS OUT SO THAT YOU
GUYS COMPLAINED BETTER SOME I'M
JUST GONNA THROW THAT UP FOR
CONSIDERATION I APPRECIATE ALL
OF YOU BEING HERE AND WHAT YOU
DO EVERY DAY AS WELL.
WE WOULD WELCOME.
A MULTI YEAR APPROACH FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS.
THE NOTION OF WHEN I RAIN
CAMPUSES.
YOU SEE AN AN IN OTHER PLACES IN
THE COUNTRY.
IF YOU CAN BE MUCH WISER USERS
OF THE RESOURCES YOU HAVE.
IF THEY ARE PREDICTABLE.
SUSTAINABLE AND HOPEFULLY
SUFFICIENT.
THIS LAST YEAR FOR EXAMPLE --
YOU KNOW WE STARTED IN PRETTY
DEEP HOLE IN THIS BUILDING WAS
THE GOVERNOR BROWN'S NINETY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FOR US AGAINST
OF FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
SOMETHING ASK.
AND IT WASN'T UNTIL THE BILL WAS
SIGNED IN JUNE WHEN WE'VE MADE
PROGRESS AGAINST THAT INITIAL
INTRODUCTORY BUDGET.
WAS LIKE WE'D ALREADY MADE ALL
THE ADMISSIONS DECISIONS WITH
THE EXPECTATION OF OF ACTUALLY
HAVING A BUDGET CUTS.
AND IN AN OFFICE AND YOU GET
THIS BOWLS OF MONEY PERMANENT
MONEY AND YOU GO OH CRAP.
WITH ALL THE STUDENTS NOW COMING.
IN SO WE HUSTLE OUT THERE AND WE
FIND VERY CAPABLE THE TEMPORARY
FACULTY TO CREATE A CURRICULUM.
IMAGINE A WORLD WHERE IF YOU
KNEW THAT YOU COULD CLOTHING
HIGHER THE PERMIT PROFESSORIAL
FACULTY.
KNOWING THE STUDENTS ARE COMING
BECAUSE OUR DATA ANALYTICS WE
KNOW WHAT'S COMING.
AND IT WOULD BE SO FOR EVERY
DOLLAR WE GET WE CAN SPEND A
MUCH MORE WISELY.
AND HAVE BETTER OUTCOMES AND I
THINK THAT'S PROBABLY TRUE.
I KNOW IT'S TRUE FOR THE UC IN
FOR THE COMMUNICABLE HIS A WEEK
WE WOULD WELCOME A MULTI YEAR
DISCUSSION [inaudible]
RIGHT.
I AGREE AND THAT'S SOMETHING I
HOPE WE CAN WORK ON GOING
FORWARD.
GIVEN THE WIDE SWING WILD SWINGS
IN WIDE SWINGS IN THE CALIFORNIA
REVENUE STREAM IN OUR BUDGET
WILL HAVE TO FIGURE OUT.
HOW THAT WORKS --
I SUPPOSE IN IN PERIODS OF A RUN
UP WHERE YOU CAN EXPECT TO YOU
KNOW SIX OR SEVEN YEAR RUN UP IN
THE ECONOMY WE IT WOULD BE
RELATIVELY EASY TO PEG THAT
NUMBER BUT ON WHEN WE'RE ON THE
DOWNWARD SLIDE I DON'T I DON'T.
RIGHT HOW TO PICK THE NUMBER
PERHAPS THERE'SSOME RESERVE
ACCOUNT THAT COULD BE USED TO
BALANCE OUT THE REVENUE FLOW.
THAT WE DON'T GET TO HAVE
EXPERIENCES BUDGETEERS BUT THAT
YOU ALL COULD THEN BENEFIT FROM
WITH A MULTI YEAR BUDGET.
SMARTER PEOPLE THAN I AM I'M
SURE CAN FIGURE WE'VE EXPLORE
THAT A LITTLE BIT I CENTER OFF
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE --
SOME RESERVISTS ESPECIALLY
BECAUSE OUR MEDICAL CENTERS YOU
KNOW IF THERE WERE A SITUATION
WHERE THE STATE HAD TO MAKE A
CUT I MEAN THE LAST THING WE
WANT TO DO IS TO PUT THAT ON THE
BACKS OF STUDENTS.
AND SO IF IF THERE WAS A WAY
THAT YOU CAN BRING THIS STATE TO
MAINTENANCE OF EFFORT.
AND THEN --
IF YOU KNOW THE PAID OFF OVER A
NUMBER OF YEARS I THINK THAT
WOULD SMOOTH OUT.
YOU KNOW THE THE VOLATILITY THAT
WE SEE IN --
IN IN IN THE STATE REVENUES BUT
AGAIN WELL TO YOUR PLANNING IS
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL FOR US AND
ESPECIALLY TRY TO MEET THESE
GOALS OF A MILLION MORE STUDENTS
BY MILLION MORE DEGREES BY
TWENTY THIRTY WE HAVE TO GIVE A
CHANCE OR WHITES MEDICAL CENTERS
THOUGH BUT THAT'S OKAY WE'LL.
WORK ON THAT.
WELL WHEN THE MONEY AT
LEGISLATOR RATES FUNDAMENTAL
PARADIGM SHIFT TO THE FIRST
DOLLARS OFF THE STATE BUDGET --
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION IN AND WHEN
THERE'S A DOWNTURN OTHER PEOPLE
SUFFER.
WE WERE TO SEE CORMORANTS.
WELL WE'LL GO TO WORK ON THAT
GENTLEMAN.
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR EXTRAORDINARY PATIENCE AND
I WON'T HAVE TO ORDER DINNER
CANCER WAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE IF
YOU WOULD --
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD STARTING WITH MY LEAD TO
MY LEFT YOU'RE RIGHT SIR THAT
YOU.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR --
CHECKS WILD BERMAN FINANCE.
HIS WEALTH.
GOOD MORNING MICHELLE NEW IN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
MORNING ERIN AT AREA DEPARTMENT
FINANCE ALSO.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
JENNIFER KUHN PATELLA FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE SO
THANK YOU.
OKAY WHO WANTS TO START.
OKAY THINGS OFF HERE.
SO THE SERGEANT IS PASSING
AROUND A I HANDLED THAT I MAY BE
REFERENCING A COUPLE TIMES
DURING MY MY PRESENTATION.
I'M JUST GOING TO BE PROVIDING
YOU WITH A BRIEF OVERVIEW MOSTLY
OF THE K. TWELVE SPENDING --
WITH IN THE PROPOSITION NINETY
MINIMUM GET YES PRECISELY THAT --
ONE AND THEN --
WHAT MY COLLEAGUE HERE MICHELLE
WILL BE COVERING --
AND OF COURSE THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WILL BE
COVERING.
HUG KIND OF K. FOURTEEN TO ME
COLLEGES AS WELL TO HEAR ABOUT
THAT AND I'LL BE COVERING THE
GREATER DETAILS OF THE
CALCULATION OF THE GUARANTEE --
AND HOW REVENUE CHANGES ARE AND
IT'S COMMITTEE WILL BE HAVING.
HI THE NINETEEN TWENTY
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS PROPOSING
THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF FUNDING
EVER UNDER THE PROPOSITION
NINETY MINIMUM GUARANTEE WITH A
LEVEL OF EIGHTY POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS.
UP FROM SEVENTY SEVEN POINT NINE
IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND UP
FROM FORTY SEVEN BILLION DURING
THE TROUGH OF THE RECESSION.
OUT  TOTAL OF EIGHTY POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S A
PER PUPIL EXPENDITURE FROM
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHTH OF
JUST MORE.
THAN TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
PUPIL AN INCREASE OF
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS PER PUPIL
OVER TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
LEVELS.
SPENDING THE GARRETT SPENDING
HIS ME WITHIN THE GUARANTEE
INCLUDES A SERIES OF STRATEGIC
INVESTMENTS.
IN K. FOURTEEN EDUCATION WITH
THE INTENT OF PRIORITIZING
BUDGETARY PRUDENCE AND
FLEXIBILITY IN THE CASE OF
FUTURE ECONOMIC DOWNTURNS BUT
ALSO TRYING TO ENSURE THAT
AVAILABLE RESOURCES ARE
APPROPRIATELY TARGETED. TO
MAXIMIZE IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR
ALL STUDENTS OF ALL AGES.
FIGURE ONE SHOWS THE TOTAL NEW
AVAILABLE RESOURCES WITHIN THE
GUARANTEE AT APPROXIMATELY TWO
POINT NINE BILLION DOLLARS. FOR
YOU TO OUTLINES HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO
SPEND THESE AVAILABLE RESOURCES
ON K. FOURTEEN EDUCATION
PRIORITIES WITH K. TWELVE
RECEIVING ABOUT TWO AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
RECEIVING ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY SEVEN MILLION. FOR
SOME OF OUR MAJOR K. TWELVE
SPENDING PROPOSALS IN EARLY
EDUCATION THE BUDGET PROPOSES A
SHIFT TWO HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND.
FROM.
PART DAYS STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS AT NON LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND. TO ALLOW NON LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCY PROVIDERS TO
DRAW DOWN FULL DAY FULL YEAR
REIMBURSEMENT FROM A SINGLE
FUNDING SOURCE IN TO WRITE THEM
WITH FLEXIBILITY TO MAKE BETTER
USE.
OF THAT CONTRACT FUNDING.
IN THE LC OF HALF THE BUDGET
BILL THOUGHT BUILDS ON PREVIOUS
INVESTMENTS SINCE THE ENACTMENT
OF THOSE WHO BETH AND TWENTY
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN WITH AN
ADDITIONAL TWO BILLION DOLLARS
IN. NINETEEN TWENTY TO GO
TOWARDS FUNDING A COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT ON THE TARGET RATES
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
THIS WILL BRING THE TOTAL OF
INCREASED FUNDING SINCE THE
ENACTMENT OF LCF TO JUST OVER
TWENTY THREE BILLION DOLLARS
WITH A TOTAL AMOUNT OF FUNDING
FOR THE PROGRAM.
WHOLE -- AT
SIXTY THREE ADDITIONALLY AS
SHOWN IN FIGURE FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES TO
USE.
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF OUTSTANDING SETTLE UP
PAYMENTS --
TO PRIOR YEARS --
IN THE GUARANTEED. TO FUND LCF
IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IN ORDER TO
AVOID CURRENT YEAR CUTS SCHOOLS
AS A RESULT OF THE PROVISION
NINETY MINIMUM GUARANTEE
DECREASING.
IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
YEAR COMPARED TO THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT.
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION THE BUDGET
PROPOSES A SPECIAL EDUCATION
PROPOSAL USING BOTH ONGOING AND
SOME ONE TIME FUNDING --
PROPOSITION NINETY FUNDS OF
THREE HUNDRED NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING AND A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME.
THIS FUNDING WILL BE USED TO
SUPPORT EXPANDED EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS AND SCHOOL READINESS
SUPPORTS A LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES WITH HIGH PERCENTAGES
OF BOTH.
A DUPLICATED PEOPLE'S UNDER THE
LCF AND STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES.
THE BUDGET ALSO PROPOSES ANOTHER
ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS PROVIDE A COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT. TO OTHER --
KATO PROGRAMS WITHIN THE
GUARANTEE.
THERE ARE ALSO SOME MAJOR.
EDUCATION PROPOSALS THAT ARE IN
THE NON PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
WORLD THAT I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
FOR YOU AS WELL.
AND FIGURE THREE OF OF THE HAND
OUT HOW'S THOSE ON THERE.
WE HAVE A THREE BILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL --
TO PAY DOWN THE CAL STIRS DEBT
FOR EMPLOYERS APPROXIMATELY
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF
WHICH WILL GO TOWARD REDUCING
EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTION RATES
APPROXIMATELY 1% IN EACH OF THE
NEXT TWO YEARS SO TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE REMAINING.
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS WILL GO TOWARDS
PAYING DOWN THE LONG TERM
UNFUNDED LIABILITY ON THE
EMPLOYER SHARE THE CAL STARS
FUNDING PLAN.
WHICH IS ESTIMATED TO EQUAL
ABOUT POINT 5% OF A REDUCTION TO
CONTRIBUTION RATES IN FUTURE
YEARS BEGINNING IN.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE OF FOR A
TOTAL OF APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE LIFE OF
THE CONCERTS FUNDING PLAN WHICH
IS SCHEDULED TO END IN --
TWENTY FORTY SIX AND THERE ARE A
SERIES OF EARLY EDUCATION
PROPOSALS AS WELL THAT WE ARE
PROPOSING --
IN NON PROPOSITION NINETY
GENERAL FUND AND YOU'LL BE
HEARING ABOUT THOSE IN MORE
DETAIL AT A LATER HEARING --
BUT I DO WANT TO EMPHASIZE THEM
AS THEY ARE REALLY PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S GREATER PUSH
THIS YEAR TO EMPHASIZE --
SERVICES FOR THE WHOLE CHILD AND
REALLY --
EMPHASIZING AND TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF COLLABORATION ACROSS MULTIPLE
SYSTEMS SUCH AS HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCIES HIGHER
EDUCATION AND LABOR AS WELL AS
K. TWELVE EDUCATION.
HOW THE FIRST OF THOSE AND I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT IS SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IS
BEING PROPOSED IN ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL FUND
TO CONTINUE?
NEW CONSTRUCTION OR RETROFITTING
OF EXISTING FACILITIES FOR FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS OR TO
FUND OTHER ACTIVITIES --
THAT WOULD HELP TO REDUCE
BARRIERS TO PROVIDING FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN.
THERE'S ALSO A FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND PROPOSAL TO BOTH EXPAND
SUBSIDIZE CHILDCARE FACILITIES
IN THE STATE.
AND MAKE A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN THE EDUCATION OF
THE CHILD CARE WORK FORCE TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF CARE AND
MOVED CHILD CARE PROFESSIONALS
ALONG THE EARLY EDUCATION OR
COCHLEAR PROFESSIONAL CONTINUING.
BUDGET ALSO PROPOSES ALMOST ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE.
AN ADDITIONAL TEN THOUSAND SLOTS
FOR FULL DAY FOR YOUR ACCESS TO
STATE PRESCHOOL TO ALL ELIGIBLE
LOW INCOME FOUR YEAR OLDS.
AND THE BUDGET MAKES A SERIES OF
OTHER INVESTMENTS WITHIN OTHER
AREAS OF THE BUDGET TO DISCOUNT
WORKS CAL GRANT ACCESS AND HOME
VISITING --
TO FURTHER THIS GOAL OF SERVING
THE WHOLE CHILD AN EARLY
EDUCATION.
LASTLY OF THE BUDGET PROPOSES A
TEN MILLION DOLLAR --
FUNDING TO PLAY ELEMENT OF A
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM.
THAT WILL REALLY WE'VE TOGETHER
STUDENT [inaudible]
DATA ACROSS.
DIFFERENT SYSTEM SUCH AS EARLY
EDUCATION K. TWELVE HIGHER
EDUCATION THE WORK FORCE AND
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
I WITH THAT I WILL CONCLUDE MY
COMMENTS AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THEY'RE LIVING QUESTIONS.
I DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS AT
THIS POINT ALTHOUGH YOU FOR MY
COMMENTS ABOUT THE CONCENTRATION
GRANT I THINK.
I DON'T NEED TO REPEAT THEM YES
MA'AM [inaudible]
THIS MONTH --
I WILL OF MITCHELL NEW IN A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'LL BE
PROVIDING.
MY COLLEAGUE JACK'S FAULT AND I
WILL BE PROVIDING THE HIGHER ED
OVERVIEW PORTION OF THE
PRESENTATION.
SO OF MORNING AGAIN --
I I WILL BEGIN WITH A AS I JUST
MENTIONED HIGHER LEVEL HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR HIGHER EDUCATION AND
THEN HIGHLIGHT THE MAJOR
SPENDING PROPOSALS FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
OF MY COLLEAGUES WILL THEN
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS FOR
THE UNIVERSITIES AND STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN ALL
THREE OF THE STATE'S HIGHER
EDUCATION SEGMENTS AND IN
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION.
IMPROVE STUDENT SUCCESS AND
TIMELY COMPLETION OF A DEGREE OR
PROGRAM.
AND TO BETTER ENSURE THAT
COLLEGE REMAINS AFFORDABLE.
THE BUDGET PROPOSES TOLD FUNDING
OF THIRTY SIX POINT FOUR BILLION
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION.
WHICH IS MADE UP OF TWENTY POINT.
FIVE BILLION GENERAL FUND AND
LOCAL PROPERTY TAX AND FIFTEEN
POINT NINE BILLION IN OTHER
FUNDS.
THIS TOTAL REFLECTS BOTH DIRECT
FUNDING TO THE PUBLIC SEGMENTS
AND FUNDING FOR FINANCIAL AID.
THAT STUDENTS MAY RECEIVE AT
ELIGIBLE INSTITUTIONS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES
YEAR OVER YEAR INCREASES OF TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FUND FOR THE UC.
THREE HUNDRED MILLION ON GOING
GENERAL AS YOU ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND ABOUT THREE HUNDRED MILLION
GENERAL FUND FOR THE CALTRANS
PROGRAM AND ADMINISTERED BY C.
SACK.
THE ADMINISTRATION SUPPORTS
CONTINUED INVESTMENT IN HIGHER
EDUCATION WITH THE EXPECTATION
THAT COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
WILL WORK TOGETHER.
ALONG WITH EMPLOYERS FACULTY THE
STATE AND STUDENTS. TO ENHANCE
THE THE CURRENT HIGHER EDUCATION
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT MODEL
TO BEST SERVE STUDENTS AND TO
MEET THE CHANGING AND EVOLVING
WORKFORCE NEEDS OF THE WITHOUT
I'LL DESCRIBE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
PROPOSED INVESTMENTS FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. FOR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES NINE POINT NINE BILLION
IN FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND ADULT EDUCATION
AFTER ACCOUNTING FOR AVAILABLE
PROP.
NINETY EIGHT LOCAL PROPERTY
TAXES AND STUDENT FEES.
THIS FUNDING SUPPORTS GENERAL
PURPOSE APPORTIONMENT AND
NUMEROUS OTHER PROGRAMS AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BUILDS ON
AND SUPPORTS INVESTMENTS MADE IN
RECENT YEARS.
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUDGET
ACT FUNDS AB NINETEEN WHICH
ESTABLISHED THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE PROMISE AND ALLOWED
COLLEGES TO WAIVE.
TUITION FEES FOR FIRST TIME FULL
TIME STUDENTS AND THEIR FIRST
ACADEMIC YEAR.
THE CALIFORNIA CALLED PROMISES A
FRAMEWORK FOR COLLEGES.
THAT SUPPORTS AFFORDABILITY AND
ACCESS WHILE ALSO ADVANCING
PROGRAMS THAT MAXIMIZE STUDENT
SUCCESS AND THE NAVIGATION OF
COLLEGE PATHWAYS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
FORTY MILLION PROP NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT A SECOND
YEAR OF FREE TUITION. FOR
STUDENT FOR FIRST TIME FULL TIME
STUDENTS AND THEIR SECOND
ACADEMIC YEAR.
IN ADDITION THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES FIVE MILLION ONE
TIME NON PROP NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND. FOR THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO EXPAND
OUT REACH AROUND THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE PROMISE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
CONTINUES TO IMPLEMENT THE
STUDENT CENTERED PHONE FUNDING
FORMULA WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED IN
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUDGET
ACT.
THE FORMULA ALLOCATES GENERAL
PURPOSE APPORTIONMENT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BASED ON
ADDITIONAL FACTORS INCLUDING THE
ENROLLMENT OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS.
AND SPECIFIED STUDENT SUCCESS
METRICS INCLUDING THE COMPLETION
OF A DEGREE OR CERTIFICATE.
THIS IS THE FIRST YEAR OF
IMPLEMENTATION FOR THE STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA.
AND THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING SOME REVISIONS TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE ANOMALIES IN THE
DATA BEING REPORTED BY DISTRICTS
[inaudible]
SPECIFICALLY MAINTAINING. TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN RATES
INCIDENT TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY FISCAL YEAR.
AND CAPPING YEAR OVER YEAR
GROWTH FOR THE STUDENT SUCCESS
ALLOCATION.
OF THE FORMULA 210%.
THESE REVISIONS ARE INTENDED TO
ADDRESS LONG TERM.
FISCAL STABILITY FOR THE FORMULA
AND TO PROVIDE SUFFICIENT TIME
TO ENSURE ACCURACY OF THE DATA
BEING REPORTED.
BY THE DISTRICTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
APPORTIONMENT INCLUDING TWENTY
SIX MILLION PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR
ENROLLMENT GROWTH AND A THREE
POINT 46% COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT [inaudible]
THE OF OF TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
EIGHT MILLION PROF NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND.
IN ADDITION THERE ARE OTHER COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENTS FOR
VARIOUS PROGRAMS AND THESE TOTAL
ABOUT THIRTY TWO MILLION.
A PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO A
ALSO PROVIDES TEN MILLION PROP
NINETY GENERAL FUND FOR LEGAL
SERVICES TO UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANT STUDENTS.
FACULTY AND STAFF ON COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUDGET
PROVIDED ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
THIS PURPOSE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES TO MAKE THIS
ONGOING FUNDING.
FIRST THE OPERATIONS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
FOR A ONE TIME NON PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND. FOR
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE FOR A
STAFFING CONTRACT FOR THE
FUNDING FORMULA OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED
IN LEGISLATION LAST.
FALL -- LESS
THAT AT LAST BUDGET ACT IN
ADDITION THE BUDGET PROVIDES A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
ONGOING NON PROPOSITION NINETY
GENERAL FUND.
AND ONE POSITION FOR AN
INFORMATION SECURITY OFFICER. TO
IMPROVE DATA AND NETWORK
SECURITY CAPACITY AT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
FINALLY FOR A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACILITIES PROJECTS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE MILLION
IN GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND
FUNDING. FOR TWENTY SEVEN NEW
AND CONTINUING PROJECTS TO
ADDRESS CRITICAL FIRE LIFE
SAFETY ISSUES.
pTO MY CALL MY COLLEAGUE JACK AND
WE'LL BE HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS
AFTER OUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON JACK WELCH FORMER
FINANCE I'LL BEGIN WITH THE
UNIVERSITIES THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INVESTS OVER A HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
THIS INVESTMENT ONE SURE THAT
BOTH UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS WILL BE
ABLE TO BE IMMEDIATE OPERATIONAL
NEEDS INCREASE AFTER STORIES
GRADUATION RATES AND OVERALL
STUDENT SUCCESS.
AND MAINTAIN MAINTAIN PROGRAMS
TO SUPPORT ACCESS TO THESE
INSTITUTIONS.
IN LIGHT OF THE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN BOTH THE CSU AND
THE UC THE ADMINISTRATION
EXPECTS TUITION TO REMAIN FLAT
IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THE
ADMINISTRATION'S CONVEYED THAT
THE FUNDING PROPOSED IN THE
BUDGET IS CONTINGENT ON TUITION
FEES REMAINING FLAT.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD THE
ADMINISTRATION BEGIN AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION WITH EACH
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM ON HOW WE CAN
COME COLLABORATE --
ON SHORT AND LONG TERM
INITIATIVES TO PROVIDE FISCAL
CERTAINTY FOR STUDENTS IN THE
FAMILIES INCREASE ACCESS
IMPROVES SUCCESS GREW MORE COST
EFFICIENT SYSTEM OF HIGHER
EDUCATION.
IMPROVE THE LINK BETWEEN HIGHER
EDUCATION AND SKILLS NEEDS
ECONOMY BOTH NOW AND IN THE
FUTURE.
SPECIFICALLY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES A FOUR POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATIONS OF CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THE CSU
CURRENTLY SERVES ABOUT FOR
HONORED TEN THOUSAND FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT STUDENT SERVICE
TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES --
THE BUDGET PROPOSES INCREASE OF
FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR
UNIVERSITY THREE HUNDRED POINT
THREE MILLION OF WHICH IS
ONGOING.
THE PROPOSAL CAN BE BROKEN UP
INTO FOUR PARTS THE FIRST
COMPONENT SEEKS TO ADDRESS
ONGOING OPERATIONAL COSTS IN THE
CC BUDGET.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
ONE HUNDRED NINETY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS TO COVER THE COST OF
INCREASED COMPETITION FOR CSU
EMPLOYEES.
AND TO SUPPORT HEALTH AND
RETIREMENT BENEFITS MAINTENANCE
ANOTHER OPERATIONAL COSTS.
THE SECOND COMPONENT OF OUR
PROPOSAL RELEASED ACCESS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES
SIXTY TWO MILLION FOR A WOMAN
GROWTH EXPANDING THE C. ISSUES
TOTAL CAPACITY BY 2% ROUGHLY
SEVEN THOUSAND FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT STUDENTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES FIFTEEN MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND TO COMBAT
STERN HUNGER HOMELESSNESS TWO
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND.
TO REVIEW POTENTIAL CSU CAMPUS
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY INTO
AN FIFTY THOUSAND ONGOING
GENERAL FUND. TO HELP FORMALLY
INCARCERATED STUDENTS ACCESS TO
PHYSIO.
THE THIRD COMPONENT OF OUR
PROPOSAL FOCUSES ON STUDENT
SUCCESS.
THE TWENTY SIXTEEN BUDGET CALLED
ON THIS ISSUE TO AND RATES INTO
YOUR TRANSFERRED GRADUATION
RATES.
WITH SPECIFIC EMPHASIS ON
CLOSING ACHIEVEMENT GAPS FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY GROUPS.
THIS IS THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
ADOPTED BY THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
COMMITS THE UNIVERSITY TOO
AMBITIOUS GRADUATION GOALS
INCREASING THE FOUR YEAR
FRESHMAN GRADUATION RATE TO AT
LEAST 40%.
INCREASE IN THE TWO YEAR
TRANSFER GRADUATION RATE TO AT
LEAST 45%.
INCLUDING ELCA AND INCLUDING GAS
ALCHEMIST'S DREAM THAT THE
TARGET STUDENTS AND APPEARS.
TODAY THE STATE HAS PROVIDED
OVER A HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
MILLION GENERAL FUND TO THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE INCLUDING
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AT
GENERAL FUND ONGOING IN THE
CURRENT YEAR.
THE BUDGET PROVIDES AN
ADDITIONAL FORTY FIVE MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FORTY FIVE
MILLION I'M GOING GENERAL FUND
TO SUPPORT THIS CRITICAL WORK.
THE FOURTH AND FINAL PIECE OF
OUR PROPOSAL ADDRESSES CRITICAL
FACILITIES NEEDS OF THE CSU.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALLOCATES
TWO HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE
CSU TO HELP ADDRESSES DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG.
AND EXPAND ON CAMPUS CHILD CARE
CENTRES.
REGARD THE UC.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES A
THREE POINT NINE BILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THE TEN
UC CAMPUSES IN ROLE PROXIMALLY
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
STUDENTS.
WITH ANOTHER FORTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS CONNECTED TO ITS
EXTENSION PROGRAMS.
THE BUDGET PROPOSES AN INCREASE
OF THREE HUNDRED NINETY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND FOR
THE UNIVERSITY OF WHICH TWO
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS IS
I'M GOING.
THE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES.
A ONE HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLAR --
ALL ONE TIME --
SUPPORT FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS TWO MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME TO SUPPORT A TO DEVELOP AND
EXPAND TO GREET FOR COMPLETION
PROGRAMS THAT USE EXTENSION
CENTERS.
THIS INVESTMENT IS MORE THAN
FOUR TIMES LARGER THAN WHAT WAS
PROPOSED IN LAST YEAR'S
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES
TWO HUNDRED MILLION ONGOING
GENERAL FUND CONSISTING OF ONE
HUNDRED NINETEEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION FOR CONTRACTUALLY
OBLIGATED COMPENSATION.
NOT SELLING PRICE INCREASES IN
SIMILAR COSTS. FORTY NINE POINT
NINE MILLION FOR DEGREE
ATTAINMENT INSTANCE SERVICES
PROGRAMS. FIFTEEN MILLION TO
ADDRESS STERN HUNGER AND
HOMELESSNESS TEN MILLION TO
SUPPORT THE MOMENT PAY FOURTH
ONE TIME FUNDS.
AND FIVE POINT THREE MILLION FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO ENDS
PRACTICE OF SHIFTING GENERAL
FUND OUT OF UC'S BASED BUDGET
BACK FILLING WITH PROPOSITION
FIFTY SIX MONTHS.
THE SAID TO SUPPORT GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION.
THIS CHANGE PROVIDES THE UC WITH
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
GENERAL FUND.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO ADDRESS
UC'S ESTIMATED FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
BACKLOG AND FIFTEEN MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND.
WILL BE AVAILABLE TO THE UC TO
EXPAND A PILOT DEGREE COMPLETION
PROGRAMS EXPANSE OF DIFFICULT
PROGRAMS EXTENSION CENTERS.
ALTHOUGH THESE OUT YOUR
COMMITMENTS DO NOT APPEAR IN THE
BUDGET BILL.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED
ONE POINT THREE MILLION ONLINE
GENERAL FUND FOR IMMIGRANT LEGAL
SERVICES BEGINNING IN --
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND ONE
MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND FOR
FIREARM VIOLENCE RESEARCH
BEGINNING IN. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO TO ENSURE THAT THESE
PROGRAMS OF ONGOING SUPPORT --
BUT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
CONTAINS SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
AID PROPOSALS THAT'LL HELP SOON
PARENTS NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROJECTS
APPROXIMATELY FOUR NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND STUDENTS.
WE'LL SEE NEARLY TWO POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS OF AID IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THE
CALDERON PROGRAM THE STATE'S
LARGEST FINANCIALLY PROGRAM.
IS EXPECTED TO SERVE ABOUT FOUR
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND STUDENTS
TO PROVIDE MORE THAN TWO POINT
FOUR BILLION IN AID.
SPECIFICALLY THE BUDGET INCLUDES
A HUNDRED TWENTY ONE POINT SIX
MILLION AN ONGOING GENERAL FUND.
TO INCREASE OUR PROVIDE ACCESS
WORDS TO STERN PARENTS.
STUDENTS ATTENDING THE CSU YOU
SEE AND THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WHO HAVE DEPENDENT CHILDREN
RECEIVE A CAL GRANT A OR B.
WE'LL GET AN ANNUAL ACCESS WORTH
UP TO SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS.
CAL GRANT SEE STUDENTS WILL SEE
THE BROKEN SUPPLIES GRANT
INCREASE FROM 1-009-410-0090
FOUR DOLLARS TO FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
THE BUDGET ALSO FRIENDS IS NINE
POINT SIX MILLION TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF NEW COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANT AWARDS BY FOUR
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY FROM
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TO THIRTY
THOUSAND COMPARE OF CAL GRANT
RECIPIENTS ARE OFTEN
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS WHO ARE.
WHO ARE OLDER FROM LA LOWER
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS AND FACE THREE
SPEAKERS TO COMPLETION?
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
COMPETITIVE AWARDS IMPROVES
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY FOR
STUDENTS WITH FINANCIAL NEED
WEATHER WISE WOULD NOT QUALIFY
FOR CAL GRANT AWARD.
WITH THAT WILL CLOSE AND WE'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU.
WELL FINANCES AMID SAY YOU GREAT
PRESENTATION AND WE CERTAINLY
WANT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR IN
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THIS
BUDGET.
IT'S ROBUST AND WORK NEEDS TO BE.
YOU KNOW YOU HEARD THE THE V.
YOU SEE IN THE C. ISSUE
PRESENTATION WITH RESPECT.
TO THE DESIRE FOR SOME MULTI
YEAR.
LEVEL OF CERTAINTY WITH RESPECT
TO THEIR FINANCING AND IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT YOU KNOW FISCAL
SEARCH CERTAINTY FOR STUDENTS.
PROBABLY DEPENDS ON FISCAL
CERTAINTY FOR OUR INSTITUTIONS
OF HIGHER.
EDUCATION TO SOME EXTENT AND
WHETHER IT'S THROUGH A HIGHER
EDUCATION RESERVE ACCOUNT OR OR
SOMETHING WE OUGHT TO TAKE A
LOOK AT HOW WE CAN.
SORT OF LEVEL OUT THE THE
BUDGETING PROCESS FOR YOU SEE
AND SEE ISSUES SO THERE'S SOME
PREDICTABILITY GIVEN THE FACT
THAT THEY ADMIT STUDENTS AND
IT'S NOT A ONE OFF THING IT'S A
ONE YEAR TWO YEARS THREE OR FOUR
YEAR TO GET OUT OR FIVE OR SIX
TO GET.
OUT WITH A DEGREE SO.
SOME CERTAINTY IN THE LEVEL OF
FUNDING WOULD PROBABLY HELP BUT
GREAT JOB.
HELLO.
I'M SAYING SHOULD HAVE A HAND
OUT IN FRONT OF YOU OVERVIEW OF
EDUCATION PROPOSALS THE FIRST
FOUR PAGES ARE LARGELY THERE FOR
YOUR REFERENCE THERE'S JUST
GOING TO HIGHLIGHT.
A COUPLE OF THINGS ON EACH PAGE
SO THE FIRST PAGES ALL THE EARLY
EDUCATION PROPOSALS YOU FOR
QUITE A BIT ABOUT.
I WOULD POINT OUT THAT 75% OF
ABOUT ONE POINT SIX BILLION IN
NEW EARLY ON SPENDING THIS FOR
ONE TIME INITIATIVES.
THE THOUGHT OF QUARTERS FOR NEW
ONGOING SPENDING SOME OF THAT
NEW ON GOING SPENDING AS
ASSOCIATED WITH GROWTH IN COSTS
FROM PREVIOUSLY ADOPTED POLICIES.
PAGE TWO IS ALL THE NINETY EIGHT
PROPOSALS YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT TWO
POINT NINE BILLION VIRTUALLY ALL
OF THIS IS ONGOING.
BUT IS SIGNIFICANT OUR TURN TO
IT ALL MEANT.
PAGE THREE IS ALL THE HIGHER%
EDUCATION PROPOSALS BOTH NINETY
EIGHT AND NINE NINETY EIGHT
ABOUT 30% SO THOUGHT ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION LISTED AS ONE TIME.
THE REMAINING IS ONGOING SO THE
FIRST THE BUDGET COMMITTEE AS A
WHOLE IS JUST THE ARCHITECTURE
OF YOUR BUDGET SO HE'S GOT TWO
POINT NINE BILLION AN ON GOING
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS
AND COLLEGES.
HE HAS TWO POINT SEVEN BILLION
AND NON NINETY EIGHT FOR ALL
OTHER AREAS OF THE BUDGET.
OF THAT TWO POINT SEVEN BILLION
AND NINE NINETY EIGHT SPENDING
ABOUT A BILLION IS IN THE
EDUCATION AREA.
SO OF THAT BILLION ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION AS FOR
MORE UNIVERSITY AND AIDS FUNDING
IN ABOUT THREE INTERN FIFTY
MILLION IS FOR EARLY EDUCATION
THE NUMBER I JUST HEARD ON A FEW
PAGES AGO.
SO THOSE ARE THE FIRST ORDER
DECISIONS FOR YOU AS WE WENT
THROUGH OUR ANALYSIS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE IDENTIFIED
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SOME MILLION AN ON GOING NINE
NINETY EIGHT SPENDING THAT WE
THINK YOU MIGHT WANT TO RESET
THAT.
AND ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED SOME
MILLION AND ONE TIMES FUNDING SO
WE THINK THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR YOU TO IMPROVE THE BUDGET
MAKE IT MORE EFFICIENT PUT YOUR
STAMP ON IT.
A HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THOSE IN A
MOMENT.
IN ADDITION TO ALL THE GENERAL
FUND SPENDING YOU'VE BEEN
TALKING ALSO THIS MORNING ABOUT
BOND FUNDED ACTIVITIES SO PAGE.
FOR IS ALL OF THE CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS FOR HIGHER EDUCATION.
THOSE PROJECTS ARE TYPICALLY RUN
THROUGH THE BUDGET CYCLE HE
TWELVE PROJECTS AREN'T LISTED
HERE BECAUSE WE DON'T PUT THEM
THROUGH THE BUDGET BUT THERE'S
ANOTHER ONE AND A HALF BILLION
IN PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE FUNDING
FOR K..
TWELVE YOU CAN SEE SOME
DIFFERENCES IN APPROACH FOR
EXAMPLE FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THE ADMINISTRATION IS
JUST FUNDING PLAN THEIR PLANS
AND WORKING DRAWINGS THAT'S THE
TRADITIONAL STATE APPROACHES TO
DISCO PROJECT PHASE BY PHASE.
FOR THE GET CSU ALL PHASES ARE
BEING OF FINANCE SIMULTANEOUSLY
AND FOR YOU SEE IT'S JUST THE
CONSTRUCTION PHASE OF THEIR
PROJECTS.
BECAUSE I WAS CONVERSATION
EARLIER THIS MORNING I JUST STOP
FOR A MOMENT IF THERE IS GOING
TO BE CONVERSATION OF THE NEW
BONDS THAT WOULD INCLUDE HE
UNIVERSITY IS --
JUST AS A HISTORICAL REVIEW BACK
IN THIRTEEN FOURTEEN FOR YOU SEE
AND BACK AND FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
FOR CSU THE STATE MADE A
DECISION AT THAT TIME. TO TAKE
THE STATE THAT SERVICE AMOUNT
ROLL IT INTO THE UNIVERSITY'S
MAIN SUPPORT ITEM SUCH THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE --
A BETTER CONVERSATION WAS THE
THEORY ABOUT THE TRADE OFFS
BETWEEN THEIR CAPITAL AND
SUPPORT BUDGETS SO IF YOU WERE
TO WANT TO TAKE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH ME FORWARD YOU MIGHT
WANT TO REVISIT HOW MUCH OF
THEIR EXISTING BUDGET IS GOING
FOR DOT SERVICE.
AT LEAST HAVE THAT AS ONE OF
YOUR CONSIDERATIONS.
SO THE REST OF THE HAND OUT IS
OUR ANALYSIS OF THE BUDGET SO
PAGE FIVE IS --
HIGHLIGHTING A FEW THINGS THAT
YOU'LL HEAR MORE DEEPLY ABOUT IN
THE EARLY ADDS DR.
THE LARGEST OF THE GOVERNOR'S
ONE TIME PROPOSED BROWN'S TRYING
TO PROMOTE MORE FULL DAY
PROGRAMS IT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
STATE STARTED THIS YEAR.
SO WE WENT AND WE LOOKED AT THE
FIRST ROUND APPLICATIONS FOR THE
HUNDRED MILLION THE STATE
PROVIDED THIS YEAR.
AND DISCOVERED THAT VIRTUALLY
ALL OF IT IS GOING TO DISTRICTS
WHO ALREADY RUN ONLY FULL DAY
PROGRAMS.
SO WE THINK THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT YOU MIGHT WANT
TO REVISIT THE PROPOSAL YOU
COULD USE IT FOR HIGHER RESERVES
YOU COULD USE THAT FOR
ADDITIONAL SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT
PENSION PAYMENT.
IF YOU DID ON THE LAST ONE TO DO
SOMETHING IN IN THIS AREA WE
WOULD SUGGEST YOU CREATE A FAR
MORE TARGETED PROGRAM SO WHERE
AS MOST OF THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
MONEY IS GOING TO DISTRICTS THAT
ALREADY RUN FULL DAY PROGRAMS.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO THINK ABOUT A
MUCH MORE TARGETED PROGRAM IT
WOULD ONLY BE FOR DISTRICTS
RUNNING PART DAY PROGRAMS DUE TO
FILL PHYLLIS FACILITY
CONSTRAINTS.
THAT COULDN'T BE ADDRESSED
THROUGH THE STATE'S REGULAR
SCHOOL FACILITY PROGRAM THAT
WOULD BE THE ONE WAY YOU COULD
TARGET AT TO MAKE SURE YOU'RE
GETTING WHAT YOU WANT.
IT MIGHT BE THAT YOU COULD DO
THAT FOR MUCH LESS MONEY THAN
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION.
THE SECOND LARGEST PROPOSALS THE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION FOR CHILD
CARE WORK FORCE AND FACILITIES.
THE STATE ALREADY HAS ONGOING
PROGRAMS IN THESE TWO AREAS A
SPENDS ABOUT FIFTY MILLION
ANNUALLY ON PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR CHILDCARE
WORKERS.
AND TRAIN OTHERS FORMS FORMS OF
TRAINING --
AND IT HAS A FACILITY REVOLVING
LOAN FUND.
SO I THINK WITH THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION IS INTENDED TO DO IS TO
ADDRESS ISSUES THAT CAN BE
ADJUSTED IS EXISTING ONGOING
PROGRAMS.
BUT THERE'S A LOT THE STATE
DOESN'T KNOW IN IS AREAS THAT
DOESN'T HAVE BASIC INFORMATION
LIKE THE NUMBER OF CHILD CARE
WORKERS THEIR EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT THEIR CREDENTIALS.
HOW LONG THEY STAY WHY THEY
LEAVE? FOR FACILITIES WE DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY PROVIDERS OWN OR
LEASE OF THOSE THAT LEASE WE
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY ARE
SUBSIDIZED THROUGH OTHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
WE DON'T KNOW THE GREATEST
FACILITY CHALLENGE US AND WE
DON'T KNOW IF THOSE CHALLENGES
VARY ACROSS THE STATE.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF INFORMATION
WE THINK THE STATE COULD OLLECT
BEFORE IT --
GOES AHEAD AND A PORTIONS THOSE
FIVE MIGHT BE AN AREA WHERE YOU
WOULD WANT TO SPEND IN THE
FUTURE YOU COULD SET THOSE
MONIES ASIDE.
STUDY THE ISSUES UPON GETTING
THE RESULTS GO AHEAD AND OF
COURSE IN THE FUNDS IN FUTURE
YEARS.
THERE IS A CONVERSATION EARLIER
ABOUT THE PRESCHOOL PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND IT TO ALTHOUGH INCOME
STUDENTS CHILDREN.
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT THE
EXPANSION IS JUST VERY AMBITIOUS
IF YOU WERE TO LOOK AT ADDING
TIME THOUSAND SLOTS IN A SINGLE
YEAR IT'S A 40% INCREASE FOR
THESE PROVIDERS WHO WOULD BE
TASKED WITH DOING NOT.
A BIG JOB FOR CD E. JUST TO
SOLICIT APPLICATIONS REVIEW THEM
FOR PROVIDERS TO FIND FACILITIES
AND STAFF.
SO WE'D RECOMMEND A SLOW
ARAMBULA MAYBE SOMETHING MORE ON
THE ORDER OF TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS AT CHILDREN.
I WOULD AGAIN FREE UP SOME MONEY
IN YOUR BUDGET FOR OTHER THINGS
THIS YEAR.
THE GOVERNOR ALSO IS PROPOSING
TO REMOVE THE WORK REQUIREMENT
FOR THE FULL DAY SLOTS BUT HE
DOESN'T HAVE ANY OF THE FISCAL
IMPACT BUILT INTO HIS BUDGET.
SO IF THERE WERE FAMILIES WHO
ARE NOW USING PARK DAY SLOTS WHO
ALL WOULD BECOME ELIGIBLE FOR
FULL DAY THOUGHTS IF ANY OF THEM
CHOOSE TO ENROLL FULL DAY.
YOUR PROGRAMS GOING TO COST MUCH
MORE THAN IS CURRENTLY IN YOUR
BUDGET SO IF HALF OF THE
FAMILIES DECIDED TO DO FULL THEY
WERE IN THE PAST THEY WOULD HAVE
THEM PART TODAY.
THE PROGRAM'S GOING TO BE THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SOME MILLION
DOLLARS MORE EXPENSIVE OBVIOUSLY
A FULL DAY SLOTS MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN PARTY SLOT MORE
THAN DOUBLE THE COST.
WITH THAT TEND.
TO WITH THAT TEND TO CUT THE
SLOTS FOR FAMILIES WHO ACTUALLY
NEED HAVE FULL DAY CARE.
YES SO IF YOU HAVE ANY
PROJECTIONS ON ON THE IMPACT.
I'M SO THERE WOULD BE TWO WAYS
TO APPROACH A IF YOU DID WANT TO
DO THE POLICY YOU COULD JUST PUT
THE MONEY BEHIND IT AND MAKE
SURE YOU DIDN'T SEE THE DROP IN
FULL DRAIN.
OTHERWISE YOU WOULD SEE THE DROP
IN CHILDREN AND THE WAY WE
UNDERSTAND IT WOULD BECOME
TRIAGE DOES WE TRIAGE TODAY
WHICH WOULD BECOME INCOME BASED
SO EVEN IF A FAMILY WAS WORKING
THEY MIGHT YOU LOSE THEIR SLOT
JUST BECAUSE THEY WERE SLIGHTLY
HIGHER INCOME THAN SOMEBODY WHO
STAYS AT HOME.
SO GETS TO THE HEART OF YOUR
FAMILY WHO IS CONTINUING TO WORK --
OR JUST BECAUSE YOU WANT EVERY
LOW INCOME CHILD REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THEIR PARENTS ARE
WORKING TO BE ABLE TO AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF A FULL DAY PROGRAM
BUT YES ONE OF THE IMPLICATIONS
AS IF YOU DON'T PROVIDE.
THE SUBSTANTIALLY MORE MONEY YOU
NEED TO COVER THE COST OF THE
POLICY THEN FEWER CHILDREN WILL
BE SERVED HIM VERY LIKELY FEWER
CHILDREN FROM WORKING FAMILIES
ARE COUNTERPRODUCTIVE SO I WHAT
I THINK WITH SOME FOLKS.
WOULD LIKE TO SEE HAPPEN FAMILY
WERE TO WORK ONE NO CAN'T WORK.
WHICH PUTS THEM INTO A DIFFERENT.
INCOME CATEGORY IT SORT OF SICK
SIR CIRCULAR SOMEBODY NEEDS TO
DO SOME ANALYSIS.
OKAY WE WHAT CAN KERR SO I'M
TURNING.
TO NINETY EIGHT IS ONE OF THE
MOST STREET FOR NINETY EIGHT
BUDGET SHALL EVER SEE MOST OF
THE MONEY'S GOING FOR COLA.
AND YOU'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
WHAT MAY MIGHT LOOK LIKE IT
MIGHT NOT BE ONE OF THESE A FULL
SURPRISES WHERE YOU HAVE A LOT
MORE TO WORK WITH AND MADE IT
COULD BE YOU EVEN HAVE A LITTLE
BIT LESS TO WORK WITH.
IF STATE REVENUE COMES IN UNDER
THE JANUARY PROJECTIONS WHICH IT
IS TO DATE UNDER PROJECTIONS IN
THE GUARANTEES GONNA DROP JUST
THAT'S HOW THE FORMULA WORKS
IT'LL DROP VERY ROUGHLY FIFTY
CENTS ON THE DOLLAR.
SO WE JUST WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU
TO THINK NOW ABOUT YOUR
PRIORITIES ABOVE GROWTH IN COLAS
ADMINISTRATION'S PRIORITIES ARE
SPECIAL ED IN THAT COLLEGE
PROMISE PROGRAM.
EVEN IF YOU WERE TO CARE ABOUT
THOSE AREAS WE THINK THERE ARE
SOME MORE EFFICIENT WAYS YOU
COULD GO ABOUT --
BOTH PUTTING MORE MONEY INTO
SPECIAL EDUCATION AS WELL AS
PUTTING MORE MONEY INTO
FINANCIAL AID.
WE ALSO SUGGEST THAT YOU JUST
THINK ABOUT HOW TO POSITION
SCHOOLS FOR WHAT WE THINK WILL
BE ON THE HORIZON WHETHER IT'S
NEXT YEAR OR A FEW YEARS FROM
NOW RGARDING AN ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN.
SO THE GOVERNOR'S PACKAGE BEFORE
YOU HAS NO ONE TIME CUSHION OVER
THE LAST SIX YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE STATE HAVE
PUT IN A ONE TIME QUESTION.
ITS RANGE FROM FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION TO ONE POINT TWO BILLION
BUT IT'S ALWAYS HAD SOMETHING
IT'S AVERAGE SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION THERE'S NONE OF THAT AND
THE BUDGET BEFORE YOU.
WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO THINK ABOUT
NOT ONLY IS THERE NOT A QUESTION
BUT THE GOVERNOR AS ACTUALLY
USING SOME ONE TIME FUNDING TO
SUPPORT ON GOING PROGRAM.
SO THAT MEANS YOU'RE GOING TO
GET TO NEXT YEAR AND THE VERY
FIRST CALL ON YOUR DOLLARS IS
GOING TO BE TO BACK FILL THIS
WHOLE.
STATE SOMETIMES DOES THIS WHEN
IT'S IN REALLY TIGHT BUDGET
TIMES WE DON'T ENCOURAGE YOU TO
DO IT WHEN YOU'RE IN A GOOD
BUDGET SITUATION SO THAT WHOLE
RIGHT NOW IS SEVENTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
WE ALSO AS YOU WILL HEAR MORE
ABOUT OUR YOU'VE HEARD A LITTLE
BIT ALREADY ON THE PENSIONS THE
GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT TO GIVE A GREAT
RELIEF TO DISTRICTS.
BUT THIS IS A GOOD FISCAL
ENVIRONMENT FOR PEOPLE SENDING
IS GOING UP THREE POINT 8% SO WE
WOULD SUGGEST THIS ISN'T THE
RIGHT TIME TO BE OFFERING RIGHT
RELIEF YOU COULD PUT THAT SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A
SCIENCE.
AND GIVE THEM RATE RELIEF WHEN
THEY'RE PER PEOPLE FINDING AS
FLAT OR DECLINING THERE BUDGET
SITUATIONS ARE MUCH TIGHTER THAN
THEY ARE TODAY.
WHAT PROP NINETY EIGHT IS
AMONGST THE MOST STRAIGHTFORWARD
BUDGET SHOW EVER SEE THERE'S
MANY MORE MOVING PIECES TO HIRE
ADD YOU'VE EXPLORED A LOT OF
THOSE ALREADY THIS MORNING?
WE THINK THE BUDGET THE
GOVERNOR'S BASIC APPROACH IS
VERY CONSTRUCTIVE AS OPPOSED TO
THE FORMER ADMINISTRATION WHO
GAVE A LOT OF MONEY AND HANDS
OFF WALKED AWAY.
THIS GOVERNOR'S TELLING YOU WHAT
HE CARES ABOUT WE THINK THAT'S
PRODUCTIVE YOU CAN SEE HOW WELL
THOSE PARTIES ARE LINED WITH
YOUR OWN. ONE OF THE LARGEST --
PARTS OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
IS FOR COMPENSATION.
HE HAS SUFFICIENT FUNDING AND
HAS BUDGET ACROSS THE SEGMENTS
TO PROVIDE TWO AND A HALF TO
THREE AND A HALF PERCENT SALARY
INCREASES FOR MOST EMPLOYEE
GROUPS.
MOST NINETEEN TWENTY CONTRACTS
HAVE BEEN FINALIZED AND THEIR
AGREED UPON NEGOTIATED RATE
INCREASES ARE IN THAT RANGE.
HE DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING BUILT
INTO HIS PROPOSAL FOR YOU SEE
NON REPRESENTED EMPLOYEES WHICH
IS ALL THEIR FACULTIES SO ABOUT
TWO THIRDS OF THEIR CORE FUNDED
STAFF IS NOT REPRESENTED.
YOU SEE HOW REQUESTED 3%.
THE THINKING IS THAT THEY CAN
FIND SOME OTHER REVENUE STREAMS
TO COVER THAT COST BUT AGAIN
IT'S NOT EXPLICITLY IN THE
BUDGET FOR YOU.
WE WOULD SUGGEST YOU MIGHT WANT
TO CONSIDER.
EXPLORING WITH UC AND CSU THEM
DOING --
STAFFING ANALYSIS WE THINK THEY
SHOULD BE DOING THIS REGULARLY
AND THEY WOULD LOOK AT
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION DATA.
AND THEN AT LEAST FOR NEXT YEAR
YOU CAN HAVE INFORM YOUR
CONVERSATIONS NEXT YEAR BUT BUT
NON FACULTY PERSONNEL.
I'M ACTUALLY ACROSS THE BOARD SO
WE HAVE SOME INFORMATION
REGULARLY ON FACULTY
COMPENSATION BUT WE DON'T ON
RETENTION AND RECRUITMENT WE
ONLY GET THAT DATA THROUGH
PERIODIC STUDIES AND WE HAVE
VERY LITTLE DATA ON NON TENURE
TRACK OR OTHER.
FORMS OF UNIVERSITY STAFF.
I'M ON A ROLL IT TARGETS YOU'VE
HEARD THAT IT'S A HALF A PERCENT
FOR THE COLLEGES 2% FOR CSU
NOTHING FOR YOU SEE AND THERE'S
NOT A LOT OF GUIDING FACTOR IS
THAT EXPLAINS THE DIFFERENCE AS
WE WOULD UGGEST YOU TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT SOME BASIC FACTORS.
NUMBER OF HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES
AND HOW THAT'S CHANGING THE
EXISTING ENROLLMENT LEVELS AND
HOW WELL A LINE THEY ARE WITH
THE MASTER PLAN.
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS ARE BEING
REDIRECTED ON THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WHO ARE JUST BEING
TURNED AWAY.
THE FIRST TWO FACTORS WOULD
SUGGEST THAT YOU DON'T NEED A
HIGHER ENROLLMENT TARGET NEXT
YEAR IN THE LAST TWO FACTORS
WOULD SUGGEST SOME GROWTH MIGHT
BE WARRANTED.
SO ON THE IMPROVEMENTS
INITIATIVES WE JUST SUGGEST IF
YOU DO DECIDE AND THERE'S SOME
PRETTY.
TOUGH TRADE OFFS AS TO WHETHER
YOU WANT TO CONTINUE TO PUT
MONEY AND CITIES THE NATIONAL
DOES BUT WERE YOU.
TO ONE TWO WE WE JUST ENCOURAGE
YOU TO THINK ABOUT HOW MEAN
EXPLICIT EXPECTATIONS THAT THE
SEGMENTS WOULD CONTINUE TO
IMPROVE YOU WOULD HAVE
EXPECTATIONS THAT THEIR
GRADUATES WOULD IMPROVE THEIR
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS WOULD NARROW
THEIR ACCESS UNIT TAKING WOULD
BE REDUCED.
THAT WOULD BE A VERY EXPLICIT
CLEAR EXPECTATION.
ON THE LIVING A MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES THE STATE HAS A LONG
STANDING POLICY OF COVERING
TUITION FOR ALL FINANCIALLY
NEEDY STUDENTS BUT IT DOESN'T
HAVE A LARGE SCALE LONG STANDING
POLICY ON HOW TO COVER LIVING
COSTS.
AND YOU HAD A BIT OF THAT
CONVERSATION THIS MORNING WHAT
WOULD BE THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT.
BUT BECAUSE THIS COULD BE A
MAJOR EW POLICY FOR THE STATE
WITH MAJOR NEW COST IMPLICATIONS
RESEARCHERS.
ARE LEARNING AS MUCH AS THE
STATE KIND C. SO WE THINK
THERE'S LOTS THAT COULD BE
LEARNED.
THE INCIDENTS AN UNDERLYING
CAUSES OF HOUSING A FEW FOOD AND
SECURITY WHY IT IS SO HIGH ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES MUCH HIGHER
THAN THE CALIFORNIA POPULATION
AT LARGE.
OBTAIN RELIABLE COST OF
ATTENDANCE DATA FOR ALL KINDS OF
STUDENTS INCLUDING STUDENT
PARENTS.
UNDERSTAND THE INTERACTION OF
FINANCIAL AID WITH ALL THE OTHER
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
DESIGNED TO HELP INDIVIDUALS
WITH FOOD AND HOUSING.
FIGURE OUT THE TRADE OFFS ARE AT
LEAST CONTEMPLATE THE TRADE OFFS
BETWEEN PRETTY MORE MONEY AND TO
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND MORE MONEY
AND TO LOW INCOME FAMILIES THAT
LARGE.
AND HAVE A MUCH BETTER SENSE OF
WHAT IS THE UNMET NEED AND WHAT
ARE YOUR OPTIONS FOR COVERING
THEM I THINK YOU COULD GO
THROUGH THE SAME ISSUES WITH
MENTAL HEALTH THERE'S JUST A LOT
THAT THE STATE DOESN'T KNOW YET.
AND I THINK BEFORE THE STATE
WOULD CREATE A PROGRAM JUST FOR
YOU SEE STUDENTS FOR EXAMPLE IN
MY ONE A STEP BACK AND LEARN A
LOT MORE ABOUT THE ISSUE ACROSS
THE STATE.
I'M TUITION PREDICTABILITY THERE
SEEMS TO BE BROAD CONSENSUS THIS
WOULD BE A GOOD THING IF SOMEHOW
THE STATE COULD FIGURE OUT HOW
TO HAVE MORE PREDICTABLE TUITION
NOT HIKES DURING.
RECESSIONS AND THEN FLAT FOR
LONG PERIODS OF TIME ELSEWHERE.
WE THINK THE BEST WAY TO DO THIS
IS MORE RESERVE.
SO THE WAY IS HOW HOW DO YOU
FIGURE OUT HOW TO BUILD UP YOUR
RESEARCH.
AND ONE WAY IS TO AT LEAST
CONSIDER I'M TAKING THESE COST
INCREASES BEFORE YOU WHETHER
THEY BE FOR FACULTY OR FOR
STUDENTS SUPPORT --
AND HAVING NON FINANCIALLY NEEDY
STUDENTS ARE SOME OF THAT COST
SO IF ALL COSTS ARE GOING UP 3%
BOTH THE STATE AND NON
FINANCIALLY NEEDY STUDENTS THE
ONES THAT ARE PAYING THE TUITION
AND NOT ALL THE CAL GRANT
STUDENTS.
I WHICH SHARON THOSE COSTS.
RIGHT NOW NON FINANCIALLY NEEDY
STUDENTS AT CS YOU PAY 23% OF
THEIR EDUCATION COSTA NOTCSU
I'M SORRY AT UC 13%.
IT'S LOWER AT YOU SEE BECAUSE OF
ALL THEIR NON RESIDENT TUITION
AND THEY CAN USE THAT TO CROSS
SUBSIDIZE THEIR RESIDENTS.
BUT THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE NON NEEDY
STUDENTS ARE PAYING TODAY SO THE
QUESTION BEFORE YOU IS WHETHER
YOU WANT TO JUST KEEP THEM WHERE
THEY'RE ADDED --
THEY'RE DROPPING THEIR SURE HAS
CONSISTENTLY BEEN DROPPING OVER
THE SIX YEARS WERE FEES HAVE
BEEN FLAT.
IF YOU HAD A POLICY WHERE AS
RESERVES ARE THE BEST WAY TO
SIGNAL YOUR INTENTION TO KEEP
TUITION PREDICTABLE OVER TIME A
SHERIFF COST POLICY THAT WOULD
SAY.
A NON FINANCIALLY NEEDY FOR
STUDENT THERE RESPONSIBLE FOR
WHATEVER YOU CHOOSE 102040% OF
COST.
IT WOULD HELP THEM KNOW WHETHER
THEY ENTER COLLEGE DURING A
RECESSION OR DURING A RECOVERY
THAT WOULD BE THE COST THEY
WOULD BE EXPECTED TO BEAR.
THE FINAL PAGES ON CAP OUT LATE --
WE AS YOU'VE HEARD A LOT A LOT
ABOUT SUGGEST THAT YOU EVEN
ACCELERATE MORE PROP FIFTY ONE
BOND --
PAYMENTS.
THE GOVERNOR HAS MUCH MORE THAN
THE PREVIOUS GOVERNOR DEAD
TRIPLE THE AMOUNT FOR K. TWELVE
THE BACKLOG IS SUBSTANTIAL WE
SUGGEST YOU GO AHEAD AND DO THE
ONE AND A HALFBILLION OR
SOMETHING OF THAT MAGNITUDE.
WITH COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE THINK
YOU COULD SUPPORT MORE PROJECTS
EVEN WITH THE GOVERNOR HE IS
PROPOSING MORE PROJECTS THAN IN
THE PAST ALMOST MORE THAN DOUBLE
THE PROJECTS THAT WERE APPROVED
EACH AT PROPOSED EACH OF THE
LAST TWO YEARS.
BUT HE'S STILL ON ABOUT A NINE
YEAR TRACK TO SPEND ALL THE PROP
FIFTY ONE DOLLAR SO YOU MIGHT
WANT TO THINK ABOUT EXPEDITING
NOT.
WE ALSO WOULD SUGGEST THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE GET ON THE SAME PAGE AS
TO THE STANDARDS THEY USE TO
EVALUATE THESE PROJECTS YOU
HEARD ABOUT THE DIFFERENCES
EARLIER.
IT DOES CREATE SOME FRUSTRATION
IN THE FIELD THAT THEY'RE NOT
QUITE SURE WHAT IT TAKES TO PUT
TOGETHER A GOOD FACILITY PROJECT.
WHERE ENCOURAGE THAT THAT FOR
THE UNIVERSITY IS THE
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING PROJECT
BY PROJECT AND SEEN IF THERE'S
JUSTIFICATION FOR IT?
NORMALLY THAT MEANS THAT WE LOOK
AT THE FACILITY UTILIZATION AND
SEE IF IT'S AT OR REACHED FOR IN
EXCESS OF EXISTING CAPACITY.
AND IS LOOKING AT COSTSTO MAKE
SURE THEY'RE REASONABLE WE THINK
THERE ARE STILL SOME
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOU TO REFINE
SOME OF THOSE PROJECTS --
AS YOU GO THROUGH THE SEASON
UNDER FOR MAINTENANCE AGAIN MANY
PEOPLE THINK IT'S A GOOD YOU
SOMEONE TIME FUNDS IT PREVENTS
COSTLIER REPAIRS FROM BEING
NEEDED DOWN THE ROAD.
BUT WE WOULD SUGGEST YOU GOT
SOME ACCOUNTABILITY WHAT
PROJECTS ARE GOING TO BE A HOT
UNDERTAKEN.
FINANCE REPORT A FEW YEARS AND
NOW FROM NOW WERE THEY UNDERTAKE
AND YOU'RE TRYING TO DO THIS TO
REDUCE THE BACKLOG WAS THE
BACKLOG REDUCED.
DO THE SEGMENTS HAVE A PLAN FOR
ULTIMATELY NOT HAVING THIS FOR
SOME BILLION AT EACH STATEMENT
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG.
SO WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS WITH THE REGARD TO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE PORTION OF
PROP FIFTY ONE DO YOU HAVE ANY
IDEA WHAT THE TOTAL AMOUNT.
AUTHORIZED WAS IN AND WHAT'S
BEEN.
YEAH AND IT'S IT'S TWO BILLION
UNDER PROP FIFTY ONE NOT
AVAILABLE IF YOU ARE TO APPROVE
EVERYTHING FROM A TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN
APPROVED TO DATE AND ALL OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS.
IT WOULD BE SOMETHING LIKE SIX
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MILLION THAT
YOU WOULD HAVE COMMITTED --
WE STILL THINK YOU COULD
PROBABLY AT THIS PHASE IN THE
GAME CENSURE THREE SOME YEARS
AND YOU COULD CONTEMPLATE.
DOING EVEN MORE THAN HAS THREE
HUNDRED SOME MILLION NOT HE'S
PROPOSE.
FOR NINETEEN TWENTY AND WITH
REGARD TO THE WE HAD THE BOND
CONVERSATION EARLIER POTENTIAL
BOND CONVERSATION ABOUT.
REVOLVING AROUND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND CAPITAL NEEDS IT
BOTH THE UC IN THE C. ISSUE --
CAMPUSES.
REFRESH MY RECOLLECTION ABOUT
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN AYE I WAS
HERE I SEEM TO REMEMBER.
WHAT I THINK I RECALL IS THAT
THE -- OF
THE OF THE BOND OBLIGATION WAS
TRANSFERRED FROM THE STATE.
TO IN THE CASE OF YOU SEE TO YOU
SEE THAT WHAT HAPPENED.
YEAH OUT WHERE WE WERE A LITTLE
BIT NERVOUS ABOUT THIS AT THE
TIME BECAUSE IT REPRESENTED SUCH
AS SIGNIFICANT DEPARTURE FROM
STATE PRACTICE HISTORICALLY.
BUT YES AND TWENTY THIRTEEN
FORTY THAT IT WANTED A NEW
PARADIGM WHERE RATHER THAN
THINKING ABOUT CAP OUT LAY AND
SUPPORT AS TWO SEPARATE ENTITIES
SEPARATE PARTS OF THE BUDGET WE
WOULD PULL THEM TOGETHER INTO
ONE ITEM AND EVERY YEAR IT MAKE
IT EASIER FOR YOU AND THE
SEGMENTS. TO WEIGH THE TRADE
OFFS BETWEEN MORE MONEY FOR
CAPITAL AND MORE MONEY FOR
SUPPORT.
SO AS PART OF THAT NEW PARADIGM
AND THE SHIFT TO IT THE STATE
CALCULATED IT NEW EFFECTIVELY
WHAT IT WAS PAYING FOR YOU SEE
GENERAL OBLIGATION BONDS AT THAT
PERIOD OF TIME.
IT WAS --
TWO HUNDRED SOME MILLION DOLLARS
AS I RECALL IT JUST SHIFTED INTO
THE MAIN ITEMS THAT WE NO LONGER
HAD A CAPITAL ITEM IN A SUPPORT
ITEM WE JUST HAD ONE MAIN ITEM.
AND SAID WELL YOU SEE YOU GO
FORTH AND MANAGER FACILITIES SO
SINCE THAT TIME YOU SEE HAS GONE
TO THE MARKET THROUGH UNIVERSITY
BONDS AND FINANCE THEIR PROJECTS.
AND THEY STILL HAVE THAT TWO
HUNDRED SOME MILLION SO THEY
STILL ARE CARRYING SOME STATE
GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND AT OF
THOSE THIRTY YEAR SOME PROJECTS
OF NOT RETIRED AT THIS POINT SO
THEY CONTINUE TO HAVE MAKE SURE
WE ARE AS A STATE AND THEY AS A
STATEMENT MAKE SURE.
THAT THOSE PAYMENTS ARE HONORED
SO I GUESS THE POINT OF THE
CONVERSATION IN THE POINT TO
LOOKING BACK TO A GENERAL
OBLIGATION BOND.
IS THEY MUST BE OUT OF BONDING.
OR DO WE HAVE INSUFFICIENT
BINDING CAPACITY.
TO TAKE CARE OF THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND CAPITAL NEEDS OF
THE UC CAMPUSES.
YEAH I THINK THOSE WOULD BE THE
KINDS OF ISSUES YOU WOULD WANNA
START CONTEMPLATING AGAIN ALSO
AS A REMINDER AS PART OF THE NEW
PARADIGM.
THE STATE PUTTING CAPS AS AN
EFFORT TO SAY OKAY WE'RE GONNA
DELEGATE TO YOU UC AND CSU HOW
TO MANAGE YOUR FACILITIES ENTER
OPERATIONS BUT WE DON'T WANT YOU
SPENDING MORE THAN 15% OF YOUR
BUDGET ANNUALLY ON THAT ON
CAPITOL THAT.
SO IT DID CREATE SOME MORE
FLEXIBILITY BUT WITH THIS OLD
CEMENT EXPECTATION THAT THEY NOT
SPEND MORE THAN YOU WANTED ON
THE CAPITAL SIDE SERVER GOES TO
THE MARKET WE PUT A LIMIT ON ON
THE FUNDING YOU EAT EXACTLY.
SEE ISSUE DO WE DO THE SAME
THING TO THE CSU CAMPUS YEAR
LIKE YOU JUST SAID A YEAR LATER
THEY HAVE THE SAME THE ISSUE IS
THE SAME ISSUES PRESUMABLY YOU
SEE DOES IN THAT REGARD.
AFTER [inaudible]
OKAY BUT ELEVEN QUESTIONS.
I'M GONNA GO BACK TO THE PRE
SCHOOL EXPANSION.
SO YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THE TEN THOUSAND
MORE SLOTS BUT THAT'S A LITTLE
SCARY WHEN YOU'RE THINKING THAT
LOGISTICALLY WE JUST COULDN'T DO
THAT IS THAT WHAT YOU THINK.
YEAH SO WE HAVE SOME I'M HIS
HISTORY WE CAN RELY UPON SO A
FEW YEARS AGO THE STATE GAVE
THESE NON ALLEY A PROVIDERS THE
ONES THAT ISSUE THOUSAND NEW
SLOTS AND THEY WERE ABLE TO USE
THEM OKAY --
BUT TEN THOUSAND SPOTS IS THIS
40% INCREASE AND SO WE THOUGHT
WELL YOU IDEALLY WANT THE SLOTS
TO BE YOU IS YOU'RE GOING TO BE
PUTTING MONEY BEHIND THEM SO WE
THINK.
TWENTY FIVE A HUNDRED NEW SLOTS
IS JUST A BIT OF A MORE
PRACTICAL --
NUMBER.
THE STATE HAS BEEN SO.
AGAIN YOUR IF YOU COULD AND
TWENTY FIVE MILLION THERE BUT
YOU MIGHT SEE A HUNDRED MILLION
OF THAT RIVER NEXT YEAR BECAUSE
YOU JUST WEREN'T ABLE TO GET THE
FOUGHT SHE WANTED SO THAT'S THE
RISK YOU FACE.
YOU CAN SET THIS TARGET HOWEVER
YOU WANT WE'RE TRYING TO SUGGEST
YOU SAID A LITTLE BIT MORE
CONSERVATIVELY SO YOU DON'T.
HAVE MONEY SITTING ASIDE IN
NINETEEN TWENTY THAT COULD GO
FOR SOME PURPOSE GOT IT THANK
YOU.
WE HAVE QUESTIONS I GUESS NOT.
THANK YOU ALL VERY VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION.
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
AT THE NEXT SERIES OF THESE
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS.
I THINK OF WHAT I WANT TO DO AT
THIS POINT WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
FIVE MINUTE RECESS IN A MINUTE
BUT I UNDERSTAND THERE MAY BE
SOME STUDENTS IN THE AUDIENCE
WHO WOULD HAVE.
SOMETHING.
TO SAY AND WANT TO PARTICIPATE
IN PUBLIC COMMENTS SO.
WHILE I'M GOING TO GENERALLY.
HOLD PUBLIC COMMENT UNTIL THE
END I'M GOING TO ALLOW THE
STUDENTS TO COME UP WE WERE IN
THE AUDIENCE AND PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT WE WELCOME YOU HERE SO.
PLEASE COME UP.
A GOOD MORNING CHIRAC AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS SUMMIT SEAL AND A CURRENT
STUDENT AT CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SACRAMENTO MAKING
PUBLIC COMMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION.
WE SUPPORT THE OVERALL FUNDING
LEVELS FOR THE CSU BUT WE
REQUEST THAT TWENTY MILLION BE
SET ASIDE FOR MENTAL HEALTH
EIGHTY NINE OF THIS FOR HIRING
OF COUNSELORS AND TWO MILLION.
FOR HOW REPORT --
NEW REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
CAMPUS MENTAL HEALTH SURVEYS.
GROWING CRISIS IS THE PHRASE
USED BY THE AMERICAN
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION
DESCRIBES STATE OF MENTAL HELP
ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES. 52% OF
STUDENTS REPORT FEELING HELPLESS
AND THIRTY NINE POINT 1%
REPORTED FEELING SO DEPRESSED
THEY COULDN'T FUNCTION.
THE INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
COUNSELING SERVICES RECOMMENDS A
RATIO OF A THOUSAND TO FIFTEEN
HUNDRED STUDENTS FOR EACH FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT COUNSELOR ON
CAMPUS.
WHEN THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WAS ASKED AT A SENATE AT THE
SENATE BUDGET MEETING THIS YEAR
BY?
SENATOR LEYVA WISE YES YOU
DIDN'T RECEIVE FUNDING FOR
MENTAL HEALTH LIKE THE C. S. USE
THE RESPONSE WAS THAT THE UC
BUDGET PRIORITIZE IT BUT THE CSU
DIDN'T.
SEE IF YOU MAY PRIORITIZE WHAT
MAY NOT HAVE HIGH TORQUE
PRIORITIZE MENTAL HEALTH FUNDING.
BUT IT NEEDS.
TO AS CHAIR OFFSET EARLIER
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ARE VITAL
STUDENT WELL BEING AND SUCCESS.
SEE IF THEY ASK THAT TWO MILLION
BE PRIORITIZED TO ADDRESS THE
MENTAL HEALTH FUNDING IN THE CSU
SYSTEM.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MARSHA SURVEY SURE I AM
A JUNIOR AT UC BERKELEY AND A
BOARD MEMBER OF THESE HOUSTON
ASSOCIATION WHEN I SAY THANK YOU
FOR GIVING US THE TIME TO SPEAK
COINCIDENTALLY I HAVE A
CALIFORNIA POLITICS CLASS AT
BERKELEY BACK THAT I THAT I NEED.
TO MAKE.
SO LAST YEAR I HELPED LEAD THE
UC STUDENT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE STATE --
THANKS TO THE LEGISLATURE WE
WERE ABLE TO SECURE THAT FUNDING
AND WE WERE ABLE TO AVOID A
TUITION HIKE FOR IN STATE
STUDENTS.
BUT AS YOU KNOW THAT MONEY WAS
ONE TIME.
SO WHILE WE ARE INCREDIBLY
EXCITED ABOUT THE ADDITIONAL TWO
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE NEW GOVERNOR.
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE MAKE THE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT OF NINETY
FIVE MILLION IN ONGOING FUNDS TO
MAKE LAST YEAR'S FUNDING
INCREASE PERMANENT.
THE OVER THE NEXT TWO MONTHS WE
AS YOU SEE STUDENT LEADERS WE
WILL BE HERE WE WOULD BE PUSHING
FOR THAT AND OTHER COMPONENTS OF
THE BUDGET REQUEST.
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE WE ARE
DESERVING OF THE SAME HIGH
QUALITY YOU SEE EDUCATION AS
GENERATIONS PAST THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME GOOD.
LUCK IN YOUR POLITICS CLASS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MY
ROSE AND I'M ALSO A STUDENT AT
UC BERKELEY.
I CHOSE A SCHOOL BECAUSE I WAS
PROMISED ONE OF THE BEST
EDUCATIONS IN THE WORLD.
YEAH I SING CLASSES WITH THREE
pPROFESSOR TELLS ME THAT THIS MAN
FOR FIFTY WHICH DIMINISHES MY
LEARNING.
AND I STRESS OVER IF I WILL HAVE
ENOUGH UNITS BEING OFFICIALLY
ENROLLED STUDENT HAS THE CLASSES
FOR MY MAJOR POLITICAL SCIENCE --
SO IMPACTED.
INCREASING THE QUANTITY OF
STUDENTS DECREASES THE QUALITY
OF OUR EDUCATION IF NOT PROPERLY
FUNDED.
THIS IS WHY IT IS CRUCIAL TO
SUPPORT THE UC'S ASKED FOR AN
ADDITIONAL SEVENTY TWO POINT SIX
MILLION.
IN ORDER TO BETTER SUPPORT THE
STUDENTS ALREADY ENROLLED AND TO
SUPPORT THE RISING NUMBER OF
STUDENTS THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS OUR PRE CORE AND I
TEN UC BERKELEY.
MOST LOW INCOME STUDENTS ARE
ALSO FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENTS.
AS A LOAN CONVERSATION CALLED
STUDENT IT WILL TAKE STUDENTS
LIKE ME ON AVERAGE MORE THAN
FOUR YEARS TO GRADUATE COLLEGE.
I RELY ON SUMMER SESSIONS TO
STAY ON TRACK TO GRADUATE IN A
TIMELY MANNER.
MORE IMPORTANTLY I RELY ON
FINANCIAL AID TO FINANCE MY
EDUCATION WITHOUT WHICH I WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO PURSUE MY STUDIES.
FOR THIS REASON I THINK SENATOR
OFF FOR ALL GRAND URGE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE TO ALLOCATE FOR
THE FUNDING. FOR THIS BILL.
THE SUMMER CAL GRANT ALLOW
STUDENTS LIKE ME FROM
UNDERPRIVILEGED BACKGROUNDS TO
STAY ON TRACK WITH MY ACADEMICS
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY.
MAKE MY ACADEMICS EVEN POSSIBLE
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING WAIT NO NO GOOD
AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS DAVE ON THOMAS AND
I'M A JUNIOR UC SANTA CRUZ AND
THE CHAIR OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS SO SEE ATION.
NOT OUT OF STATE STUDENTS
ASSOCIATION OR THE IN SPACE IN
ASSOCIATION I STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH MY INTERNATIONAL
PEERS OUT OF STATE PEERS AND AND
DOCUMENTS IS NOTPROTECTED BY AB.
FIVE FORTY WE APPRECIATE OF OF
THE UC KEEP IN STATE TUITION
FLAT HOWEVER THE BRITISH AN
AWFUL AND ARE RESIDENT STUDENTS.
WITH THE UC STUDENTS --
STATION STAND TO GET THE
POTENTIAL CAP ON OUR RESIDENTS
IN THE UC AND TUITION HIKE FOR
THE COMMUNITY THAT WILL BE ON
THE AGENDA FOR NEXT WEEK WE MUST
REMIND OURSELVES THE LEADERS OF
TOMORROW WILL COME FROM
CALIFORNIA AND OUTSIDE OF IT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS --
SORE LIGHTING ON THE FIRST YEAR
AT UC SANTA CRUZ I AM.
FIGHTING IT WILL BE DIFFICULT SO
PLEASE LIKE PART ANY ERECTIONS.
BECAUSE OF THAT OF THE HOMELESS
STUDENT.
SITUATION AT UC SANTA CRUZ IS
CURRENTLY CATASTROPHIC AROUND
ONE INCH WHEN STUDENTS.
LIVE WITHOUT ANY HOUSING AND
THAT NUMBER IS ONLY GOING TO
BECOME HIGH MEDICARE AND HOUSING
DAMAGES A GOOD PLACE TO START IS
FUND PROGRAMS WHICH CONNECT
STUDENTS OF HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES.
WHICH IS WHY I'M HERE TO
ADVOCATE FOR SB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT
WHICH ARE RAPIDLY HOUSING
PORTANTINO WHICH ALLOCATES
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS SERVICE
IF PASSED THE SENATE BILL.
BOB OKAY FUNDS THE CONNECTOR WAS
STUDENTS WITH THE RIGHT
RESOURCES THE CONNECT THEM WITH
HOUSING AND FINANCIAL AID
OPPORTUNITIES.
WITH THIS IN MIND I STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO LEGISLATIVE STATE
BUDGET PROPERLY REFLECTS THE
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM.
THANK YOU SENATORS VERA
DILIGENCE AND THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US NEXT.
HELLO MY NAME IS DEREK WILL HOME
I'M A STUDENT SAN FRANCISCO
STATE UNIVERSITY AND CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT OFFICER THE
CALIFORNIA STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION.
I WANT EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION
FOR YOUR SERVICE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA ON EDUCATION POLICY
IN FUNDING.
BUT I WANT TO BRING YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE MOMENT TO THE
REAL IMPACTS OF THESE POLICIES
ON THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
I'M A NONTRADITIONAL STUDENT HAS
RETURNED MY EDUCATION AFTER A
LONG PERIOD OF HOMELESSNESS
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AN
ADDICTION --
IT'S SAD THAT IT BROUGHT ME TO
PLACE RIGHT HAD TO LOSE
EVERYTHING TO REALLY BENEFIT
FROM FINANCIALLY DID MEANING
FLAYED DANCE MY EDUCATION.
NOW I'M GRADUATING THIS MAY IN
AN WITH A BACHELORS IN
COMMUNICATIONS WHEN THEN
MINORING GLOBAL PEACE HUMAN
RIGHTS AND JUSTICE.
BUT MY EDUCATION DOESN'T JUST
BENEFIT ME.
I AM PROUD OF RESEARCH I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO DO WITH OTHER STUDENTS
TO SAN FRANCISCO STATE ON THE ON
THE WAY THAT RACISM AFFECTS OUR
SEXUAL ATTRACTIONS AND RESHAPES
OUR COMMUNITIES.
I AM PROUD OF THE OPTION I HAD
TO TEACH A CLASS IN THE
EXPERIMENTAL COLLEGE ON THE
RHETORIC HOMELESSNESS WHERE WE
DECONSTRUCTED THE NARRATIVES
ABOUT HOW WE TALK ABOUT PEOPLE
WHO ARE EXPERIENCING THIS SOCIAL
PROBLEM.
I AM PROUD OF THE WORK HAD BEEN
ABLE TO DO IS IS AS A STUDENT
LEADER IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
THE OUR EDUCATION ISN'T JUST
ABOUT DOLLARS AND GRADUATING
IT'S ABOUT THE IMPACTS THAT WE
HAVE AN IMPROVING OUR HUMAN
POTENTIAL.
AND THAT IS THE THE BENEFIT THAT
THE PEOPLE CALIFORNIA RECEIVE AS
THE NEXT GENERATION --
ADVANCES THE PROSPERITY AND
ABUNDANCE CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SIR.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR PROGRESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MICHAEL WE OFTEN OMIT THIRTY
YEARS SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY
AND I'M FROM REDLANDS CALIFORNIA.
LAST YEAR MY RAP FOR SHARED
APARTMENT WAS EIGHT HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH --
AROUND SAN DIEGO STATE. TO PUT
THIS INTO PERSPECTIVE IF YOU
WERE IF YOU WERE TWENTY HOURS A
WEEK WHICH IS THE ON CAMPUS
MAXIMUM.
AT THE MINIMUM WAGE AND YOUR
ENTIRE PAYCHECK WILL GO TOWARDS
JUST RAN.
THAT'S NOT COUNTING TUITION
TEXTBOOKS CLASS SUPPLIES FOOD
TRANSPORTATION AND OTHER COSTS
OF LIVING. FIFTY STUDENTS WERE
PLEASED TO SEE SENATOR LEVELS
INTEREST AND HOW IT AT
AFFORDABILITY WITH SB.
TWO NINETY ONE WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE MORE SUPPORT FOR CSU
STUDENTS TWO EIGHT SUPPORT.
IN THE FUTURE OF THE STATE NEEDS
THE SUPPORT.
THE FUTURE OF THIS NATION NEEDS
THE SUPPORT FOR THE EDUCATION
THAT THEY NEED PLEASE HELP US
AND FIXING FINANCIAL AID.
WE'LL DO OUR BEST THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US SIR.
NEXT BUT RAISES UP A LITTLE BIT
HELLO HELLO.
MY NAME IS JAMES BALDWIN I
SERVICE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR
YOU TO SANTA CRUZ IS STUDENT
UNION ASSOCIATION MUSCLE BOARD
MEMBER ON THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION.
SO -- FIRST
AND FOREMOST I JUST LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY SINCERE THANKS TO YOU
FOR OFFERING  SUMMER CAL GRANT
BILL AS BEFORE --
SIXTY ONE THROUGH JUST COMMON
SENSE INITIATIVE THAT WILL HELP
US CLOSE THE EMPLOYMENT AND
SKILLED WAGE GAP IN CALIFORNIA
I'VE HEARD THAT THE SHORTAGE CAN
YOU OUT WELL ONE MILLION WORKERS
SO.
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO GET THE
STUDENTS OUT OF THE UC QUICKER
REALLY APPRECIATIVE OF AND I'M
SURE ALL OF MY PEERS AGREE.
HOWEVER THERE ALSO FOR THE STEPS
THAT WE CAN TAKE TO ENSURE THAT
THE UC'S EDUCATIONAL MISSION IS
FILLED.
AND AJ WHEN I HIGHLIGHT ONE OF
THESE RIGHT NOW AS PART OF OUR
RACIAL JUSTICE NOW CAMPAIGN FOR
YOU SEE STUDENTS ASSOCIATION
RESTING FOR TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONGOING FUNDING TO
SUPPORT OUTREACH AND RETENTION
CENTERS ON OUR CAMPUSES.
YOU SEEN REALLY GREAT --
SUCCESS STORIES WITH --
THESE WILL HELP STUDENTS AT THE
UC WHO ARE HISTORICALLY UNDER
SERVED --
AND AS A SHEET AND THE LADY WAS
SAYING --
BUDGET IS A STATEMENT OF MORAL
VALUES RIGHT --
SO PUTTING MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH
IS SAYING THAT THE SEA IS AN
INCLUSIVE EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTION IS SOMETHING THAT WE
REALLY WANT TO PUSH --
FOR BUT ONCE AGAIN OF REALLY
SUPPORT AS BEFORE SIXTY ONE AND
APPRECIATE THE WORK YOU ALL YOU
FOLKS DO THEY THANK YOU SIR NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON --
MY NAME IS HANNAH BACK SEVEN I'M
WITH THE CAL STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION --
WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OPPOSED INVESTMENTS
IN THE CSU ESPECIALLY THE FIVE
FIFTEEN MILLION FOR BASIC NEEDS
SUCH AS HOMELESSNESS AND FOOD
INSECURITY ACROSS ALL TWENTY
THREE CAMPUSES.
BUT IN ORDER TO TRULY HELP
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS NOT JUST SIX
FEET BUT SURVIVED THE STATE
NEEDS TO FINALLY COMMIT THE
FINANCIAL AID OR FORM.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THE TOTAL
COST OF ATTENDANCE HAS RISEN
EXPONENTIALLY ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO HOUSING.
FINANCIAL AID HAS NOT INCREASED
RESULTING IN THE BASIC NEEDS
CRISIS WE SEE ON OUR CAMPUSES
TODAY.LIKE THE LEGISLATURE WE WANT TO
SEE OUR STUDENTS GRADUATE ON
TIME IF YOU'RE PREPARED FOR THE
WORK FORCE BUT WHEN A THOUSANDS
OF STUDENTS DON'T HAVE A PLACE
TO SLEEP.
NOW HOW COULD THEY FOCUS ON
SCHOOL THEREFORE WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE EXPANDED ACCESS SUMMER
COURSE COVERAGE SUPPORT FOR
BASIC NEEDS AND INVESTMENTS THAT
COVER THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE.
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE PLEASED TO
SEE DEMONSTRATED IN SB TWO NINE
ONE BUT WOULD LIKE TO SEE CSU
STUDENTS INCLUDED AS WELL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
NEXT.
HELLO MY NAME ISJOSEPH KANSEN
I'M A MULTICULTURAL GENDER
STUDIES MAJOR APP YOU COLLEGE
AND I AM HERE IN SUPPORT OF
CERTAIN PORTANTINO'S.
I REQUEST FOR TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO ADDRESS STUDENT
HOMELESSNESS LAST SEMESTER I WAS
HOMELESS INSTEAD OF BEING ABLE
TO FOCUS ON MY SCHOOL WORK IN MY
FUTURE I WAS FORCED TO PUT ALL
MY ENERGY INTO THE PRESENT.
AND FIGURE OUT WHERE WOULD BE
STAYING FOR THE NIGHT AND
SEARCHING FOR A PLACE TO LIVE
THOUGH IF IT WITHIN MY LIMITED
INCOME.
I WAS ABLE TO MOVE INTO AN
APARTMENT ON NOVEMBER FIRST OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN JUST ONE WEEK
BEFORE THE CAMP WILD FIRE WHICH
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
STRUCTURE OF ENTIRE COMMUNITY.
INCLUDING THE LOSS OF MY
BOYFRIEND'S HOME MY BEST
FRIEND'S HOME AND HUNDREDS OF
OTHER COLLEGE STUDENTS.
THE CITY OF G. COULD OCCUR TO
HOUSING CRISIS JUST WEEKS BEFORE
THE FIRE STARTED AND WITH THE
ADDED INFLUX OF PEOPLE IN NEED
OF HOUSING IS JUST TOO FAR GRAY
FOR A COMMUNITY TO TACKLE ON OUR
OWN.
AT THE MOTEL A WORK OUT WE STILL
HAVE PEOPLE FROM THE FIRE LIVING
OUT OF OUR ROOMS SOME OF BEEN
THERE SINCE THE FIRE.
WITH THE TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
NOT ONLY GOOD MY COMMUNITY WORK
TOWARDS A BRIGHTER FUTURE THE
CALLOUSED AND ALL OVER THE STATE
COULD BREATHE EASIER KNOWING
THEIR RESOURCES FOR THEM AND GET
BACK TO FOCUSING ON YOUR
EDUCATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US [inaudible]
SIR NEXT.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DAVID GOOD SON I WORK AT BIãU
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
NOW I'M HERE TO ALSO SUPPORT THE
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST
FROM SENATOR --
PUT PORTANTINO TO ADDRESS
STUDENT HOMELESSNESS --
THE STUDENTS THAT WE HELP OR LOW
INCOME HAVE DIFFICULTY MEETING
THAT LOWER LEASE REQUIREMENTS
OFTEN HAVE NO COSIGNER OR UNDER
EMPLOYED.
MAYBE SLEEPING IN THEIR CARS
GOING.
FOR WITH STUDENTS COME TO US
THEY ARE TRAUMATIZED OVERWHELMED
WITH TRYING TO FIND REASONABLE
COST HOUSING.
WHEN HOUSING BECOMES THEIR
PROBLEM FOOD AND SECURITY
INTERESTS AS WELL AS THE
STUDENTS MUST SACRIFICE TO MAKE
A CHOICE ON WHAT THEY WILL SPEND
THEIR MONEY ON HOUSING OUR FOOD?
HOUSING INSTABILITY DIRECTLY
IMPACTS OUR STUDENTS ACADEMIC
SUCCESS THEY MISS MORE CLASS
THAN OTHER STUDENTS AND HAVE
TROUBLE CONCENTRATING ON THEIR
STUDIES DUE TO THE STRESS IN
THEIR LIVES.
AROUND HOUSING SB FIVE SIX EIGHT
WILL MAKE A DIFFERENC THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
THE CARD.
A GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
MY NAME IS EDDIE I YOU ARE MY
STUDENTS SUPPORT SPECIALIST AT
NEW COLLEGE --
I AM IN SUPPORT OF CENTER
PORTANTINO'S REQUEST FOR TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TO ADDRESS
STUDENT HOMELESSNESS.
SB COLLEGE STAFF MEMBER I'VE
HEARD PERSONAL ACCOUNTS OF
HOMELESSNESS FROM STUDENTS ONE
PARTICULAR STUDENT HAD TO SHARE
EXPERIENCE OF LIVING IN A CAR
WITH HER SIBLINGS.
THE IMAGERY OF SEEING A STUDENT
HAVING TO STUDY THESE CONDITIONS
IS HEARTBREAKING.
IN SPITE OF THESE EDUCATIONAL
BARRIERS THE STUDENTS STAY
RESILIENT.
HOWEVER THE CONCERN OF BEING
THROWN BACK INTO A STATE OF
HOMELESSNESS IS VERY REAL.
AND A TIME DOES IMPACT THEIR
EDUCATIONAL FOCUS.
I REALIZE THIS IS A STATE WIDE
IS BACK TO THE RECENT FIRES.
I KNOW THAT THE FUNDS PROPOSED
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE --
TO ASSIST OF STUDENTS AFFECTED
BY HOMELESSNESS BUT DEFINITELY
HELP FOR ALL THESE REASONS I
SUPPORT THE REQUEST FOR FUNDING
TO ADDRESS ALMOST TO SPEAK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MY NAME'S
DESSLER ACT I'M HERE FROM THE
COLLEGE.
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO REQUEST FROM
SENATOR BENNETT HE DOES.
DIGESTION HOMELESSNESS --
I WAS.
HOMELESS IN LIVING IN MY CAR --
HOMELESSNESS IS A THE DESPERATE
CYCLE HE LOSING FRIENDS AND
CLASSMATES WHO DON'T UNDERSTAND.
VERY UNHEALTHY DIET --
GETTING AROUND FIVE HOURS OF
SLEEP A NIGHT WHEN PEOPLE AREN'T
BANGING ON YOUR CAR WINDOW OR
SCREAMING IN YOUR CAR --
FALLING ASLEEP IN THE LIBRARY
WHEN I COULD BE STUDYING --
FEAR MY CAR BATTERY DYING AGAIN
WHEN I'M STUDYING AFTER HOURS --
TWENTY FOUR HOURS OF STRESS IN A
PANIC OF STRESSING ABOUT YOUR
ACADEMIC CAREER.
FORTUNATELY GOOD THINGS HAPPEN
FAST WHEN I GO OUT OF THE
SUPPORT I NEDED FRM SCHOOLS.
BUT I WAS LUCKY
THERE'S NUMBER OVERWHELMING FOG
IN OF TERROR AND STUDENT
HOMELESSNESS --
YOUR SUPPORT TO COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES CAN BE A GREAT --
GAME CHANGER THIS CRISIS I
MYSELF HAVE A THREE POINT EIGHT
GPA AND READY TO TRANSFER --
IN.
TWENTY TWENTY BECAUSE I'M ABLE
TO FOCUS ON SCHOOL IN A DAY
TODAY SURVIVAL THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US.
JUST A REMINDER I OPENED UP
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR TWO OF THOSE
STUDENTS WHO NEED TO GO BACK TO
CLASS BUT I APPRECIATE ALL THE
COMMENTS WE WILL.
TAKE A FIVE MINUTE RECESS WE
WILL COME BACK TO TALK ABOUT
STATEWIDE LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEMS AND THEN I WILL RE OPEN
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR ALL OF YOU --
WAITED
OKAY IF I COULD HAVE YOU
IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR THE RECORD
STARTING WITHOUT START WITH MY
RIGHT THIS TIME YOU LEFT.
I THANK YOU DAN HAD OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE GENERAL
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
AMBER ALEXANDER ALSO WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THANK YOU
MA'AM.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
AND THANK YOU.
CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES AND SEGMENTS OF PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION HAVE BEEN
STEADILY INCREASING THE DATA
COLLECTION AND ANALYSIS EFFORTS
OVER THE PAST DECADE.
HOWEVER THE ADMINISTRATION
RECOGNIZES THAT THESE EFFORTS
HAVE LARGELY BEEN ISOLATED FROM
EACH OTHER.
MAKING IT DIFFICULT FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO GAIN
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW OTHER
STUDENTS PERFORM ONCE THEY ENTER
THE WORKFORCE.
OR MOVE ON TO COLLEGE.
CONVERSELY CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES ARE
NOT ABLE TO OBSERVE METRICS FOR
HOW OTHER STUDENTS DID DURING
THEIR TIME IN K. TWELVE SCHOOLS.
AS CALIFORNIA SCHOOL STRIVE TO
INCREASE STUDENT SUCCESS IMPROVE
STUDENT OUTCOMES.
IT WILL BE CRITICAL TO HAVE%
ACCESS TO DATA THAT CAN
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPACT OF
EDUCATIONAL INITIATIVES ON A
STUDENT'S ABILITY TO PROGRESS
THROUGH EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS
AND INTO THE WORK FORCE. TO THIS
END THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES
TEN MILLION DOLLARS. ONE TIME
NON PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TO PLAN FOR AND
DEVELOP A STATE.
STATEWIDE LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEM.
THIS IS THE MORE CONTENT
CONNECTS TO INFORMATION FROM
EARLY EDUCATION PROVIDERS K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS.
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
EMPLOYERS.
BOTHER WORKFORCE ENTITIES AND
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCIES.
BUT PORTION OF THIS FUNDING WILL
GO TOWARDS THE CREATION OF A
WORK GROUP.
THAT ONE FORM THE DEVELOPMENT OF
A LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM.
THERE MANY FUNDING WILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR THE INITIAL STAGES
OF SYSTEM IMPLEMENTATION.
THE NEW SYSTEM WILL ALLOW THE
STATE TO OPTIMIZE EXISTING
PROGRAMS ENHANCE ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES.
AND CONDUCT RESEARCH ON
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES.
FURTHER A LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEM WILL ALLOW THE STATE TO
BETTER SUPPORT THE NEEDS OF
CHILDREN AND ADULTS.
IN THE STATE'S PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS STILL IN
THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING
LANGUAGE FOR THIS PROPOSAL AND
IS LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING
FROM THE DISCUSSION FROM TODAY'S --
PANELS FEATURING DID EXPERTS
FROM K. TWELVE AND HIGHER
EDUCATION TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
WHAT CURRENTLY EXISTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WHAT EDUCATIONAL LEADERS ARE
INTERESTED IN INCLUDING AS PART
OF A LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING
CONVERSATIONS RUNS PROPOSAL IN
THE COMING MONTHS HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
WELL THIS IS A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE I AM ALSO
INTERESTED IN LISTENING --
TO OF THE NEXT PANEL AND I'M
HOPING THAT AS PART OF THAT
SOMEONE WILL.
TAKE JANEMR JANE IN PRE K. AND
TAKE JANE THROUGH FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTION AND TELL ME WHAT.
THE DATA SYSTEM IS GOING TO TELL
ME.
ABOUT JANE.
I'D BE INTERESTED TO HEAR THAT.
BUT OTHER THAN THAT I HAVE NO
QUESTIONS AT THIS POINT
HOPEFULLY YOU WILL.
JOIN US UP HERE AND WE CAN BRING
UP THE SECOND PANEL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT WAY YOU'LL HAVE A
MICROPHONE.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS
CONVERSATION.
SO ONCE ALL ONCE EVERYBODY THE
MUSIC STOPS AND EVERYBODY GETS A
CHAIR --
LET'S --
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD PLEASE WE'RE GOING TO
START TO MY LEFT YOU'RE RIGHT
SIR WITH YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR DAVID
O'BRIEN ACTING CHIEF OF RESEARCH
EVALUATION THE DATA FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT A COMMISSION
THANK YOU MISTER BRIAN --
HOME OF DOCTOR DIPPED INTO
REGION CHIEF LABOR MARKET
INFORMATION DIVISION AND ADD ARE
CORRECT THANKS FOR JOINING US
PAMELA BROWN VICE PRESIDENT
INSTITUTIONAL RESEARCH AND
ACADEMIC PLANNING AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON NATHAN
EVANS CHIEF OF STAFF AND SENIOR
ADVISER FOR ACADEMIC AND STUDENT
AFFAIRS WITH THE CSU OFFICE THAT
YOU'RE.
JOINING THIS AFTERNOON'S THEIR
NOVEL MORGAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION EARLY
LEARNING CARE DIVISION.
FOR AT STATE SUPERINTENDENT TONY
THURMOND EDUCATION ANALYSIS
MEASUREMENT ACCOUNTABILITY PARTY
DIVISION.
WHOSE US.
AND CHRISTIAN OSMAN DEVICE
CHANCE OVER THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
I'LL PROBABLY MESS UP NAMES SO
OF TRYING TO CALL AND ANYBODY
WHO WANTS TO START FIRST.
YEAH I MEAN IT STARTS INSIDE OF
THE JEANS AND THE ONE THERE AND
MAY.
I HAVE THE EARLY LEARNING SIDE
OR AT LAST HAVE THE SIDE OF THE
DATA.
THOUGH I A MINUTE --
SHARE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT WE
HAVE TO DO FOR FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS BECAUSE OF THAT
CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT FUNDS
WE COLLECT DATA MAINLY AROUND
DEMOGRAPHICS AND AROUND FAN
FAMILY ELIGIBILITY AND NEED. TO
REALLY AROUND THE PROGRAMMER
CREDIT REQUIREMENTS WE USE THE
DATA FOR MONITORING PROGRAM
INTEGRITY AND TO ENSURE
STEWARDSHIP OF PUBLIC FUNDS.
THE ONCE AGAIN A LOT BACK TO
THAT FAMILY ELIGIBILITY AND NEED
COMPONENTS BUT ALSO FOR TRAINING
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
CONTINUE IN PROVE MEANT. TO
ENSURE THERE'S BETTER SERVICES
TO ADDRESS AN ACCORDION
RESOURCES ACROSS THE STATE AS WE
LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
VERSUS THE PERCENTAGE SERVED IN
EACH OF THE COMMUNITIES.
BUT REALLY I'M HERE TODAY TO SAY
THERE'S A LOT OF CHALLENGES AND
RESTRICTIONS IN THE DATA AND THE
USE OF THE DATA DUE TO A LACK OF
A UNIFIED SYSTEM AND DUE TO LACK
OF UNIQUE IDENTIFIERS.
SO WE CAN'T ACTUALLY FOLLOW THE
CHILDREN FOLLOW THEM THROUGH OUR
PROGRAMS BECAUSE THEY TEND TO GO
IN AND OUT SO I CAN'T TELL YOU
OF THAT SCENE CHILD.
HAS LEFT AND THEN RETURNED AND
WE ALSO CAN GIVE YOU AN ON
DUPLICATED COUNT ON THE CHILDREN
AND WE CAN'T TELL YOU IF THEY'RE
ALSO RECEIVING HEAD START EARLY
HEAD START.
THE LOTS OF GAPS IN THE DATA DUE
TO THE LACK OF AN INTEGRATED
SYSTEM AND DUE TO THE LACK OF
THOSE.
AND UNIQUE IDENTIFIERS.
WE KNOW WE NEED THE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION. TO ENSURE THAT WERE
MOVING JUST FROM MONITORING TO
ACTUALLY A SYSTEM THAT'S FOCUSED
ON IMPROVEMENT.
I TRULY DRIVEN DATA SYSTEM WE
KNOW WE NEED TO MOVE FROM A
FRAGMENTED DATA SYSTEM TO ONE
THAT'S TRULY COORDINATED.
AND FROM A SNAPSHOT JUST AT ONE
POINT IN TIME TO LONGITUDINAL SO
WE CAN SAY WHEN A BABY ENTERS
AND THEN AS THEY GO THROUGH THE
SYSTEM THROUGH PRESCHOOL AND
THEN ON UP TO KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH THIRD GRADE.
SO WE COULD ACTUALLY GIVE YOU A
LITTLE BIT MORE.
MEAN REALIZE THAT POLICY MAKERS
NEED MORE DATA TO UNDERSTAND THE
PATTERNS IN SERVICE TO LOOK AT
RESOURCE ALLOCATION. TO ASSESS
THE IMPACT AND TO DEFINE THE
COSTS OF PROVIDING THE QUALITY
OF THOSE SERVICES ACROSS THE
STATE.
THOSE ARE THE SAME INFORMATION
THAT RESEARCHERS ARE ALWAYS
ASKING US FOR WE GET CONSTANT
DATA REQUEST.
I'M ESPECIALLY IF WE WANT TO
LOOK AT CHILD OUTCOMES AND
REALLY ADDRESS SOME POLICY
IMPACTS AROUND THOSE INVESTMENT.
PARENTS ALSO DEEPLY NEED MORE
INFORMATION THEY NEED NOT TO
JUST UNDERSTAND AVAILABILITY BUT
THEY NEED GREATER INFORMATION
AROUND IMPACT TO MAKE INFORMED
CHOICES.
ABOUT THE EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE THAT'S AVAILABLE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. TO BE SUCCESSFUL WE
ACTUALLY NEED A DATA GOVERNOR IN
THE INTEGRATION FOR BUSINESS
NEEDS.
AND FOR THE STAKEHOLDERS AS WELL
WE TRULY DEEPLY NO WE NEED
UNIQUE IDEAS FOR EACH FAMILY
PROVIDER AND FACILITY THAT
RECEIVES OUR FUNDS. TO COMPLY
WITH FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA'S ONLY ONE
OF THREE STATES THAT DOES NOT
SEND THE FULL POPULATION DATA
WITH THOSE UNIQUE ES DE ID'S
BACK TO THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
THE CITY IS TAKING STEPS RIGHT
NOW AND USING THE FEDERAL
PRESCHOOL DEVELOPMENT GRANT TO
CONDUCT A COMPREHENSIVE EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE NEEDS
ASSESSMENT.
WE'RE DOING THIS IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND
WORKING WITH THE STATE ADVISORY
COUNCIL ON EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE.
THROUGH THAT WILL BE ABLE TO
LOOK AT AN ANALYSIS OF OUR DATA
AND NINETY CAPS WERE IN THE
BEGINNING STAGES OF IDENTIFYING
AND ENGAGING STAKEHOLDERS FOR
THE CREATION OF AN EARLY
CHILDHOOD.
INTEGRATED DATA SYSTEM THAT THEN
CONNECT BEYOND THAT SIDE OF
EARLY LEARNING CARE DATA.
INDICATE TWELFTH MY PARTNER NEXT
TO ME THAT WE REALLY CAN FOLLOW
CHILDREN AND WHAT WE'RE MISSING
IS THAT ENTITY DEDICATED TO
COLLECTING INTEGRATING AND
REPORTING THAT DATA AND A WAY
THAT'S USEFUL FOR YOU.
ALSO USEFUL FOR RESEARCHERS AND
TRULY USEFUL FOR PARENTS THAT
CONCLUDES MY AND YOU MAKE MA'AM
YOU KNOW MAY NOT BE THE ONE THAT
I SHOULD DIRECT THIS TO BUT I'M
TRYING TO GET AN IDEA.
IN A PERFECT WORLD IF WE WERE
ABLE TO CREATE A STATEWIDE
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM.
THAT CENTRALIZED AND NOT WITH
THE OTHER WORD FEDERATED NOT --
SO THERE'S SOME CENTRALIZED
COLLECTION OF DATA.
FROM PRE K. THROUGH.
COMPLETION OF WHATEVER THE
INSTITUTION IS TO YEAR FOUR YEAR.
AM I ABLE TO DO WILL I BE ABLE
TO TELL THAT BECAUSE JANE.
A DIDN'T TAKE --
GEOMETRY AND HER SOPHOMORE YEAR.
THAT.
THERE'S SOME CONNECTION BETWEEN
WHAT JANE DID AT CAL STATE.
NORTHRIDGE IN HER.
MATH PROGRAM AND SHE WAS.
A SOCIOLOGY MAJOR AND WHEN SHE
GRADUATED.
SHE GOT A JOB AT MCDONALD'S
BECAUSE THERE ARE NO JOBS I MEAN
WHAT DO I DO WITH THIS DATA IS
THAT A FAIR QUESTION I'M NOT AN
EDUCATOR I'M LOOKING AT YOU ALL.
SET UP LARGE MAYBE I SHOULD WAIT
TO YOU ALL FINISH THEN LET ME
ASK OKAY.
SO WHO'S NEXT I'M HAPPY TO
CONTINUE THE JANE AND ONE AND
NOW.
THAT'S MY QUESTION I CAN DO THAT --
SO AGAIN TALKING THROUGH A K.
TWELVE SYSTEM BECAUSE THE STATE
IS INVESTED IN A LUNCHEON OF
DATA SYSTEM FOR K. TWELVE SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND NINE WE CAN
TELL THAT JANE TOOK.
GEOMETRY WHAT KIND OF GRADE SHE
GOT WHETHER OR NOT SHE COMPLETED
HIGH SCHOOL IN THE FOUR YEARS
ARE SHE COMPLETED IT AT A LATER
DATE WE CAN TELL A. F. AS SHE
WAS FORTUNATELY DISADVANTAGED IF
SHE WAS A FOSTER USE IF --
IF SAME THINGS WITH --
ONE IF ONE OF THE MORE IN
ENGLISH LEARNERS SO WE ARE ABLE
TO CAPTURE THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION --
WE DO HAVE DATA SHARING
AGREEMENTS WITH ENTERED INTO
SOME OF THOSE AT TERRY
DETERMINES FOR THE VERY REASON
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT.
WHAT ARE THEY MISSING OR WHAT
HOW CAN WE AVOID --
HAVING STUDENTS GOING TO RADIO
EDUCATION AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEVEL --
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT
KIND OF AT AT ED CLASSES ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT STUDENTS ARE PREPARED FOR
FOR MATH IN COLLEGE BUT THE KIDS
FOLLOW UP LEVEL THAT'S WE
COLLECT THAT WOULD HELP WITH
WITH WHAT YOU'RE ASKING.
OKAY AND THEN I AM I'LL JUST TRY
ANOTHER QUESTION BUT I'M GONNA
LET EVERYBODY PHOENICIAN SO THEN
MIKE MY MY REAL QUESTION IS
WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE WHAT WE
REALLY DO WITH THAT DATA ONCE WE
FIND.
WHAT'S WE GATHER WRITTEN AND WE
COME TO A CONCLUSION THAT
SOMEBODY MISTER MATH COURSE OR
WHATEVER WHAT WHAT'S THE IMPACT
OF THE DATA.
AND HOW DO WE USE IT IN THE
LARGER.
IN THE LARGER SCHEME OF THINGS
WHICH IS WE EDUCATE PEOPLE.
FOR SOCIETY IN THE WORKPLACE AND
HOW THE PIECES FIT TOGETHER
WHO'S NEXT.
ALL MOVE ALL START CHRISTMAS
WHEN YOU'RE THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES I THINK YOUR
QUESTION IS THE CRUX OF KIND OF
THIS DISCUSSION WE OFTEN START
WITH THE TECHNOLOGY AND WITH THE
MEASURES.
HAVE HOW DO WE ACTUALLY GET THE
DATA TOGETHER.
I THINK THE HEART OF THE
QUESTION YOUR CHEN TO GETS TO IT
IS KIND OF WHO IS THE AUDIENCE
AND WHAT ARE THEIR GOALS --
HAPPY TO TALK TO YOU MAYBE IT
MIGHT BE HELPFUL TO TALK THROUGH
WAYS WE USE DATA TODAY.
AND WAYS A LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEM MIGHT BE BETTER
CHANCELLOR OAKLEY --
TALKED ABOUT THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS.
COR GOALS OF IMPROVING OUTCOMES
REDUCE.
THAT VISION FOR SUCCESS WAS
PREDICATED ON OUR EXISTING
ASSESSMENT OF KIND OF STATEWIDE
AND ACROSS REGIONS ACROSS
DISTRICTS WHERE WE SEE GAPS IN
PERFORMANCE WHAT WE DO ABOUT
THEM SO I THINK.
THAT OF ONE AUDIENCE IS STATE
POLICYMAKERS ARE BOARDS FIGURING
OUT HOW TO IDENTIFY THE GOALS
WHAT INTERVENTIONS TO BE PUT IN
PLACE ONE OF THE INTERVENTIONS
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR PUT IN
PLACE LAST YEAR.
WAS A NEW FUNDING FORMULA THAT
LARGELY RELIED ON OUR EXISTING
DATA OF THE NUMBER OF YOU KNOW
LOW INCOME STUDENTS ACROSS
DISTRICTS.
OUT COMES ACROSS DISTRICTS
THAT'S ONE THING WE COULD DO
DIFFERENTLY --
YOU KNOW WITH DIFFERENT KINDS OF
DATA -- YOU
KNOW A LONG STANDING ROLE FOR
DINNER SYSTEM HAS BEEN PUBLIC
TRANSPARENCY THAT WE HAVE SAID.
DATA IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE CAN
GIVE COMMUNITIES MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE STUDENTS.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
THEIR COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
SERVING AND HOW WELL THEY'RE
SERVING THEIR STILL STUDENTS WE
HAVE --
SINCE TWENTY THIRTEEN HAVE HAD A
STUDENT SUCCESS CORKER SCORECARD
AIMING TO DO JUST THAT TO SAY
HERE'S THE YOU KNOW HERE'S THE
PERFORMANCE OF YOUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT.
YOU AS A COMMUNITY MEMBERS A
STUDENT AS A FAMILY MEMBER CAN
WORK WITH YOUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES.
BLAST EXAMPLE AND AND WHAT I
THIS I THINK CRITICAL TO OUR USE
OF DATA --
HIS MAKING SURE A NEW DATA
SYSTEM IS ABLE TO BE ACCESSED BY
LOCAL PRACTITIONERS --
YOU KNOW CHANCELLOR OAKLEY THIS
MORNING TALKED A LOT ABOUT THE
WORK WE'VE DONE ON MAKING SURE
MORE STUDENTS ENTER COLLEGE
LEVEL COURSES.
NOPE.
PROCEED THROUGH COLLEGE LEVEL
COURSES ONE OF THE WAYS IN WHICH
WE HISTORICALLY HAD RELIED --
ONE OF THE TOOLS WE HAD RELIED
ON FOR PURPOSES OF PLACEMENT HAD
BEEN AN ASSESSMENT BUT YOU COME
TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES YOU
TAKE A PLACEMENT EXAM YOUR
PLACEMENT EXAM TELLS YOU WHAT
COURSES YOU'RE.
READY.
FOR WHAT WE HAVE MOVED TO IS
LOOKING AT HIGH SCHOL GRADES
AND WHAT WE'VE LEARNED IS THAT
HIGH SCHOOL GRADES TLL US MUCH
MORE.
ABOUT WHAT A STUDENT --
HOW READY A STUDENT IS FOR
COLLEGE LEVEL COURSES --
YOU KNOW WE COULD DO THAT ON A
SELF REPORT BASIS STUDENTS CAN
TELL US WHAT THEIR GPA WAS WHAT
COURSES THEY TOOK.
BUT I THINK WHAT GIVES US MUCH
MORE CONFIDENCE IN THE SYSTEM IS
AN ABILITY TO LOOK AT THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL TRANSCRIPTS.
AND USE THAT FOR PLACEMENT
DECISIONS SO I THINK AS WE TALK
WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT KIND OF THE
RESEARCH AND ANALYSIS PURPOSE OF
TRADING LODGINGS PEOPLE THIS
SYSTEM.
I THINK WHAT WE THINK IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT --
WANTS TO THIS POINT TWO POINTS I
WOULD JUST MAKE A BEFORE I CLOSE.
THE FIRST IS THAT YOU KNOW I
THINK.
THE CLEAR KIND OF TAKE AWAY FROM
US FROM THOSE EXAMPLES IS THAT
WE CAN HAVE A BETTER OUTCOME
MEASUREMENTS --
IF WE CONNECTOR DATA THAT AS YOU
MENTIONED YOU KNOW OUR GOAL IS
NOT SIMPLY TO AWARD SOMEONE IT
AGREE OUR GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY SUCCEED IN THE WORK
FORCE THE BUT YET EMPLOYMENT IN
THE FIELD OF STUDY THAT PAY
ACHIEVEMENT.
FILED A LIVING WAGE THAT IS ONLY
POSSIBLE BECAUSE WE SHARE DATA
AND EDIE SHARES DATA WITH US.
I THINK THE OTHER POINT I WOULD
JUST MAKE --
YOU KNOW OUR DATA DOESN'T ACT ON
IT SO THAT YOU KNOW I THINK THAT
SHOULDN'T STOP US FROM KIND OF
TALKING ABOUT IN ACTUALLY
PUTTING TOGETHER LONGITUDINAL
DATA SYSTEM.
BUT I THINK THE CONVERSATION WE
ALSO NEED TO HAVE IS WHAT WE
WANT TO CHANGE AND WHAT ARE THE
DECISION POINTS THAT WE'RE GONNA
USE -- TO TO
MAKE THOSE CHANGES.
I WILL HOLD THE REST OF MY
COMMENTS AND HOPE THAT'S HELPFUL
WELL I I YOU KNOW I'VE SAID FOR
SOME TIME THAT --
IN THE IN THE EDUCATION IN THE
HIGHER EDUCATION FIELD --
WE YOU ALL OF US NEED TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW WELL YOU'RE
MEETING THE NEEDS OF YOUR
CUSTOMERS AND YOUR CASE YOUR
CUSTOMERS YOUR STUDENTS.
AND ONE MEASURE OF THAT I THINK
NOT BEING AN EDUCATOR IS A FIVE
MOVE THROUGH A PROGRAM AND I GET
A CERTIFICATE AT RIVERSIDE CITY
COLLEGE OR I GET A A DEGREE AT
RIVERSIDE CITY COLLEGE WITH A
CONCENTRATION IN WHATEVER.
WHAT WHAT AM I DOING TWO YEARS
FROM NOW?
IN MY IN MY ABLE TO TRANSLATE
THAT INTO SOME SOMETHING THAT'S
USEFUL.
OR DOES THE MARKET PLACE NOT
CARE ABOUT WHAT I DID AT
RIVERSIDE CITY COLLEGE IN WHICH
CASE.
I WOULD BE NICE IF I HAD KNOWN
THAT GOING IN.
AND ONE ELEMENT OF THIS
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM IS
PERHAPS IF IT WORKS.
I'LL BE ABLE TO KNOW THAT AND
CAN MAKE DECISIONS I MAY DO WHAT
I DID ANYWAY BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
I WANT TO DO BUT BE NICE TO HAVE
THAT INFORMATION.
OKAY MAYBE PRIDE TWO EXAMPLES --
YOU KNOW I THINK IN AND I THINK
THAT EXAMPLE HIGHLIGHTS KIND OF
THE MIND SHIFT --
MINDSET SHIFT THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE A SENSE TO LONG TIME WE
HAVE RELIED ON TRANSFER READY.
AS THE WAY IN WHICH WE ASSESS
WHETHER WE'RE DOING A GOOD JOB
MEETING OUR TRANSFORMATION THAT
WE SAID.
YOU KNOW IF THE STUDENT IS
TAKING THE RIGHT COURSES AT A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THE COURSES THEY NEED TO
TRANSFER THE UC AND CSU WE WILL
SEE THAT AS KIND OF YOU KNOW
SUCCESS FOR OUR INSTITUTIONS ONE
OF THE THINGS THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS DID WAS SAY WE ACTUALLY
SHOULD CARE ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THEY ACTUALLY TRANSFERRED TO UC
AND CSU. FOR THEIRS I THINK THE
POLICY DECISION THAT NEEDS TO BE
MADE BUT TO SUPPORT THE POLICY
DECISION --
YOU KNOW THE ACTUAL DATA THAT
WOULD LET US KNOW THAT WE NOW
GET FROM YOU SEE CSU IN THIS
NATIONAL STUDENT CLEARINGHOUSE
BUT SAYS THIS IS WHERE THE
STUDENT.
WHAT TO AFTER THEY LEFT YOUR
INSTITUTION I THINK THE OTHER
EXAMPLE WOULD BE THE WORK THAT
WE'VE DONE AROUND OUR SALARY
SURFER?
THAT NOW GIVES STUDENTS THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO SAY IF
I MAJOR IN ACTS ARE A COMPLETE
THIS PROGRAM OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HERE'S THE REASONABLE
EXPECTATION I CAN HAVE.
BUT THE CAREERS I CAN ENTER INTO
AFTER IT.
AND THAT WILL INFORM OUR CAREER
TECH EDUCATION C. T. E. EFFORTS.
DIRECTLY BECAUSE PEOPLE CAN SEE
THAT THERE'S LIGHT AT THE END OF
THE TUNNEL AND IF THEY GO
THROUGH THIS PROGRAM.
SOMETHING GOOD IS GOING TO
HAPPEN TO THEM.
YES THEY COULD BUT I THINK
THAT'S I THINK WE NEED TO PLACE
ESPECIALLY YOU KNOW I THINK
AGAIN THE DATE ON ITS OWN
DOESN'T DO THAT I THINK WE NEED
TO HAVE A PLACE WHERE WE'RE
HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND
SAYING.
THE DATA WE GET FROM THE SYSTEM
ABOUT WHERE STUDENTS ARE GOING
AND WHAT THE YOU KNOW WHERE
THEY'RE OUR CAREERS AT A LIVING
WAGE I HAD.
SHOULD BE INFORMING OUR DECISION
I THINK WE NEED WE BUILD THE
DATA SYSTEM CREATE THAT SPACE
FOR THAT CONVERSATION AND MAKE
SURE THAT THE PRIORITY.
AND I GUESS IN THE OTHER
QUESTION IS.
DATA ACCESSIBLE YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT BEING ACCESSIBLE AMONG YOU
ALL.
IS SHOULD BE ACCESSIBLE TO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
I THINK THAT'S A CORE
INTERNATIONAL BUT OTHERS GET IT.
WELL I THINK THAT'S A CALL OR
KIND OF CONVERSATION THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE ABOUT GOVERNMENT'S
ABOUT WHO IS THE AUDIENCE WHAT
DO THEY NEED TO DO WITH THE DATA.
AND HOW DO WE BALANCE PRIVACY
CONCERNS WITH --
THAT USE OF DATA.
THANKS TO THE SO I THINK WHAT
MAYBE CONTINUE ON THE POT
SECONDARY SEGMENT --
AND THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR
OTHER COLLEAGUES --
ONCE AGAIN MY NAME IS NATHAN
EVANS I AM THE CHIEF OF STAFF
AND SENIOR ADVISER FOR ACADEMIC
AND STUDENT AFFAIRS AT THE CSU
OFF THE CHANCELLOR AND I'M GONNA
DISPENSED WITH SOME OF MY
PREPARED COMMENTS BECAUSE I
THINK -- TO
TO MISTER AND MENUS POINTING AND
DISCUSSION A LOT OF IT IS
TALKING ABOUT SCENARIOS THINGS
SUCCESSES BECAUSE THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF DATA
SHARING HAPPENING AMONG ALL
AMONGST ALL THE ENTITIES YOU
HAVE BEFORE YOU --
SOME OF IT IS PUBLIC IN TERMS OF
THE EXAMPLE THAT KRISTIN
MENTIONED THE D. OUTCOMES SO
LOOKING BY CAMPUS BY DISCIPLINE
WHERE OUR STUDENTS LAND IN THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE TODAY
BACKWARDS MAPPING YOU KNOW FOR
THROUGHOUT THE PAST DECADE --
WE HAVE OTHER GREAT EXAMPLES AND
WORKING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ENOUGH
FOR EXAMPLE OUR LONG STANDING
EARLY ASSESSMENT PROGRAM THAT
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ALSO PARTICIPATE IN WHICH IS
USING THE SMARTER BALANCED
ASSESSMENT ELEVENTH GRADE.
AND LOOKING AT THAT AS A
PRODUCTIVE AND AYE AYE PREDICTOR
OF COLLEGE READINESS IN ENGLISH
AND MATH.
WELL THE REALITY IS --
WHEN WE WORKED WITH CITY ON ON
LOOKING AT A LONGER RANGE OF
DATA?
WE COULD BACKWARDS MAP THAT TO
STANDARDIZE THE THE SORT OF
ANNUAL ASSESSMENT THAT'S DONE
ALL THE WAY BACK TO THIRD GRADE
SO THE NEEDS FOR INTERVENTION.
WHILE THEY ARE IMPORTANT
pGETTING READY IN STUDENTS READY
FOR POST SECONDARY EDUCATION THE
REALITY IS WE VIEW O LOOKING AT
THAT DATA COMBINED BIG.
COMBINING OUR TWO SEGMENTS
REALLY INDICATED THAT THE
EFFORTS HAD TO START FAR FARM
EARLIER --
ALL THE WAY IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
AND SO IT'S ONLY THROUGH THE
ABILITY TO SHARE --
ON A REGULAR BASIS AND NOT JUST
LOOKING AS A AT A POINT IN TIME
AS WE TALKED ABOUT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES WITH PAT BUT ABLE TO
BEING ABLE TO LOOK AT THE DATA
IT LONGITUDINALLY.
ONLY TO FALL INFORM
INSTITUTIONAL PRACTICES BUT AS
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD TO TO
INFORM STUDENTS FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES FROM A CONSUMER
STANDPOINT FROM --
PLANNING AND CAPACITY PLANNING A
STANDPOINT AND REALLY THAT'S IT
I THINK THE CRUX OF OF WHAT CAN
HAPPEN WITH WITH THIS DATA WE
HAVE NUMEROUS PROJECTS WE CAN
ALL TALK ABOUT WHERE WE ARE ARE
ARE.
ARE DOING A GREAT AMOUNT OF DATA
SHARING BUT IT IS SORT OF
PROJECT BASED AND IT IS REALLY
LOOKING AT WHATEVER AYE AYE
NARROW --
TOPIC MIGHT BE AT ONE TIME SO
THERE IS IN OWN I PRAY WORK OF
OUR FACULTY OUR INSTITUTIONS TO
INFORM THE COMMUNITIES WE SERVE
TO INFORM THE THE STATE --
AND OTHER PRACTITIONERS IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT ARE VERY MUCH
INTERESTED IN AND SUPPORTING OUR
EDUCATION ALL THAT THIS SORT OF
CRADLE TO CAREER PIPELINE IT FOR
TALKING ABOUT I HAVE TO TELL YOU
I WAS VERY VERY IMPRESSED WITH
OUR REGION ON READING THE
ANALYSIS THAT WERE PROVIDED TO
GET.
PREPARED FOR THESE.
THIS TYPE OF HEARING --
HOW MANY HOW MANY DIFFERENT?
DATA COLLECTION OPERATIONS WE
HAVE IN THE STATE THAT SEEM TO
BE DOING QUITE WELL --
THE QUESTION IS HOW DO THEY
RELATE AND IF IF I SPEND TWO
YEARS AT CAL STATE SAN FERNANDO
AND FLIP.
TO YOUR RECEIVE CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE IS OR SOMETHING THAT
COLLECT CONNECTS ALL THAT SO
THAT IF I'M AT THE THIRTY
THOUSAND FOOT LEVEL.
I CAN I CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT
HAPPENED TO THIS PARTICULAR
PERSON AND IT MIGHT BE
INTERESTING TO KNOW.
WHAT THEY DID IN --
K. THROUGH TWELVE TO YOU KNOW TO
SEE IF THERE WERE PARTICULAR
PROBLEMS BACK THEN THAT RESULTED
IN A IN A CAREER CHANGER
ACADEMIC CHANGE --
THE ISSUE WERE YOU SEE.
SO -- I'M
NOT CRITICAL AT ALL OF WHAT
YOU'RE DOING I THINK IT'S ACTUAL
CYST QUESTION I GUESS THAT'S WHY
GOVERNOR PUT THIS IN THE BUDGET.
WHETHER WE SHOULD FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO GREAT AT ALL AND HAVE
SOMEBODY WHO'S NOT IF ONE OF
YOUR CAMPUSES OR ONE OF YOUR
SYSTEM OFFICES BE ABLE TO PUSH A
BUTTON.
AND AND FIGURE OUT SOMETHING.
YES MA'AM RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME PAMELA BROWN VICE PRESIDENT
FOR INSTITUTIONAL RESEARCH AND
ACADEMIC PLANNING AT THE
UNIVERSITY.
OF CALIFORNIA I'VE BEEN DOING
INSTITUTIONAL RESEARCH NOW FOR
OVER TWENTY YEARS AS SIXTEEN OF
THEM ON THE BERKELEY CAMPUS IN
THE PRESIDENT.
AND I KNOW THE BENEFITS OF
HAVING A LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEM FOR ME AND BEING ABLE TO
LOOK AT STUDENTS BOTH
UNDERSTANDING --
FOR HIGH SCHOOLS IN OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHAT HAPPENS
ON THE ADMISSION SIDE ENROLLMENT
AND BEING ABLE TO SHARE
INFORMATION ON HOW MANY GRADUATE
AND THEN ON THE OUTCOMES TIED
FOR PARENTS AND STUDENTS ON
BEING ABLE TO UNDERSTAND.
YOU KNOW THAT CAREER AT THAT
THEY GO INTO A AND THEIR
EARNINGS AND THE RETURN ON
INVESTMENT FOR HAVING A DEGREE
WE FOCUS QUITE A BIT ON THAT
WE'VE LEVERAGED ARE OUR SYSTEM.
TO INFORM THE MULTI YEAR
FRAMEWORK THAT --
CFO BROSS FROM TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER TODAY MAKE SURE THEY
WERE MEETING THE GOALS THAT ARE
THERE I'VE I'VE PUT TOGETHER AT
A HANDOUT --
THAT LAYS WHAT THE THE DATA
SYSTEM LOOKS LIKE FOR US AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WHICH I
APPRECIATE IS MUCH SIMPLER THAN --
A MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES AROUND
THE TABLE THAT HAVE MANY MORE
CAMPUSES AND DISTRICTS TO WORK
WITH -- BUT
IT HIGHLIGHTS THE DATA THAT WE
COLLECT ON STUDENTS --
UNDER THE INPUT SIDE IT
HIGHLIGHTS SOME OF THE TOP AREAS
OF THE DATA WAREHOUSE SIDE SOME
OF THE KEY FUNCTIONS.
AND THE WAYS THAT WE SHARE THAT
INFORMATION THE OUTPUT --
FOR THE AUDIENCES THAT WERE
SERVING.
OF THE KEY --
AREA THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
INVESTMENT AND TIME SPENT ON IS
THIS DATA WAREHOUSE --
SECTION OF IT THE NOT SOME BOLTS
OF IT AND I'LL JUST MENTION FOR
AREAS THAT I THINK A REALLY
IMPORTANT CONSIDERING PUTTING
TOGETHER STATEWIDE SYSTEM ONE IS
THE QUALITY OF THE DATA --
WE SPEND AN AWFUL LOT OF TIME
CHECKING THE DATA THAT WE HAVE
THAT COMES IN WE AUTOMATE THE
PROCESS AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE AND
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS EACH YEAR
SOMETHING SPECIAL COMES ALONG.
AND WE HAVE TO GO BACK AND CHECK
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE LOADING IS ACCURATE
AND COMPLETE --
WE HAVE SET UP THIS THIRTY IN
PLACE THAT NEEDS TO BE
MAINTAINED IT NEEDS TO BE
UPGRADED --
ALONG THE WAY SO THERE'S AN
ONGOING INVESTMENT THAT NEEDS TO
BE THERE.
AND WE ALSO WORK QUITE A BIT ON
ENSURING THAT WE'RE PROTECTING
THE PRIVACY OF OUR STUDENTS.
AND ONE OF THE WAYS THAT WE
THINK ABOUT THAT IS HOW WE SHARE
THE INFORMATION --
WITH -- THE
PUBLIC.
WE KNOW THE VALUE OF THE DATA
THAT WE COLLECT SO WE FOCUSED A
LOT ON GETTING INFORMATION OUT
TO THE PUBLIC THROUGH THE YOU
SEE ACCOUNTABILITY REPORT THAT
WE'VE STARTED WHICH HAS.
GOT INFORMATION ON OPERATIONS
ACROSS THE BOARD --
WE SHIFT MORE INFORMATION NOW
INTO WHAT WE CALL ARE YOU SEE
INFORMATION CENTER IT'S THE
INTERACTIVE WEBSITE --
THAT ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS TO GO IN
AND WE ANSWER THE TOPPLING
QUESTIONS BUT THEY HAVE SOME
FUNCTIONALITY TO FILTER FOR
CAMPUS OR LOOK AT IT FOR
DIFFERENT SUBPOPULATIONS AND
THAT GIVES THEM MORE INFORMATION.
ON WHAT THEY CAN.
LEARN ABOUT --
IT ALSO GIVES US A LITTLE BIT
MORE THE RESEARCH THAT WE NEED
TO DO TO INFORM --
THE UNIVERSITY THE STATE ON SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT WE SEE --
ARE COMING UP AT SO THOSE ARE
CRITICAL AREAS YOU --
YOU RAISE SOME GOOD QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
YOU HOULD EXPECT TO BE ABLE TO
GET OUT OF IT YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE BENEFITS OF CALIFORNIA BEING
IN THE SPACE THAT WE'RE IN RIGHT
NOW IS THAT THERE ARE.
A NUMBER OF OTHER STATES THAT
YOU CAN LOOK TO TO FIND OUT WHAT
THEY DID WITH THEIR LESSONS
LEARNED WERE --
WHAT THEY COLLECT WHAT THE
REPORT AND HOW THEY MANAGE
RESEARCH AND THINK ABOUT THAT IN
TERMS OF WHAT YOU WANT TO GET
OUT FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA?
YOU RAISE A VERY INTERESTING
QUESTION ABOUT YOU KNOW CAN I
GET DOWN TO KNOWING IF SOMEBODY
DIDN'T TAKE A GEOMETRY CLASS
WILL THAT HAVE AN EFFECT ON WHAT
IT IS.
I THINK LAYING OUT THE QUESTIONS
THAT YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO
ANSWER IS A REALLY CRITICAL
BECAUSE THE AMOUNT OF WORK I
CAN'T UNDER ESTIMATE.
WHAT IT TAKES TO MAINTAIN A
SYSTEM LIKE THIS --
IFYOU WANTED TO BE ABLE TO
COLLECT INFORMATION TO START MY
MY RECOMMENDATION IS ALWAYS
START SMALL SUCCEED LEARN FROM
THAT AND AND BUILD --
BUT WILL WE FAILED THAT.
IT'S ITS IT'S SOMETHING I LIVE
BY WITH WITH THESE KINDS OF
PROJECTS BUT LIKE THEQUESTION
THAT YOU ASKED ONE OF THE WAYS
YOU COULD APPROACH IT IS.
TO COLLECT INFORMATION THAT
WOULD ALLOW YOU THE CHAINS ARE
ONES I THINK THOSE ARE THE NAMES
WERE WORKING WITH THAT ARE
STRUGGLING FIND OUT IF THEY'RE
CONCENTRATED WITHIN PARTICULAR
DISTRICTS.
AND THEN GO IN AND ASK FOR
COURSE LEVEL DETAIL YOU KNOW YOU
GO TO IN ORDER THAT SHE WAS IN
IT BECAUSE YOU KNOW YOU YOU NEED
VARIOUS LEVELS HERE.
IF I'M EDUCATORS.
WHO ARE PLANNING FOR EDUCATORS?
NEED A CERTAIN GRANULARITY WHEN
IT COMES TO THE DATA AND THEN
YOU MAY NEED.
TO PRIVACY BECOMES AN ISSUE
BECAUSE I MAY NEED TO KNOW WHAT
A PARTICULAR STUDENT OR GROUP OF
STUDENTS.
DID OR DID NOT DO AT SOME POINT
IN THE PROCESS THE PUBLIC ON THE
OTHER HAND.
HI THERE --
AS A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC OR AS
A PARENT I DON'T NEED TO KNOW
THAT CHARLIE DID THIS OR ONE
HUNDRED JANE OR SAM.
A WHAT I NEED TO KNOW
GENERICALLY IS YOU KNOW
SOCIOLOGY GRADUATES FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SANTA
CRUZ RIGHT HAVE A LIKELIHOOD OF
GETTING THIS KIND OF JOB ARE
DOING THIS KIND OF THING.
OF POST GRADUATION RATE IN.
AND I THINK ALL OF OUR SEGMENTS
ARE WORKING ON DOING EXACTLY
THAT WE CAN TELL YOU FOR THE
STUDENTS THAT HAVE COME TO OUR
INSTITUTIONS.
THE PROGRAMS THAT THEY MAJOR IN.
THE FIELDS THAT THEY GO IN THE
INDUSTRIES THE WORK TOGETHER ON
TRYING TO MAKE THAT AS
CONSISTENT AS POSSIBLE AS A
PARENT YOU GO TO EACH OF THE
SITE SO I UNDERSTAND.
THE BENEFITS OF HAVING THAT KIND
OF INFORMATION IN ONE PLACE SO
THAT YOU CAN SEE THAT I KNOW
IT'S MADE A BIG DIFFERENCE FOR
US TO BE ABLE. TO TO PROVIDE
THAT KIND OF TRANSPARENCY OF
ABOUT THE OUTCOMES OF GETTING A
UC DEGREE AND WHAT THAT MEANS --
I JUST THINK THAT THE YOU'RE
RIGHT THERE ARE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT QUESTIONS THAT NEED TO
BE ANSWERED STARTING WITH WHAT
YOU THINK ARE SOME OF THE TOP
PRIORITIES.
GIVES YOU A WAY TO PRIORITIZE
WHAT YOU INITIALLY WANT TO
COLLECT AND THEN UNDERSTAND WHAT
IT TAKES TO THEN INTEGRATE THAT
TOGETHER INTO A SYSTEM.
AND THEN IF THAT GIVES YOU A A
WAY TO START THEN YOU CAN BUILD
FROM THAT HAVING THAT --
UNDERSTANDING OF THE CONNECTIONS
THAT ARE THERE --
SITTING ISSUE [inaudible]
DR.
I AM HOME A DOCTOR WITH P. DIDDY
AND YOU HEARD ABOUT IT A COUPLE
OF TIMES ABOUT EIGHTY THE EDT
CONNECTS LOSS OF DATA SUCH AS
DISABILITY INSURANCE CLAIM AND
STATE ARE.
BEARD FAMILY LEAVE A DATA YOU
AYE CLEMENTS UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE CLAIMANTS DATA.
EMPLOYEES VH AREN'T UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE DATA JOB SEEKERS DATE
OUR VOTE FOR WORKFORCE
INNOVATION AND OPPORTUNITY ACT
W. I. YOU A VETERAN ADVISER
TRADE ADJUSTMENT ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM.
ELIGIBILITY TRAINING PROVIDERS
LIST CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS DATA
OCCUPATIONAL EMPLOYMENT AND
WAGES COLLECTED THROUGH
ESTABLISHMENT SURVEY TWICE A
YEAR.
CALIFORNIA LABOR FORCE NUMBER
OFTEN FLORIDA NUMBER OF
UNEMPLOYED.
UNEMPLOYMENT DATE. FOR STATE AND
LOCAL AREAS INDUSTRY AND
OCCUPATION EMPLOYMENT PROJECTION
DATA SO MORE DETAIL ABOUT ALL
THESE DATA IS PROVIDED --
AND THE HAND OUT OF IT IS THAT I
THINK YOU HAVE THAT HANDOUT.
IT LOOKS LIKE THIS.
I HAVE THAT YEAH OKAY.
SO AFTER REVIEWING TATE
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEMS FOR
MULTIPLE STAIRS I CAME UP WITH
THE CONCLUSIONS THAT EDT STORE
DATA SERVICE.
BASS RIDGE FILED FOR CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYEES AND EMPLOYERS INDUSTRY
DATE OF AND PLAY A CRUCIAL ROLE
IN BUILDING OUR STATE
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM.
THESE TWO DATA SETS CONTAIN
INFORMATION THE END CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYERS FOR APPROXIMATELY
NINETEEN MILLION CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYEES WITH THEIR NAMES
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS VERY
DESPAIRED.
PERSONAL INCOME TAX WITHHELD
MONTHLY EMPLOYMENT TOTAL
QUARTERLY BRIDGES AND INDUSTRY
COURT.
THESE DATA SETS WILL HELP US TO
DETERMINE THE NUMBER AND
PERCENTAGE OF GRADUATES IN FLOYD
IN CALIFORNIA MEDIAN OR AVERAGE
EARNINGS OVER TIME SUCH AS ONE
THIRTY FIVE YEARS AFTER
GRADUATION.
WE WILL BE ALSO ABLE TO GET OUR
NAMES FOR GRADUATES BY INDUSTRY
THAT FREUDIAN.
SO BUT THERE ARE FEW LIMITATIONS
OF ALL THESE DATA SETS I WOULD
LIKE TO MENTION DATA DOES NOT
PALATABLE BECAUSE I'M FLOYD FULL
TIME OR PART TIME.
INFORMATION NOT AVAILABLE FOR
THE GRADUATE SWAT EMPLOYED ONLY
IN CALIFORNIA.
DOES NOT PROVIDE OCCUPATIONAL
INFORMATION THAT BEACH
OCCUPATION THEY ARE EMPLOYED IN.
NOT INCLUDED IN THE FILE ARE
SELF EMPLOYED FEDERAL EMPLOYEES
RAILROAD WORKERS STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ELECTED OFFICIALS
WORK STUDY STUDENTS INSURANCE
AND REAL ESTATE AGENTS BEARD
ONLY BY A COMMISSION AND FEW
MORE WHAT WHAT WOULD WORK BEST
UP WHY WHY IS THAT.
I MEAN WE PAY STATE TAXES.
I THINK A WELFARE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT YOU WAIT YOU A TAX
EFFORT IS NOT COVERED UNDER THE
WEIGHT AT TECH.
TAXES TOLD THEY ARE NOT INCLUDED
SO EVEN THOUGH OF FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEE WHO RESIDES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WOULD WOULD FILE A CALIFORNIA
STATE INCOME TAX RETURN YEAH SO
I'VE I'VE.
WELL YOU PROBABLY HAVE ME IN
YOUR SYSTEM BUT YEAH STATE
WORKERS FILE CALIFORNIA.
STATE INCOME TAX RETURNS STATE
WORKERS ARE LIKE NINETY
CALIFORNIA NINETY EIGHT POINT
NINETY EIGHT POINT 5% BUSINESSES
ARE LIKE.
ARE COVERED UNDER YOU WHY IS
THERE ANOTHER DATABASE THAT --
WHERE WE COULD CAPTURE SO IF I
GRADUATE FROM?
THE UNIVERSITY OF YOU SEE I
CALIFORNIA IRVINE AND I GO TO
WORK FOR THE SOCIAL SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION IN ORANGE COUNTY.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE ME IN
YOUR SYSTEM BUT I'M GONNA BE
FILING A CALIFORNIA STATE INCOME
TAX RETURN.
HOW WOULD I GET THAT INFORMATION
ACTUALLY IS FOR DATA COMES FROM
THE EMPLOYERS?
AND ALL THE EMPLOYEES RETIRED.
BY THAT EMPLOYED HEY PROVIDE US
THE DATA I SEE YOU DON'T YOU
HAVE IT'S THE EMPLOYER RETURNED
IT FOR YOU I RETURN FORTNIGHTLY
AND QUARTERLY RETURN YOU USE.
WE YOU DON'T ACCESS YOU CAN
BARELY ACCESS THE CALIFORNIA
STATE INCOME TAX RETURN DATABASE.
WITH THERE MUST BE ONE FRANCHISE
TAX WE DO COLLECT INCOME TO L.
PERSONAL INCOME TAX THROUGH --
THAT QUARTERLY COLLECTION FROM
THE EMPLOYEE I DON'T KNOW
ACTUALLY --
BUT LEE IS HERE IF YOU CAN
ANSWER THIS QUESTION.
CONSIDER UP MAYBE.
I DON'T WANT TO BELABOR IT WAS
JUST FASCINATING BECAUSE I'VE
READ ALL THIS IN HERE AND I
THOUGHT WELL I WONDER WHY WE
CAN'T CAPTURE THAT OTHER DATA
BECAUSE THEY DO FILE RETURNS I
DO THINK IT'S ALSO KIND OF WHO'S
AT THIS TABLE TODAY THAT MAYBE.
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD SHOULD
BE AT THIS TABLE I WOULD SAY --
YOU KNOW I THINK IT GOES BACK TO
THE QUESTION ABOUT WHAT WE WANT
TO USE THE DATA FOR YOU I THINK
WE FOUND THAT.
BECAUSE NEARLY ALL OF YOU KNOW
WE FIND NEARLY ALL OF OUR FORMER
STUDENTS.
IN THE EDT --
DATABASE THAT --
FOR THE PURPOSES WERE USING IT
FOR TODAY KIND OF OUTCOMES FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS --
THAT SUFFICIENT IF THERE'S SOME
OTHER INDIVIDUAL LEVEL --
KIND OF QUESTION THAT FOLKS HAVE
THOUGH IT --
IT MAY NOT BE ESPECIALLY FOR
LOOKING AT CERTAIN INDUSTRIES.
THE OTHER POINT I WOULD JUST
MAKE ON THAT POINT IS THAT --
YOU KNOW WE WE ARE THINKING
ABOUT THIS KIND OF IN A PIPELINE
METAPHOR THAT WE OFTEN USE THAT
STUDENTS GO FROM ONE PLACE TO
THE OTHER --
MANY TIMES STUDENTS YOU KNOW ARE
TENDING MULTIPLE OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS AT ONCE BUT THEY'RE
ALSO ACCESSING PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS.
THAT YOU KNOW WITH FOLKS THAT
ARE NOT THIS TABLE TO CAL FRESH
BUT IF IT'S CAL WORKS BENEFITS --
THAT AGAIN DEPENDING ON THE
QUESTION YOU KNOW CHANCE OAKLEY
TALKED A LOT TODAY ABOUT
STUDENTS BASIC NEEDS IF WE'RE
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HOW THE
STATE IS MEETING BASIC NEEDS.
OF IT I THINK THOSE OTHER KIND
OF UNDERSTANDING THE VARIETY OF
PROGRAM STUDENTS ARE ACCESSING
WOULD BE INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT
RIGHT I I AND AND I'M SURE.
I JUST WAS CURIOUS BECAUSE OF
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT.
DATA POINT THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD CAPTURES.
A STATE INCOME TAX RETURN BUT MY
RECOLLECTION IS YOU HAVE TO LIST
YOUR OCCUPATION SO YOU MIGHT GET.
A LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL ON THE
OCCUPATION BEYOND INDUSTRY CODE
BECAUSE INDUSTRY CO JUST SORT OF
BROAD --
THAT WOULD JUST BE ONE EXAMPLE I
THINK AND THEN THEY'RE OTHER
PEOPLE PROBABLY THERE MAY BE
OTHER BE BE OTHER PEOPLE WHO.
FOLLOW CALIFORNIA STATE INCOME
TAX RETURN.
BUT DON'T NECESSARILY WORK FOR
AN EMPLOYER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WERE THERE WOULD NOT BE AN
EMPLOYER RETURN THAT HAD THAT
CAPTURED THE EMPLOYEE I. I
REALIZE I'M GETTING INTO.
I LOVE YOU GETTING INTO THE READ
THAT'S EXACTLY WHERE WE LIVE AND
OCCUPATION IS SORT OF THE HOLY
GRAIL THAT WE ALWAYS WANT TO BE
ABLE TO GET --
WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT TRYING TO
ACCESS IT ON MANY OF THAT --
TAX FORMS WHEN WE'VE TRIED TO
SEE WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE IT ENDS
UP BEING A TEXT FIELD.
OF VERSES IN INDUSTRY CODE WHICH
MAKES IT A LITTLE BIT MORE
CHALLENGING TO WORK WITH BUT
WE'RE TRYING TO SEE IF THERE ARE
ARE WAYS YOU CAN LEARN IT SO.
IT'S SO GETTING A SENSE AGAIN OF
WHAT WHAT YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO
ANSWER AND THEN HOW THE DATA IS
COLLECTED ALL HELP YOU FIGURE
OUT HOW SUCCESSFUL IT'D BE I
KNEW THIS WOULD BE AN
INTERESTING CONVERSATION I THINK
I HAVE A GERMAN HERE'S SENATOR
OFF MY NAME'S.
BRADLEY HODGES ON THE TAXPAYER
RIGHTS ADVOCATE FOR THE
LIMITATIONS OF EXISTING DATA AND
YOU WERE ON POINT WHEN YOU
MENTION THAT IT'S EIGHTY THESE
QUARTERLY WAGES.
SO WOULD BE INDIVIDUALS BY
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER.
THE WAGES THAT THEY AREN'T IN
THE WITH HOLDINGS THAT THEY HAD
BUT THAT'S REPORTED BY EMPLOYEES
IN CALIFORNIA EMPLOYER OR
CALIFORNIA.
AND IT WOULDN'T INCLUDE CERTAIN
TYPES OF AN EXEMPT EMPLOYMENT OR
WAGES THAT ARE REPORTED TO BE DE
MAYBE FROM FEDERAL EMPLOYERS SO
HE WAS JUST TRYING TO POINT OUT
THAT THERE COULD BE SOME GAPS IN
THAT DATA.
AND WE WOULD HAVE TO SEEK OTHER
AREAS YOU REFERENCED --
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD IS TRUE
THEY DO BUSINESS AND INDIVIDUAL
AND TAX RETURNS FOR CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS AND NONRESIDENTS THIS
HAD WITHHOLDING SO.
I MEAN I I'M NOT SURE IF THAT'S
A PLACE THAT THE EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS WOULD WANT TO LOOK.
BUT I KNOW THAT EDT DOES
CURRENTLY SHARE DATA WITH THE
NUMBER OF THESE --
EDUCATIONAL FOLKS.
AND HE WAS WILL SOME DAY IS
BETTER THAN NONE BUT I GUESS
SINCE WERE.
TRYING.
TO SOMEBODY'S TRYING TO PUT A
SYSTEM TOGETHER WE MIGHT AS WILL
OPEN THE CANOPY WAS ISSUES OR
THROUGH.
I THINK HE SAID YOU OF SIR THANK
YOU SIR THANK YOU.
IF NEEDED FOR THIS LONGITUDINAL
DATA SYSTEM GRADUATES CAN BE
MATCHED USING SSM BID THE EDT IS
GOOD IN THE STATE OF THEIR TOP
OF FIND OUT IF THE HOW.
TO IF THEY HAVE APPLIED FOR THE
WAY BENEFITS DA BENEFITS BEARD
FAMILY LEAVE OR EVEN IF THEY
HAVE PARTICIPATED IN.
WORKFORCE TRAININGS AND
EMPLOYMENT SUCH AS MIKE A MICRO
LEVEL DATA SHARED WITH THE
ENTITIES AUTHORIZED UNDER
CALIFORNIA YOU A QUARTER SECTION.
TEN NINETY FIVE EDT HAS EXISTING
DATA SHARING AGREEMENT WITH
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES JOHNSON AS OFFICE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SYSTEM.
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION CENSUS BUREAU
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR.
AND FEW OTHER CALIFORNIA STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND CALIFORNIA LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PLANNING AGENCIES.
UPON REQUEST A NONCONFIDENTIAL
GET TO DATE UP.
OUR SHARED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE.
PRIVATE EDUCATION AND ENTITIES
RESEARCH GROUPS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPERS AND MEDIA. FOR PUBLIC
USE WOULD PUBLISH.
AGGREGATED DATA ON THE EDT
WEBSITE.
A AND ALSO WE HAVE AS I
MENTIONED --
DAVIDOVICH'S INDUSTRY AND
EMPLOYMENT PROJECTIONS DATA.
A THAT DATA TELLS THAT ABOUT THE
INDUSTRIES AND OCCUPATIONS WHICH
ARE DECLINING AND GROWING AND
ABOUT APPLICATIONS HOLD MANY JOB
OPENINGS.
L. R. N. LIKE WE WE DO THE LONG
TERM.
A PROJECTION FOR TEN YEARS THAT
HOW MANY OPENINGS WILL BE THERE
FOR THEIR SPECIFIC OCCUPATION
HOW MUCH THE PERSON WILL BE
EARNING.
AND WHAT IS THE WELL I EDUCATION
REQUIRED FOR THAT KIND OF
OCCUPATION GOOD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR I DAVID
O'BRIEN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION --
I'M HERE TO ADDRESS --
DATA IN THE THE SORT OF COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY PIECE OF THE
QUESTION AND HOW IT RELATES TO
WHAT WE DO SO AS YOU KNOW WHERE
THE STATE'S FINANCIAL AID AGENCY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM.
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT
APPLICATION AND MANY MORE WE
RECEIVE A LOT OF DATA --
SEVERAL MILLIONS OF POINTS OF
DATA PER COMES DIRECTLY FROM
STUDENTS THEMSELVES SO WHEN JANE
OR WAN -- IS
GETTING READY TO APPLY FOR
COLLEGE.
ABOUT HALF OF THEM SO
STATISTICALLY ONLY CHEN OR WAN
BUT NOT BOTH OF HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS IN CALIFORNIA WILL FILL
OUT AN APPLICATION FOR FINANCIAL
AID THE MAIN FORMER WHICH IS THE
FAST THE FREE APPLICATION FOR
FEDERAL STUDENT AID --
IF THEY ARE INELIGIBLE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT IN
CALIFORNIA THEY CAN FILL OUT THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT APPLICATION.
AT THE COMMISSION WE RECEIVED
OVER ONE AND A HALF MILLION FAST --
APPLICATIONS EVERY YEAR FROM
STUDENTS BOTH.
IN CALIFORNIA AND STUDENTS FROM
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA OF
INDICATED THAT THEY WANT A PLATE
OF A CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
UNIVERSITY.
AND THAT CONTAINS DATE OF BIRTH
AGE GENDER OR INFORMATION ABOUT
THEIR INCOME THEIR PARENTS
INCOME -- AN
ADJUSTMENT AND SO FORTH AND THEN
ALSO FROM ALL PUBLIC HIGH
SCHOOLS IN A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF PRIVATE HIGH SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA WE RECEIVE --
WAITED STUDENT GRADE POINT
AVERAGE WHICH IS REQUIRED TO
CALCULATE THE CAL GRANT
ELIGIBILITY SO ARE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS HAVE THREE DIFFERENT
GPA MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS
DEPENDING ON WHICH PROGRAM.
THE STUDENT IS ELIGIBLE FOR THE
WE RECEIVE ALL OF THAT AND WE
USE THAT TO CALCULATE PRIMARILY
STUDENT ELIGIBILITY WHICH IS OF
COURSE OUR MAIN FUNCTION.
AND THEN THE STUDENT CHEN OR WAN
HEY THERE CAL GRANT OR ONE OF
OUR OTHER PROGRAMS.
AND FROM THERE ON I WILL SAY
THAT OUR ACCESS TO THE DATA AS A
STATE AGENCY.
IS LIMITED AND I SAY THIS NOT IN
ANY WAY WHATSOEVER TO THE
SMARTER COLLEAGUES AT THE
INSTITUTIONS ARE THE SEGMENTS.
BUT BECAUSE THERE'S AND THERE
HASN'T BEEN A LONGITUDINAL DATA
BASE THAT INCORPORATES
INFORMATION ABOUT FINANCIAL AID
OR ANY SORT OF STATE POLICY
ABOUT THAT DATA.
WE QUITE HONESTLY DO STRUGGLE
WHEN WE ARE ASKED BY LEGISLATORS
SUCH AS YOURSELVES BY OUTSIDE
RESEARCH GROUPS THINGS LIKE WELL
WHAT ARE THE OUTCOMES OF
FINANCIALLY DOES THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM.
HELPS STUDENTS GRADUATE AS A
STUDENT WHO RECEIVES A CAL GRANT
MORE OR LESS LIKELY TO GRADUATE
ON TIME THE STUDENTS SIMILAR
CIRCUMSTANCE WHO DIDN'T RECEIVE
A CAL GRANT.
IF THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
LEVEL ANYWAY WE DON'T RECEIVE
GRADUATION DATA ON WHETHER A
STUDENT THAT WE'RE PAYING HAS
GRADUATED FROM THEIR COLLEGE
UNIVERSITY OR HAS TRANSFERRED --
WE KNOW WHEN THEY STOP GETTING
PAID A CAL GRANT.
BUT CAL GRANT HAS A FOUR YEAR
LIFETIME ELIGIBILITY LIMIT SO
THAT COULD EASILY BE A STUDENT
AND WE KNOW THERE ARE A LOT OF
THE STUDENTS.
WHO IS TAKING A LITTLE LONGER TO
GRADUATE BUT HAS EXHAUSTED THEIR
CALVIN ELIGIBILITY FROM THAT
POINT ON WE DO NOT HAVE
INFORMATION AT THE STATE AGENCY
LEVEL ABOUT THAT STUDENT?
ANOTHER LIMITATION ON OUR DATA --
TO BE PERFECTLY FRANK HAS TO DO
WITH RACE AND ETHNICITY OF ALL
THE THINGS THE FAST SO DOES
COLLECT IT NO LONGER COLLECTS
INFORMATION --
SELF REPORTED ON STUDENTS RACE
OR ETHNICITY AND WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE IS A LOT OF INTEREST --
THAT INTEREST IN KNOWING --
ABOUT HOW STATE FINANCIAL AID IS
OR IS NOT DISTRIBUTED IN AN
EQUITABLE MANNER I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY OFFICIALLY SPEAKING WE
ARE.
A RACE NEUTRAL IN TERMS OF HOW
WE DISTRIBUTE IT BUT WE ARE
UNABLE TO RELIABLY REPORT AGAIN
AT THE STATE LEVEL INFORMATION
ON THE DISBURSEMENT --
THE DISTRIBUTION OF FINANCIAL
AID BASED ON RACE OR ETHNICITY
THEY DON'T YOU DON'T EVEN YOU'RE
NOT EVEN PERMITTED --
TO OF TERRA FORM BASIS FOR
EXAMPLE KEEP.
BLIND DATE IS TO RACE AND
ETHNICITY IN TO KNOW WHO'S
APPLIED.
THAT'S CORRECT A LOT OF THAT HAS
TO DO WITH THE FACT THAT WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF THE DREAMER
POPULATION WHICH IS --
A SMALL SUBSET OF THE STUDENTS
WE SERVE MOST STUDENTS FELT THE
FEDERAL APPLICATION TO GET STATE
AID THERE'S NO SEPARATE CAL
GRANT OR STATE CALIFORNIA
APPLICATION FOR FINANCIAL AID.
AND SO WE'RE SORT OF SUBJECT TO
THE WHIMS OF WHATEVER THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES OR DOES
NOT INCLUDE ON THE FAST THAT SO
THAT'S THE THAT IS CORRECT --
BUT WERE AWARE THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF INTEREST IN THAT AND I
THINK FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
HAVING SOME TYPE OF EITHER
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM OR JUST
SORT OF STATE POLICY.
AROUND DATA AND DATA SHARING --
IT WOULD REALLY HELP IN TERMS OF
THE WAY XIN HELP US NO --
WHAT POPULATIONS WE MAY OR MAY
NOT NEED TO TARGET MORE YOU KNOW
FOR EXAMPLE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL-CAL GRANT AID TO STUDENTS WITH
DEPENDENT CHILDREN --
HAVING INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
THOSE STUDENTS.
GRADUATION OR ON TIME COMPLETION
OF RATES ARE AFFECTED BY THE
RECEIPT OF FINANCIAL AID WOULD
BE ENORMOUSLY HELPFUL TO US IN
KNOWING HOW TO EVALUATE SUCH A
PROPOSAL WELL PRESUMABLY THE
INSTITUTIONS HAVE THAT HEY THAT
AND PROVIDE REPORTS.
THAT'S CORRECT INTERNALLY THE
QUESTION IS YOU JUST DON'T GET
THE REPORT THAT'S CORRECT AND
AGAIN THAT'S NOT AT ALL DUE TO
ANY SORT OF MALFEASANCE ON THE
INSTITUTIONS PART IS JUST DUE TO
THE FACT THAT THAT HASN'T BEEN.
PART OF THE PROCESS OR THE
SYSTEM UNTIL NOW WE DO OBVIOUSLY
ENGAGE ON A ON A ONE TO ONE SORT
OF CASE BY CASE BASIS WITH
INSTITUTIONS AND SEGMENTS WE
HAVE MEMORANDA OF UNDERSTANDING
WITH -- ALL
OF THE SEGMENTS HERE AT THE
TABLE TODAY AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO GET
VARIOUS DATA BUT I THINK ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE'RE INTERESTED
IN POLICY WISE IS.
COULD A LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM
OR SOME SORT SORT OF STATUTORY
EXPECTATION OF THE LEGISLATURE
HELP AUTOMATE SOME OF THOSE
PROCESS SEES SO THAT WHEN WE GET
ASKED FROM LEGISLATORS OR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC OR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RESEARCHERS
WHOEVER IT IS.
HEY HOW IS A HOUSE THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM AFFECTING.
THE THE MOVE TO INCREASE THE
FOUR YEAR GRADUATION RATE AT CSU --
I THINK IT WOULD PROBABLY BE WE
DON'T HAVE TO REACH OUT TO MEET
THEM AND NOT A CONCERN AS WELL
AND SAY LET'S SET UP A FORMAL
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING.
AND HAVE ALL THE ATTORNEYS GO
OVER AT AND CHECK ALL THE BOXES
THE WE CAN COLLECT THIS DATA AND
THEN YOU KNOW SEVERAL MONTHS OR
WHO KNOWS MAYBE EVEN YEARS LATER
WE'LL BE ABLE TO REPORT BACK.
ON THAT METRIC I THINK THAT
HAVING A SYSTEMOR A POLICY IN
PLACE --
ALONG THESE LINES COULD.
REALLY AUTOMATE THAT AND ENABLE
US TO PERFORM OUR FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY AS STEWARDS OF
OVER TWO AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS IN TAXPAYER FUNDS. TO
REPORT ON HOW THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
OR AREN'T WORKING OR COULD OR
COULD NOT BE IMPROVED SO.
WHAT ARE THE ISSUES THAT YOU ALL
SEE YOU?
WITH REGARD TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A LONGITUDINAL
DATA SYSTEM SOMEWHERE IN HERE
HERE I WAS READING ABOUT STUDENT
IDENTIFICATION.
OF NUMBERS --
VERSUS SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS
AND HOW ALL THAT WORKS --
SUMMER REQUIRED SOMEWHERE
REQUIRED IN.
SUMMER VOLUNTARY AND IF YOU
START AT THE VERY BEGINNING YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT GEOMETRY WE CAN'T
EVEN TELL YOU WHAT OPPORTUNITIES
CHILDREN ENGAGED IN BEFORE THEY
ENTERED KINDERGARTEN.
THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THEIR THIRD GRADE
SCORES THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM TO
MOVE THROUGH THEIR COURSE WORK
AND ACTUALLY TAKE THAT AND THEN
BE SUCCESSFUL IN EITHER A CAREER.
THAT'S VIABLE OR IN COLLEGE
RIGHT NOW SO.
IF YOU GO BACK MAP IT AND LOOK
AT EQUITY THERE IS ACTUALLY AN
OPPORTUNITY GAP SO HOW WE'RE
CAPTURING THOSE EARLY LEARNING
YEARS AND NOT BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
THAT WE KNOW HAPPENS.
THERE'S RESEARCH THAT SHOWS THE
IMPACT OF EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN
MONTHS AROUND OPPORTUNITIES THAT
IS ACTUALLY DIRECTLY AFFECTING
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
SO THE MORE IF YOU WANT TO KNOW
WHAT WHAT COLLEGE READINESS
MEANS BEING ABLE TO GO BACK AND
SAY WHERE WHERE THOSE CHILDREN
FOR EARLY LEARNING EXPERIENCES
WHAT QUALITY LEVELS FOR THOSE
EXPERIENCES AND THEN HOW DO WE
REALLY.
INVEST IN THOSE COMPONENTS OF IT
WHICH WHICH WE THEN SEE HELP
PROMOTE THOSE THIRD GRADE
READING SCORES IN MATH SCORES
WHICH AND PROMOTE THEIR ABILITY
TO APPLY TO COLLEGE.
AND BE SUCCESSFUL SO IT STARTS
IN AS WE SAY WITH OUT THAT
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY WON'T BE
ABLE TO MAKE SOME DECISIONS THAT
HELP THEM CREATE THAT VERY
COMPETITIVE INTERNATIONAL
WORKFORCE.
SO IS THE ISSUE PUTTING A MARKER
ON THESE YOUNG PEOPLE A NUMBER
OR SOMETHING HOW TO HOW DO WE DO
THIS.
HAVING THAT A UNIQUE ID IS
OBVIOUSLY A BIG PIECE OF IT
HAVING A STRONGER DATA SYSTEM
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY PUT THE
UNIQUE ID INTO AS A COMPONENT OF
IT.
AND DINE OUT MY COLLEAGUE OVER
HERE ALSO MENTIONED --
THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS TO OTHER
SERVICES SO A LOT OF THE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES THAT ARE
IN OUR PROGRAMS ALSO HAVE
SNAPPED THERE ARE ALSO ENGAGED
IN OTHERS TO NOT ONLY OUR
FAMILIES HAVING TO APPLY.
MULTIPLE TIMES TO DETERMINE
ELIGIBILITY WE THEN AREN'T ABLE
TO CONNECT THOSE FAMILIES ACROSS
THE SERVICES.
SO IF THEY WERE IN A HOME
VISITING PROGRAM IF THEY HAD A
DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENING THOSE
THINGS DON'T CONNECT ACROSS FUND
TO ACTUALLY CREATE A PICTURE OF
THE WHOLE CHILD.
AND WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THAT
CHILD'S LIFE SO WE CAN DETERMINE
WHERE TO MAKE BETTER INVESTMENTS
WE INVEST A LOT OF MONEY.
BUT HOW WELL DO WE INVEST IT
THAT I CAN'T TELL YOU INTO WE
HAVE SOME OF THE BETTER DATA TO
BE ABLE TO LINK CAN SORT OF
CARRY THROUGH IN A LONGITUDINAL
WAY.
WHAT POINT IS A UNIQUE
IDENTIFIER ASSIGNED TO A
PARTICULAR STUDENTS AND AND HOW
FAR IN THIS IT ALONG THE SYSTEM
DOES IT?
CONTINUE TO FOLLOW THE STUDENTS
BEFORE WE SHIFT TO A SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER IF IF AT ALL SO
AND WHEN CENTER CAN A GARDEN OUR
PRE K. IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM THEY ARE ASSIGNED TO
STUDENT IDENTIFIER.
AND IT'S AN IDENTIFIER CARRIES
ITH THEM AS LONG AS THEY'RE IN
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM AT THE
K. TWELVE SEGMENT MODEL WE'VE.
ALSO ARE GOING TO BE BEGIN
COLLECTING AS THEY RELATED HARD
TOLD --
EDUCATION STUDENTS THROUGH THAT
SAME IDENTIFIER --
IN IN THIS NEXT SUMMER THOSE FOR
COLLECTING DATA ON OUR SIX POINT
TWO MILLION KIDS THREE MILLION
KIDS --
EVERY YEAR WE KNOW A LOT OF
INFORMATION ABOUT THEM BECAUSE
OF THAT INFORMATION WE COLLECT
BUT WE ALSO ARE ABLE TO MATCH
THAT DATA.
NOT USING THE STEPS TO IDENTIFY
BUT USING THINGS LIKE NAME AND
AND BIRTH DATE WITH --
AGENCIES --
SUCH AS DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES WE KNOW WHO ARE
CONSIDERED FOSTER YOUTH UNDER
THEIR AUSPICES.
SAME THING WITH DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO
DETERMINE FREE AN ELIGIBLE FREE
ENTERPRISE ELIGIBLE MALES SO
STUDENTS DON'T HAVE TO COME BACK
AGAIN AND TELL US OR HAVE A
PARENT FILL OUT AN APPLICATION
WE ALREADY DIRECT CERTIFY THEM.
AND THEN ANOTHER --
PIECE OF WHICH WE DO DIRECTOR OF
CASE WE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT
THIS AT THIS AGENCY AT ALL BUT
TEACHER CREDENTIALING COMMISSION
WE ACTUALLY KNOW MORE ABOUT
WHERE OUR TEACHERS ARE TEACHING
BECAUSE WE'RE COLLECTING THAT
DATA WERE AS A COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING IS
COLLECTED ABOUT THEIR CREDENTIAL.
SO WE HAVE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
ENTERING INTO AGREEMENTS WITH
OUR HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS
THAT ARE TRAINED AS TEACHERS AND
GIVING THEM BACK INFORMATION
BECAUSE WE HAVE THAT DATA VERSUS --
AND AGENCIES A TO THE TEACHER
CREDENTIALING COMMISSION ONCE
YOU ONCE YOU.
COLLATOR COMPILED THE DATA.
USING NAMES AND BIRTHDATES
BECAUSE THESE OTHER AGENCIES
DON'T HAVE A STUDENT IDENTITY.
THE APPLICATION NUMBER
ASSOCIATED.
IT'S IN YOUR SYSTEM.
VISIT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THEN HAVE ACCESS THROUGH THIS DO
NOT IDENTIFIER. TO THAT DATA
CENTRE SO WE ENTERED INTO AN
AGREEMENT WITH THAT COMMITTEE
COLLEGES ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO
THAT AS STUDENTS ARE APPLYING TO
THE COMMUNICATIVE.
THEY ARE --
PINYIN AGAINST OUR DATABASE TO
ENSURE THAT THE THE NUMBER THAT
THEY ARE IN PUTTING ISN'T IS IS
THE ACCURATE --
NUMBER WE HAVE AT HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE OTHER
SEGMENTS ABOUT THAT --
BUT BUT BECAUSE WE DO HAVE THAT
YOU LEVEL AND THEY WERE ABLE TO
ADD IT TO THEIR APPLICATION THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAS BEEN
RECEIVING THAT DATA --
FROM FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION I JUST DID THIS TO ADD
TO CITIES OUT OF WITH A SECURITY
NUMBERS OF THE K. TWELVE DOES
NOT COLLECT SO SECURITY NUMBERS
WE ARE NOT ABLE TO ACCESS WAGE
DATA AS A RESULT OF THAT.
SO WE ARE EXPLORING --
THROUGH A A AND REMOTE WITH THE
COMMUNICABLE EDGES ON HOW TO
ACCESS WAGE DATA.
VIA AN AGREEMENT WITH THEM
BECAUSE THEY KNOW WHERE THEIR
STUDENTS THEY'RE ABLE TO OBTAIN
NATION BECAUSE THEY HAVE SO
SECURITY NUMBERS BUT BECAUSE
BAUER-KAHAN DOES NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO THAT INFORMATION.
THERE IS --
AVOID -- FOR
K. TWELVE STUDENT POPULATION
WHETHER NOT THEY IF THEY WENT TO
COLLEGE AGAIN WE CAN GRAB IT
FROM SOMEBODY LIKE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IF THEY DO NOT GO TO
COLLEGE AND GO STRAIGHT INTO THE
WORK FORCE.
WE DO NOT HAVE INFORMATION.
YEAH I THINK YOU'RE YOU'RE
ASKING THE RIGHT KINDS OF
QUESTIONS BECAUSE THIS WAY TO
INTEGRATE INFORMATION IS REALLY
CRITICAL FOR THE DATA THAT WE
END UP HAVING WE DO COLLECT
INFORMATION ABOUT THE THE
STUDENT ID THAT COMES IN ITSELF
REPORTED AND I CAN EASILY MAKE A
TYPO WITH.
WITH WHAT I INPUT --
SO WE TEND NOT TO USE IT BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE A WAY TO VALIDATE
WHETHER WHAT IS STUDENT PUTS IN
IS AN ACCURATE IDEA.
ABOUT WE USE --
SEVERAL OF THE MEANS TO DO IT --
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER BECAUSE
OF THE PRIVACY THINGS WITH IT
BUT WHEN WE GET DATA FROM ET DE
IT IS A KEY SOURCE.
AND WE USE ALL OUR PRIVACY MEANS
TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS THAT --
WE ACCESS DATA THROUGH OTHER
SOURCES LIKE THE NATIONAL
STUDENT CLEARINGHOUSE WHICH
GIVES US INFORMATION ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT.
STUDENTS ATTEND OTHER
INSTITUTIONS WHETHER OUR
UNDERGRADUATES GOING TO GRADUATE
SCHOOL WITH THAT WE USE AT WHAT
WE CALL IN TECHNICAL TERMS A
FUZZY MATCH --
AND THAT IS --
A LOT OF THE INFORMATION AND
THAT MY COLLEAGUE OVER HERE'S
MENTIONED NAME BIRTHDATE AND
OTHER INDICATORS WE GET A VERY
GOOD MATCH WITH THAT KIND OF
PROCESS --
I'M SURPRISED ABOUT HOW GOOD IT
IS -- BUT
THERE ARE THERE ARE OTHER WAYS
TO COLLECT IT BUT HAVING A MEANS
TO BE ABLE TO DO IT I CAN
IMAGINE NOT BEING ABLE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE INFORMATION.
WITHOUT THAT A KEY WAY FOR THE
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS IS
TRICKY SO WELL ONE MORE BENEFIT
I GUESS OF AN INTEGRATED SYSTEM
IS.
YOU COULD IN FACT GO TO CD AND
AND VALIDATE MY VERIFY THE
STUDENT AID.
UNIQUE STUDENT IDENTIFIER.
AND THEN HAVE ACCESS TO THE C.
D. BODY OF INFORMATION REGARDING
OUR STUDENTS AND AND THERE IS AN
EXCELLENT EXAMPLE --
IN THE WRITE UP OF THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE GUIDANCE
INITIATIVE WHICH THERE ARE
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE THAT ARE
THAT PROGRAM WHICH IS
EFFECTIVELY ALLOWING.
IT IS INTEGRATED WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND SEE
ISSUES APPLICATION FOR ADMISSION
SO THAT STUDENTS ACADEMIC RECORD
AND THEIR SSID ERROR STUDENT
IDENTIFIER ISSUED BY CD COMES TO
US ELECTRONICALLY THE STUDENT
DOESN'T HAVE.
TO MANUALLY KEY THAT --
SO THOSE TYPES OF OPPORTUNITIES
I THINK ALSO --
A FORTNIGHT A HUGE AMOUNT OF OF
PROMISE AS WERE TALKING AT RIGHT
NOW THAT'S ONLY ABOUT 15% OF OUR
APPLICANTS ARE SUBMITTING FROM
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE THAT
INTEGRATED OPPORTUNITY RIGHT NOW --
BECAUSE THAT ALSO VALIDATES THE
DATA IT'S THE DATE OUR CAMPUSES
ARE MAKING DECISIONS ABOUT
WHETHER BE ADMISSION PLACEMENT
ALL THOSE TYPES OF THINGS WERE
WE'RE DEPENDING ON THE THE
QUALITY OF THATDATA AS IT'S
COMING FROM OUR K. TWELVE
PARTNERS --
VERSES MUCH OF THE INFORMATION
THAT SET THE STUDENT PROVIDE
THAT THE POINT OF APPLICATION
ITSELF REPORTED --
SO THAT'S ALSO A REALITY OF OF
STRONGER INTEGRATION NOT JUST
FOR ANSWERING THE QUESTIONS HAT
WE'RE DISCUSSING.
BUT REALLY ALL SERVE TO THE
BENEFIT OF STUDENTS AS THEY'RE
MOVING THROUGH ALL OF OUR ARE
DIFFERENT --
ARE IFFERENT SEGMENTS OFTEN
SIMULTANEOUSLY AS AS BEEN
TALKED ABOUT SO THERE ARE SOME
PROMISING EXAMPLE CCJ BEING ONE
OF THOSE WHERE WE WE'VE ALREADY
MADE THAT CONNECTION IT'S NOT
EVEN A MATTER OF VALIDATING IT'S
REALLY COMING WITH THE STUDENTS
RECORD.
AND THEN WHAT WE'VE DONE SOME
SIMILAR THINGS WITH THIS DO NAY
COMMISSION AS WELL.
YOU ASKED ABOUT CHALLENGES SO
JUST WANTED TO KIND OF HIGHLIGHT --
THREE YOU KNOW I THINK SETTING
UP THE RULES ABOUT WHO USES THAT
FOR WHAT PURPOSES THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF ACCESS FOLKS HAVE TO
THE DATE I THINK IS IMPORTANT --
YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW THAT IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE BUT IT'S CERTAINLY
CERTAINLY DON'T BELIEVE IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE BUT TAKE WORK --
YOU KNOW I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS PAUSES FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE A LOT OF CHALLENGES
AND TIME.
IS VARYING INTERPRETATIONS OF
STATE AND FEDERAL PRIVACY LAWS
AND I AM NOT --
AGENCIES COUNCIL BUT MY SENSE IS
OUR COUNCIL SPENDS A LOT OF TIME
WITH OTHER ATTORNEYS FROM OTHER
AGENCIES WORKING THROUGH IT --
YOU KNOW IN MANY CASES DIFFERENT
INTERPRETATIONS OF OF THESE LAWS
AND SO I THINK --
THAT IS BEEN A BARRIER.
AND I WOULD JUST SAY YOU KNOW I
DON'T THINK WE SHOULD
UNDERESTIMATE KIND OF KNOW OUR
METHOD IS PRODUCING AMMO USE.
ROGER BUT PROJECT OR ENTITY BY
ENTITY THAT IS WORKLOAD --
AND WE MANAGE IT BY WE GET
REQUESTS WE HAVE A SET OF
PRIORITIES THAT --
YOU KNOW TODAY ARE LINKED TO OUR
VISION FOR SUCCESS SO WE LOOK AT
A REQUESTED WE SAY YOU KNOW IT'S
GOING.
TO A YOU KNOW ALL OF THESE
REQUESTS TOGETHER WILL REQUIRE
MORE OF OUR TIME THAT WE CAN PUT
TO THIS SO WHICH OF THESE DATA
REQUEST BEST SUPPORTS THE VISION
FOR SUCCESS --
THAT MAY NOT BE THE OTHER YOU
KNOW THE OTHER AGENCY MAY COME
TO THE CONVERSATION WITH A
DIFFERENT SET OF PRIORITIES.
AND IF IT DOESN'T --
IF IT DOESN'T ALIGN WITH OUR
VISION FOR SUCCESS IT MAKES IT
HARDER FOR US TO JUSTIFY
PRIORITIZING THAT AGENCIES
EDITOR.
AND OF COURSE THAT'S A THAT'S A
PROBLEM OR AN ISSUE THAT.
IS ASSOCIATED WITH STOVE PIPE.
TO OPERATIONS RIGHT I MEAN SO
THAT'S THAT'S THE QUESTION ONE
OF ONE OF THE THINGS THAT LIKE
FOR YOU TO TALK TO ME ABOUT AND
PROBABLY MORE IMPORTANTLY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
[inaudible]
IS A IN THIS PROCESS.
IN LOOKING AT THE DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENTATION CENTRALIZED
VERSUS I THINK THE WORD YOU ALL
USES FEDERATED BUT SEPT SEPARATE
SYSTEMS.
LINKED.
BUT I'M GONNA AB MAYBE JUST
ROUND OUT THE LAST QUESTION I
CAN AND TRANSITION THIS BUT
CERTAINLY --
HI MY COLLEAGUES WAY AND I DON'T
THINK --
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES WE TALKED
ABOUT CAN BE UNDERSTATED --
DOCTOR BROWN MENTIONED THE THE
DATA SECURITY DATA PRIVACY AND
NOT ONLY IS THE CHALLENGE OF
BRINGING OUR ATTORNEYS TO THE
CONVERSATION INTERPRETATION.
BUT IT'S ALSO A CONSTANTLY
SHIFTING --
ENVIRONMENT --
IN TERMS OF THE SECURITY THAT'S
NECESSARY WHAT'S HAPPENING --
OUR INSTITUTIONS ARE ALSO
SUBJECT AND TO A TWO FOR EXAMPLE --
LAWS THAT ARE ARE IT FROM THE
EUROPEAN UNION IF WE HAVE
STUDENTS THAT HAVE ENTERED --
SO THERE ARE CONSTANTLY NEW AND
EMERGING CHALLENGES IN THE DATA
SECURITY DATA PRIVACY FRONT AND
I THINK.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
AND AND TO CHRISTIANS POINT I
THINK SPEND A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF TIME ON IT WILL HAVE TO ALSO
BE VERY MUCH A PART OF THE
CONVERSATION.
AND ALL OF THE DATA USAGE THE
TYPE OF QUESTIONS BUT ALSO THE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
PRIVATE --
ADDRESSING PRIVACY AND SECURITY
CONCERNS BECAUSE IT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE WORK THROUGH I THINK ON
A DAILY BASIS --
ACROSS THE BOARD AND ALL THE
STATEMENTS YOU HAVE HERE WE'RE
PRETTY SENSITIVE TO THE YEAH
SURE ABSOLUTELY ABSOLUTELY --
IN TERMS OF YOU CENTRO VERSUS
FEDERATED AYE I WOULD ALSO ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF MY CALLING
DOCTOR BROWN AND IN TERMS OF I
THINK THAT THERE ARE THERE'S
PROBABLY A COMMON SET OF OF
ELEMENTS THAT WE WOULD WANT TO
BEGIN WITH AND THAT MAKES SENSE
TO BE -- AS
A COMMON SYSTEM THAT IT THAT
THAT WERE ALL USING ACROSS THE
STATE AND THAT COULD BE
AUGMENTED OVER TIME --
SO PERHAPS WE START WITH THAT
SORT OF CENTRAL REPOSITORY OF OF
A COMMON SET OF DATA TAT HELPS
LOOK LONGITUDINALLY ACROSS --
A CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCE AND WE
BUILDING NEXT IT IS BECAUSE
URGING NEW WE'VE WE'VE NAMED ALL
TYPES OF AGENCIES THAT ARE AT
THE TABLE TODAY --
THAT ALSO ULTIMATELY I THINK
WOULD BENEFIT FROM BEING A PART
OF THE CONVERSATION SO I THINK
THERE IS AN ELEMENT TO START
WITH AS A A IS A STATEWIDE
EFFORT AND THEN WE CAN ADD TO
THAT IS AS TIME PROGRESSES.
WELL BECAUSE THERE'S CERTAIN
TYPES OF DATA THAT.
EVERYBODY WOULD USE.
AND THEN THERE'S DATA.
THAT MAY BE UNIQUELY UTILIZED BY
YOU SEE OR BY SEA ISSUE.
EVEN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES K.
TWELVE AND SO THAT WOULD NOT
NECESSARILY NEED TO BE.
IN THE COMMON POT.
AT LEAST INITIALLY.
SO THAT'S A VERY GOOD POINT ANY
OTHER ANY YES MA'AM I THINK ONE
OF THE OTHER THINGS WE THINK
ABOUT A FEDERATED VERSUS
CENTRALIZED IT IS IT'S GOING%
BACK TO THE DATA QUALITY ISSUE
AND YOU'RE GOING.
TO YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A HIGHER
LEVEL OF DATA QUALITY AT WHEN
YOU'RE CLOSEST TO WHERE YOU'RE
COLLECTING YOUR DATA FROM.
SO WITH A THOUSAND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WE ARE CONTINUE TO YOU
KNOW IMPLEMENT CHANGES IN OUR
SYSTEM TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
VALIDATIONS MAKE SURE THEY'RE
SUBMITTING --
DATA THAT IS THAT IS THAT
ACCURATE --
BUT IF YOU TAKE THAT PIECE THE
WAY YOU YOU YOU BRING IT UP
ANOTHER TWO LEVELS YOU KNOW
YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE STE FURTHER
DISTANCING YOURSELF FROM THE
STUDENT.
FROM THE TEACHER FROM THE THE
ADMINISTRATOR AND FROM THE
DISTRICT AND SO WE SPEND A GREAT
DEAL OF TIME MAKING SURE THAT
DISTRICTS ARE LOOKING AT THE
DATA PRIOR TO SUBMITTING TO A
SAINT ARE YOU REALLY SURE THAT
YOU'RE GIVING US A 100% --
ATTENDANCE RATES FOR EXAMPLE
WHICH DID HAPPEN IN OUR FIRST
OUR FIRST YEAR SO.
AT SITE AT I WOULD --
I WOULD LEVERAGE THAT THERE ARE
PIECES OF AND WHERE THEY COME
FROM -- YOU
KNOW WHAT KIND OF IT AT HIGH
SCHOOL HE ATTENDED I'M A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THEM AND THEIR PROGRAM
BUT THERE ARE OTHERS SUCH AS
WHAT THEY HAD FOR LUNCH TODAY
THAT THAT EVEN THE DEPARTMENT
ISN'T QUITE IT'S NOT RELEVANT TO
WHAT WE DO AND SO WE THINK ABOUT.
STARTING WITH WHAT A QUESTION A
PROBLEM MARIE TRYING TO SOLVE I
THINK WE GET BETTER AT FIGURING
OUT HOW TO LEVERAGE.
ON THE INVESTMENT THE STATUS
MADE IN EACH OF OUR DATA SYSTEMS
TODAY AND ESPECIALLY ON THE K.
TWELVE SIDE --
YOU KNOW WE HAVE BEEN A SUCCESS
STORY THAT WE STARTED OFF A
LITTLE BUMPY BUT WE'VE BEEN A
SUCCESS STORY IN AND TALKING
ABOUT -- HOW
TO PUT OUT A DATA SYSTEM THAT IS
FUNCTIONING AND --
IS WORKING ABLE TO PULL DATA
FROM IT ON ON A REGULAR BASIS
WELL BUT AND THERE CERTAINLY
HAVE TO BE QUALITY CONTROL
CHECKS IN THE PIPELINE BUT AS
THE DATA MOVES THROUGH BOOK.
THROUGH THE PIPE BEFORE IT
LEAVES THE THE PARTICULAR PIPE
IT'S AN WHICH WOULD BE K.
THROUGH TWELVE OR K. TWO
FOURTEEN THEY HAVE TO BE DEBT
CHECKS ON THE QUALITY THE DATA
BEFORE DUMPS OUT.
INTO THE LARGER.
SYSTEM OF WHATEVER IT IS MY
QUESTION MY CONCERN CENTRALIZED
VERSUS FEDERATED IS WE'VE WE'VE
HAD A GREAT DEAL OF AND MAY NOT
BE AN ISSUE HERE BUT WE'VE HAD A
GREAT DEAL OF DIFFICULTY.
ON THE LARGER STATE LEVEL TRYING
TO CONNECT DIFFERENT SYSTEMS
YEAH -- I
THIS IS MY FIRST RODEO HEARING
THE CASE SUBCOMMITTEE BUT I
SPENT SIX YEARS.
DEALING WITH STATE IT PROJECTS
IN THE OTHER SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND THERE WAS NOT MUCH FUN SO I
WAS JUST I'M JUST WONDERING IF
IT'S EVEN POSSIBLE TO DO HIS
FEDERATED APPROACH AND I SUPPOSE
MY OUR NEXT PANEL WILL ADDRESS
THAT.
YEAH I MEAN I THINK.
SORRY I THINK WE MIGHT ENDUP
WITH SOMETHING ONE OPTION IS IS
A BLENDED KIND OF PLAN I THINK
IT'S RIGHT THERE ARE CERTAIN
THINGS WHERE YOU'RE GOING TO
WANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE INFORMATION. TO ANSWER
THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE
HAVING THAT SET OF A KEY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU WANT THE DATA
THAT YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO
COLLECT STARTING WITH THAT WILL
GIVE YOU A WAY TO SEE THAT WE'RE
COLLECTING IT IN SIMILAR WAYS
THAT WILL MAKE SENSE IF YOU
COMBINE.
THEM TOGETHER AND THEN WHEN YOU
GO SEE TRENDS THAT YOU'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THEN THE
QUESTION IS DO I WANT TO EXPAND
WHAT I'M COLLECTING CENTRALLY OR
DO I WANT TO WORK IN A FEDERATED
WAY TO COLLECT THE INFORMATION
TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION OF THE
DAY.
AND THEN --
GO FROM THERE SO SO I HAVE
ALWAYS BELIEVED IN A SMALL BUILD
IT.
BUT SEE WHAT YOU GET AND THEN --
SEE OTHER QUESTIONS COME BECAUSE
OF THE AMOUNT OF WORK IT TAKES
TO MAINTAIN.
AT THE SYSTEMS THAT YOU END UP
CREATING --
AM I EVEN DO THAT WITH THE TEN
CAMPUSES THAT WE HAVE THERE'S
CERTAIN THINGS TAT WE COLLECT
CENTRALLY THERE ARE OTHER THINGS
WERE THEN I RELY ON THE CAMPUSES
BECAUSE THEY'RE BETTER SET TO
ANSWER THIS.
I WOULD LIKE TO MENTION ABOUT
ACTUALLY IS VERY SIMILAR --
DATABASE WHICH IS UNDER WAY
RIGHT NOW TO ANSWER THE ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY THIRTY SIX AND W. I.
YOU A CHAPTER FOUR WE ARE
TALKING BUT STUDENTS
LONGITUDINAL DATABASE BUT DEBT
IS FOR THE WORK FORCE.
IT IS UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD.
AND IT IS CALLED CROSS SYSTEM
ANALYTICS AND ASSIST ASSESSMENT
FOR LEARNING AND SKILLS
ATTAINMENT.
THE CATSKILLS PROJECT AND THERE
ARE THE PARKING DATA PARTNERS ON
LIKE ARE ELEVEN DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS.
AND DAY INCLUDING ADD DEPARTMENT
OF THREE HAVE GOT FLASH GOT GOD
WORKS COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
CAREER TECH EDUCATION STATE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM.
SO WHY I'M MENTIONING THIS ONE
ACTUALLY THERE BECAUSE THEY HAVE
BEEN THROUGH A LOT OF CHALLENGES
TO CREATE THAT DAY ABOUT WHAT
THEY WANT.
WHAT ARE THE PURPOSE OF THIS IS
TO CREATE WHAT FORCE METRICS
DASHBOARD AND ONLY?
AB MERGER PROGRAM PARTICIPATION
EFFECTIVE TRACKING UP OR
DISPENSED AND IMPROVE
PERFORMANCE ON A CAR
ACCOUNTABILITY SO IT LOOKS LIKE
IT IS VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT LONGITUDINAL
DATABASE.
SO THEY IF IT CAN BE CONSULTED
WITH THEM ACTUALLY AND I I A 2%
DDT AND THAT ON THAT PROJECT SO
THAT CAN BE CALIFORNIA'S SING
THE RESULT YEAH [inaudible]
SIR. ONE LAST THING --
THE CENTER TO ANSWER YOUR QUEST
TO ADDRESS THE QUESTION ABOUT
CENTRALIZED VERSUS FEDERATED OR
DECENTRALIZED --
I THINK.
IN TERMS OF FINANCIAL AID ONE
WAY TO LOOK AT IT IS TO WHAT
EXTENT DO WE LOOK AT THINGS LIKE
OUR STATE FINANCIALLY PROGRAMS
INITIAL CALLS AFFORDABILITY AS
EXISTING ON AN ISLAND AS A
SEPARATE ISSUE BY ITSELF THAT IS
TO SAY.
IF ONE VIEWS THE WHOLE PURPOSE
OF THE STERN A COMMISSION IN THE
CAL GRANT PROGRAM UNDERSTATE THE
FINANCIALLY PROGRAMS AS
LITERALLY JUST GETTING MONEY
INTO STUDENTS HANDS.
WELL THEN FOR THE MOST PART AND
I SAY FOR THE MOST PART BECAUSE
WE HAVE SEVERAL MORE HOURS I
COULD.
TALK ABOUT --
VERY VERY IN THE WEEDS ISSUES
THERE BUT FOR THE MOST PART
THAT'S HAPPENING WE GET AN
APPLICATION FROM CERTAINLY
PROCESSOR ELIGIBILITY.
THEY ARRIVE AT CALVIN ELIGIBLE
CAMPUS AND WE ONE OF THE THE
THINGS THAT I THINK A
CENTRALIZED DATA SYSTEM COULD DO
IS.
HELP WITH THESE OTHER QUESTIONS
BECAUSE I JUST GET THE SENSE --
FROM HAVING BEEN MY MINERAL TWO
AND A HALF YEARS AS GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FOR THE
COMMISSION THAT LEGISLATORS AND
LEGISLATIVE STAFF AND
STAKEHOLDER AREN'T JUST
INTERESTED IN.
YOU KNOW THEY'RE JUST IN MORE
THAN JUST HOW GOODA JOB YOU DO
GETTING MONEY INTO THE STUDENTS'
HANDS IT'S HOW WHAT ELSE TO THE
STE WHAT ELSE IS THIS YOU NEED
TO SUCCEED HOW YOU KNOW HOW WE
LOOK AT THE WHOLE STUDENT.
WHAT OTHER NEEDS THAT THEY HAVE
TO WHAT EXTENT CAN THE FINANCIAL
AID SYSTEM PLAY A ROLE IN LEVY
EATING FOOD AND SECURITY HOUSING --
IN SECURITY HOMELESSNESS AMONG
STUDENTS I THINK THAT.
AS LONG AS WE'RE STILL LOOKING
AT THE ISSUE OF COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY AS BEING MORE THAN
JUST ABOUT HOW DO WE GET A CHECK
INTO STUDENTS HAND BUT HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT THE WHOLE STUDENT.
IS CARED FOR AND HAS WHAT THEY
NEED TO SUCCEED THEN IT SEEMS TO
ME AND THIS IS JUST MY OPINION
NOT SPEAKING FOR THE COMMISSION
HERE THAT MAKES A PRETTY GOOD
ARGUMENT FOR SOME TYPE OF
CENTRALIZED DATA SYSTEM.
RIGHT.
OF COURSE YOU HAVE THE MOST
THORNY PRIVACY ISSUES PROBABLY
OF ANYBODY --
EXCELLENT PANEL FINANCE --
DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
PANELS.
NO QUESTIONS BUT JUST FROM JUST
SOME THOUGHTS TO REITERATE SOME
OF THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE -- I
THOUGHT THIS PANEL DID A REALLY
NICE JOB OF KIND OF HIGHLIGHTING
YOU KNOW THE DIFFERENT DATA
COLLECTION EFFORTS THAT WERE OUT
THERE IN SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT EXIST --
CHALLENGES THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS IDENTIFIED I
MEANT THAT THIS PANEL --
UNIT REITERATED CHALLENGES LIKE
IN THE SYSTEMS ARE OPERATING
UNDER DIFFERENT REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS ARE OFTEN USING
DIFFERENT DATA DEFINITIONS.
AND THERE'S A VARYING DEGREE OF
CONNECTEDNESS AND USER FRIENDLY
USER FRIENDLINESS --
ENDED MINISTRATION LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING COLLABORATIVELY WITH
YOU WHEN YOU'RE STAFF AS WELL AS
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS IN A ROOM I'M
ON THIS PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THOSE CHALLENGES GOING
FORWARD.
WELL I AGREE EXCELLENT PENALIZED
THOROUGHLY ENJOYED THE
CONVERSATION I LOOK FORWARD.
TO MEETING IN SPEAKING WITH YOU
AS WE MOVE DOWN THIS.
PANEL NUMBER.
THREE THAT WAS INTERESTING.
COME ON DOWN.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US IF I
COULD ASK YOU TO IDENTIFY
YOURSELF FOR THE RECORD STARTING
MY LEFT YOU'RE RIGHT.
MA'AM.
MY NAME IS VALERIE [inaudible]
HELLO.
THANKS FOR JOINING US I'M
CALLING FOR AND I'M THE
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF THE
EDUCATION.
CENTER FIVE MINUTES.
WERE YOU HEARD OUR DISCUSSION SO
[inaudible]
YEAH.
WHO WANTS TO GO FIRST?
THAT'S GOOD OKAY.
OKAY -- I
YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU ROB AND OTHER MEMBERS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
I THINK THAT I'M PROBABLY MORE
EDUCATION IN LIKE MANNER AND I
WAS ASKED TO GET COMMENTS TODAY
BASED ON RESEARCH I DID A COUPLE
OF YEARS.
ON CALIFORNIA'S APPROACH TO
TRACKING STUDENT PROGRESS ACROSS
K. TWELVE AND HIGHER ED AND ITS
NEEDS GOING FORWARD I THINK I
GAVE US SUMMARY DOCUMENT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO REFERENCE IT
WHILE I'M TALKING BUT JUST.
I READ THE ONE THAT WAS IN MY
PACKET OUT OKAY.
WHEN IN DOING REMARKS MAYBE YOU
COULD TOUCH ON SOME OF THE
ISSUES?
YES PHYLLIS I WILL TRY TO DO
PREPARED REMARKS THAT I THINK
ADDRESS SOME OF YOUR QUESTIONS
BUT I DID MAKE MYSELF NOTES
ABOUT LIKE PLACES TO DIVERT. TO
TO ANSWER THINGS THAT YOU ASKED
SO -- ANYWAY
I DID RESEARCH OVER A COUPLE OF
YEARS AND I'D LIKE TO START WITH
THE POSITIVE ASPECTS OF WHAT I
FOUND SO WHILE THERE IS NO
STATEWIDE CROSS SECTOR DATA
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA.
THE FOR PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEMS
EACH HAVE LONGITUDINAL STUDENT
DATA SYSTEMS THAT ARE QUITE GOOD
AS YOU HEARD THEM TALK ABOUT --
INCLUDES CAL PAD SYSTEM IT'S AND
SICK AT SEGMENTS ALSO HAS A
LONGITUDINAL STUDENT DATA SYSTEM.
SO THESE SYSTEMS CONTAIN
INFORMATION THAT'S VERY VALUABLE
FOR UNDERSTANDING STUDENT
PROGRESS AN OUTCOME WITH IN EACH
SYSTEM.
SO THE INFORMATION ARE GENERALLY
UPDATED ANNUALLY IN SOME CASES
OR AT SPECIFIED POINTS DURING
EACH TERM IN OTHER CASES
DEPENDING ON WHAT THE DATA IS.
AND THEY HAVE SOME INFORMATION
THAT'S MATCHED TO OTHER STATE
AGENCIES SO SEE SACK --
GIVES THE HIGHER END SEGMENTS
YOU KNOW SOME FINANCIAL AID
RELATED DATA THEY GET MATCHES TO
EDT DATA AS YOU ALSO HEARD TALK
ABOUT.
SO WHAT THESE DATA ARE PRIMARILY
USED FOR STATE AND FEDERAL
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
BUT IN RECENT YEARS EACH SYSTEM
OFFICE HAS INCREASED ITS EFFORTS
TO MAKE IT MORE INFORMATION
AVAILABLE THROUGH ONLINE DATA
DASHBOARDS AND OTHER REPORTS YOU
HEARD THEM MENTION A COUPLE OF
THINGS THE SALARY ARE FOR AN
UC'S INFO CENTER --
THEY SOMETIMES SHARE STUDENT
DATA AMONG THEMSELVES TO ADDRESS
PARTICULAR NEEDS AS YOU HEARD
THEM DESCRIBED.
SO WHAT'S WRONG WITH HAVING FOR
GOOD LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEMS
BUT NO CROSS SECTOR DATA SYSTEM.
SO I'LL POINT TWO THREE ISSUES.
UP FIRST THE INFORMATION WE HAVE
ABOUT STUDENT PROGRESS IN
OUTCOMES IS DISCONNECTED.
WELL THERE IS SOME DATA SHARING
AT THE SYSTEM LEVEL AS I NOTED
AND THERE ARE SOME VOLUNTARY.
DATA SHARING EFFORTS ACROSS
INSTITUTIONS IN SOME REGIONS.
WE HAVE NO WAY TO GET A
COMPREHENSIVE STATEWIDE PICTURE
OF THE EDUCATION TO WORK FORCE
PIPELINE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO FROM A BUDGET AND POLICY
PERSPECTIVE WHAT THIS DOES IS
REINFORCES CALIFORNIA'S VERY
STYLISH APPROACH TO EDUCATION
PLANNING.
OUR SECOND ISSUE IS THAT THE AND
LEE AND ACCESSIBLE WHILE I DID
MENTION THAT EACH SYSTEM HAS
PROVIDE SOME GOOD INFORMATION
IT'S OFTEN COMPLIANCE FOCUSED OR
FRAMED IN WAYS THAT SUIT THE
NEEDS AND INTERESTS OF THE
SYSTEMS THEMSELVES.
SIMILAR INFORMATION IS OFTEN
CALCULATED AND PRESENTED VERY
DIFFERENTLY ACROSS THE SYSTEMS
MAKING IT DIFFICULT FOR POLICY
MAKERS EDUCATORS STUDENTS IN THE
PUBLIC TO INTERPRET IT.
A THIRD ISSUE IS INEFFICIENCY
THE CURRENT APPROACH HAVE A
NUMBER HAVE INTO INEFFICIENCIES
BUILT INTO IT AND ONE OF THEM
KIND OF CAME UP ON THE LAST
PANEL.
SO AS ONE EXAMPLE WE HAVE
MULTIPLE AGENCIES AND INDIVIDUAL
INSTITUTIONS THAT CONTRACT WITH
THE NATIONAL STUDENT
CLEARINGHOUSE JUST IN AN EFFORT
TO TRY AND FIGURE OUT WHAT
HAPPENS TO THEIR STUDENTS WHEN
THEY LEAVE SO THIS IS.
SURELY A BOON FOR THE STUDENT
CLEARING HOUSE BUT IT'S A REAL
FAILURE TO LEVERAGE STATE
RESOURCES.
SO HAVING GOOD INFORMATION
THAT'S DISCONNECTED AN
INACCESSIBLE WITH INEFFICIENT
MEANS OF PUTTING THE PIECES
TOGETHER WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT
LEAVES US UNABLE TO ANSWER
CRITICAL QUESTIONS ABOUT STUDENT
PROGRESS AND OUT COMES ACROSS
SYSTEMS.
AND IT MAKES IT IMPOSSIBLE TO
DEVELOP EVIDENCE BASED POLICIES
AND PRACTICES THAT WILL BEST
SERVE STUDENTS AS THEY MOVE
THROUGH MULTIPLE SYSTEMS.
SO YOU ASKED ABOUT SOME SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES OF QUESTIONS AND ONE OF
MY REPORTS I HAD A LIST OF JUST
EXAMPLES OF CRITICAL QUESTIONS
WE CAN'T NOW ANSWER.
SALT GIVE YOU A COUPLE THAT ARE
PARTICULARLY POLICY FOCUSED JUST
AS EXAMPLES.
SO WHAT ARE THE OUTCOMES OF CS
YOU WHEN YOU SEE TEACHER
CANDIDATES AND WHAT IS THEIR
READY MISS AND RATE OF RETENTION
WHEN THEY CAN BECOME EMPLOYED BY
THE STATE K. TWELVE SCHOOLS.
THAT'S AN ISSUE YOU MIGHT BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS WITH A
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM IF YOU
INCLUDED --
INFORMATION ALSO FROM THE
TEACHER CREDENTIALING COMMISSION.
HOW MANY --
WHAT HAPPENS TO ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS WHO MEET ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS FOR CS YOU WHEN YOU
SEE BUT THEY'RE NOT ADMITTED DUE
TO CAPACITY CONSTRAINTS?
WHERE DO THEY GO TO THEY GO TO
COLLEGE WHERE THEY GO?
OUR DISTRICTS THAT RECEIVE WOULD
HAVE A PROBLEM THERE RIGHT
BECAUSE SOMEONE TESTIFIED IN THE
K. THROUGH TWELVE SYSTEM.
THEY DON'T CAPTURE SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS.
IN K. TO TWELVE SO IN TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THEY WERE THEY
GO ON WHAT THEY DO.
WE HAVE A PROBLEM RIGHT.
AT THE MOMENT WE DO BUT YOU
COULD LOOK AND SEE IF.
THE STUDENTS WHO WERE SAY DENIED
ADMISSION EVEN THOUGH THEY MET
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS --
THEY HAVE ALREADY PROVIDED
SECURITY NUMBER AS PART OF
HAVING APPLIED SO YOU WOULD HAVE
IT SO YOU CAN THEN LOOK AND SEE
DID THEY GO TO A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
WITH A MATCH TO THE CLEARING
HOUSE DID THEY GO OUT OF STATE
DEBATE WITH THE MATCH TO EDT DID
THEY END UP GOING STRAIGHT TO
WORK AND DIDN'T GO TO COLLEGE AT
ALL.
SO THOSE THOSE ARE KINDS OF
THINGS YOU CAN FIGURE OUT LIKE
WHAT HAPPENED WHAT WHAT ARE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF OUR CAPACITY
CONSTRAINTS IN THE CSU WHEN YOU
SEE SYSTEMS ON ACTUAL STUDENTS.
SO YOU KNOW JUST AS ONE MORE
EXAMPLE ARE DISTRICTS THAT
RECEIVE EXTRA FUNDING THROUGH
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA INCREASING THE
PROPORTION OF THEIR STUDENTS WHO
ENROLL IN COLLEGE READY TO
SUCCEED.
WE'VE IMPLEMENTED A LOT OF BIG
STAE INITIATIVES AND POLICIES
IN RECENT YEARS WITH VERY LITTLE
ABILITY --
TO ANALYZE HOW EFFECTIVE THEY
ARE.
SO THOSE ARE JUST A FEW EXAMPLES
OF QUESTIONS YOU KNOW THAT YOU
MIGHT BE INTERESTED IN THAT A
LONGITUDINAL.
DATA SYSTEM COULD ADDRESS.
AS TO THE CHALLENGES WE FACE IN
DEVELOPING A DATA SYSTEM MY
RESEARCH SUGGESTS THAT THERE
LARGELY POLITICAL AND CULTURAL.
THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA IS
COMING RATHER LATE TO THE PARTY
IN TERMS OF DEVELOPING A
STATEWIDE DATA SYSTEM IS
ACTUALLY HELPFUL IN REGARD TO
TECHNICAL CHALLENGES.
MOST OTHER STATES HAVE OR ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING SUCH
DATA SYSTEMS WHICH GIVES US
PLENTY OF EXAMPLES TO LEARN FROM
AS PAM BROWN MENTIONED EARLIER.
THE STATES HAVE ALREADY FACED
ISSUES LIKE MATCHING RECORDS
WHEN K. TWELVE AND POST
SECONDARY HAVE DIFFERENT STUDENT
ID'S OR FIGURING OUT MECHANISMS
TO MAINTAIN DATAPRIVACY AND
SECURITY THERE ARE PLENTY OF
REPORTS TO READ AND EXPERTS TO
CONSULT TO UNDERSTAND AND APPLY
THE LESSONS FROM THOSE STATES.
TO OUR OWN CONTEXT.
THE BIGGER CHALLENGES ARE IN
DECIDING WHAT BASIC TYPE OF DATA
SYSTEM TO DEVELOP AND
IDENTIFYING APPROPRIATE
LEADERSHIP FOR THE EFFORT.
SO DO WE URSUE A TRADITIONAL
STATEWIDE LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEM THAT INVOLVES CONNECTING
THE RECORDS ACROSS THESE FOR
SYSTEMS THAT W ALREADY HAVE.
THIS IS THE APPROACH USED IN
OTHER STATES AND IT HAS THE
ADVANTAGES OF LEVERAGING
CALIFORNIA'S CONSIDERABLE
EXISTING INVESTMENTS.
AND REQUIRING A FAIRLY SHORT
TIME LINE TO DEVELOP AT A MORE
REASONABLE COST.
SOME ARGUE THAT INSTEAD
CALIFORNIA SHOULD TRY TO DEVELOP
A DATA SYSTEMTHAT INVOLVES MORE
FREQUENT UP LOADS OF INFORMATION.
THAT WOULD COME FROM INDIVIDUAL
SCHOOL BUT ONE THAT COULD BE
USED TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
INDIVIDUAL STUDENTS AS THEY
TRANSITION ACROSS INSTITUTIONS I
BELIEVE CHRISTIAN REFER TO THAT
AS MAKING SURE WE'RE SERVING
LOCAL PRINTER OF LOCAL
PRACTITIONER LANDS.
IN A DATA SYSTEM.
SO WHILE THERE ARE PROMISING
LOCAL AND REGIONAL EXAMPLES OF
SUCH SYSTEMS THERE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS IN CONSIDERING THEM AS
THE MODEL. FOR THE INITIAL
DEVELOPMENT OF A STATEWIDE
SYSTEM IN TERMS OF LARGER
TECHNICAL BARRIERS GREATER COSTS
IN AN EXTENSIVE TIME FRAME
BEFORE COMPREHENSIVE STATEWIDE
DATA MIGHT BE AVAILABLE.
SO IF CALIFORNIA DECIDED TO
PURSUE AT LEAST AS AN INITIAL
APPROACH A MORE TRADITIONAL
STATEWIDE DATA SYSTEM.
THE PRIMARY CHALLENGE WOULD SEEM
TO INVOLVE DECIDING ON A
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE.
OTHER STATES USE A VARIETY OF
APPROACHES MY RESEARCH ENDED UP
CONCLUDING THAT CALIFORNIA MIGHT
BEST BE SERVED BY ESTABLISHING A
STATE DATA AGENCY OR A DATA
OFFICE WITHIN SOME EXISTING
STATE AGENCY.
THAT HAVE THE SPECIFIC MISSION
OF DEVELOPING A CENTRALIZED DATA
WAREHOUSE PRODUCING STANDARD
REPORTS AND DATA TOOLS FOR
VARIOUS AUDIENCES AND MANAGING
ACCESS TO THE DATA.
AND PRIVACY AND SECURITY
CONCERNS OF COURSE THIS
STRUCTURE WOULD ENSURE THAT
THERE'S AN ENTITY RESPONSIBLE
FOR GETTING THIS DONE.
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
SEGMENTS AND OTHER PARTICIPATING
AGENCIES OF COURSE BUT IN
NEUTRAL ENTITY WITH CLEAR
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT'S NOT TIED
TO A SPECIFIC SEGMENT.
THE STRUCTURE WOULD ALSO SUPPORT
EXPANDING THE DATA SYSTEM TO
INCLUDE DATA FROM PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY HEALTH SOCIAL
SERVICES.
EARLY LEARNING OR OTHER AGENCIES
OUTSIDE THE PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEMS AS YOU HEARD EXPRESSED A
LOT OF INTEREST IN DOING.
SO FOR DECADES CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN SITTING ON A LOT OF
EDUCATION DATA WITH NO PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE INFORMATION ON THE
OUTCOMES OF ITS INVESTMENT
ACROSS PUBLIC EDUCATION.
THE STATE'S WELL POSITION NOW TO
JOIN MANY OTHER STATES IN USING
DATA WE ALREADY COLLECT. TO
CREATE A COMPREHENSIVE STATEWIDE
SYSTEM THAT CN INFORM STUDENT
DECISION MAKING SUPPORT SCHOOLS
AND COLLEGES IN THEIR EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE STUDENT OUTCOMES.
AND MEET THE GOVERNOR'S VISION
OF USING DATA TO IMPROVE AND A
LINE STATE EDUCATION AND
WORKFORCE POLICIES I THINK WE
SHOULD SEIZE THAT OPPORTUNITY
I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE YOU WITH
SOME EXAMPLES OF HOW SOME OTHER
STATES.
HAVE USED THEIR DATA SYSTEMS GO
WE NEED TO GO WE NEED IS A
CENTRAL [inaudible]
OFFICE. TO TO MANAGE THIS THE
THIS OPERATION EVEN WHETHER OR
NOT THIS THE DATA COLLECTION IS
CENTRALIZED OR WHETHER IT'S
FEDERATED I I THINK YOU DO YES
YOU NEED A GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE
WHETHER YOU DECIDE ON A
CENTRALIZED DATA.
WAREHOUSE US RIGHT NOW SYSTEM OR
A FEDERATED SYSTEM I THINK YOU
WOULD STILL NEED A CENTRALIZED
GOVERNANCE MECHANISMS TO
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO DO THE
COLLECTION WHETHER IT'S THE
INITIAL COLLECTION OF THE
COLLATION AND THEN SOMEBODY
NEEDS TO MANAGE THE OUTPUT.
YES.
AS TO WHAT THE PRODUCT IS THAT
YOU'RE DELIVERING AND WHO YOU'RE
DELIVERING IT YES I COUNTY AS OF
THE TIME I DID THERE THE
RESEARCH --
THAT I READ UP IN THE REPORTS.
OF THE STATES THAT HAD.
CROSS SECTOR DATA SYSTEMS.
MORE THAN TWICE AS MANY CHOSE TO
GO WITH A CENTRALIZED DATA
WAREHOUSE RATHER THAN A
FEDERATED SYSTEM THE NUMBER OF
REASONS FOR THAT BUT THAT MOST
OF THEM HAD TO DO WITH GREATER
EFFICIENCY --
THEY ACTUALLY GET USED MORE
BECAUSE THE DATA ARE ALREADY
MATCHED AND ALREADY SITTING
TOGETHER IN A IN A WAREHOUSE
MAKING IT MUCH EASIER TO ACCESS
THEM -- YOU
HEARD -- THE
PEOPLE IN THE LAST PANEL TALK
YOU PROCESS AND YOU KNOW EVERY
TIME THEY WANT TO LIKE SHARE
DATA FOR A PARTICULAR PURPOSE IS
THIS LONG DRAWN OUT PROCESS OF
GETTING APPROVAL AND AND USE AND
THAT KIND OF THING SO IF YOU
HAVE A CENTRALIZED DATA
WAREHOUSE.
I MEAN OBVIOUSLY YOU NEED TO
HAVE A STRUCTURE AS PART OF YOUR
GOVERNANCE WHERE.
THERE IS DECISIONS THAT ARE MADE.
ON HOW TO USE THE DATA EACH TIME
YOU'RE GOING TO USE IT --
BUT IT'S ACTUALLY ALREADY THERE
TOGETHER --
SAID THAT OTHER STATES MORE
OTHER STATES THAN NOT HAVE
DECIDED TO GO WITH THAT.
WELL MY LIMITED I. T. EXPERIENCE
IN CALIFORNIA TELLS ME WHEN
YOU'RE ATTEMPTING.
TO CONNECT DISSIMILAR SYSTEMS
THEY'RE ALWAYS CONNECTIVITY
ISSUES AND THAT USUALLY IS VERY
VERY EXPENSIVE TO SOLVE IF YOU
EVER SOLVE IT.
BUT WHAT ABOUT A BIGGER ISSUE
WITH A FEDERATED SYSTEM AND IT
WAS WITH.
BUT OF COURSE ONE OF THE
PANELISTS IN THE WAS --
DOCTOR BROWN.
SPOKE ABOUT YOU KNOW THERE'S
CERTAIN DATA POINTS CERTAIN
LEVEL OF INFORMATION THAT
EVERYBODY WOULD BE INTERESTED IN
HAVING AND THEN THERE'S PROBABLY
OF SIGNIFICANTLY LARGER.
DATA SET THAT WOULD BE UNIQUE TO
THE UC OR THE C. ISSUE WITH A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SO IT'S A
CENTRALIZED STUFF.
THERE WE NEED TO GET INTO A POT
SOMEWHERE.
EITHER FED THERE OR COLLECTED
THERE INITIALLY RIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
YES YES I MEAN I I CERTAINLY
AGREE WITH HER THAT THERE ARE
THAT YOU KNOW THE EACH SYSTEM
OFFICE.
COLLECTS.
A SUBSET OF WHAT THE ACTUAL
INSTITUTION TAP INSTITUTIONS
HAVE MORE DATA THAN THEY SEND UP
TO THEIR SYSTEM OFFICES I THINK
SIMILARLY.
THE SYSTEM OFFICES WOULD
PROBABLY HAVE SOME PIECES OF
INFORMATION IT WOULDN'T GET SENT
UP TO ANY CENTRALIZED DATA
WAREHOUSE JUST BECAUSE THEY
WEREN'T NECESSARILY NEEDED.
ROUTINELY TO ADDRESS QUESTIONS
AND THAT SO YOU COULD HAVE SORT
OF UP A MIX OF THINGS A LOT AND
SOME STATES HAVE THAT WHERE THEY
HAVE A CENTRALIZED.
DATA WAREHOUSE FOR A SUBSET OF
OF PIECES OF INFORMATION AND
THEN IF YOU WANT SOME OTHER
INFORMATION THEN YOU GO OUT AND
YOU ASK THE SYSTEMS TO PROVIDE
THAT OR THEY HAVE A CENTRALIZED
DATA WAREHOUSE FOR EDUCATION
DATA.
BUT THEY HAVE A FEDERATED SYSTEM
WITH SAY SOCIAL SERVICES OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE WORK ONLY IFTHEY NEED IT DO THEY GO OUT AND
DO A MATCH AND GET RECORDS FOR
THE PURPOSE THEY NEED.
I THOUGHT THE COST THE COST --
INFORMATION DETAILS IN YOUR
COURSES LOW.
I WOULD HAVE EXPECTED IT TO BE
MUCH HIGHER WELL THERE IS THAT I
DID NOT DO AN IN DEPTH COST
ANALYSIS SO I WOULD CAUTION YOU
AGAINST THAT WHAT I DID DO IS IN
ALL OF MY INTERVIEWS I ASKED
PEOPLE ABOUT NATIONAL EXPERTS
PEOPLE IN OTHER STATES TO GIVE.
ME ESTIMATES ON LIKE WHAT WOULD
IT COST TO DO THIS PEOPLE JUST
KIND OF ROUTINELY FORMED AROUND
DAY I THINK IT WOULD COST
CALIFORNIA TWO OR THREE MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR. TO HAVE A SYSTEM
AGAIN.
YOU KNOW AND I AND I DID A BACK
OF THE ENVELOPE LIKE WHEN DID
SEE PAC COST NOT THAT THEY DID
EXACTLY THE SAME THING AS THIS
BUT YOU KNOW WHEN IT.
COMES IN IF YOU INFLATE THEIR
COSTS TO NOW SOMEWHERE IN THE
TWO TO THREE MILLION DOLLAR
RANGE.
BUT AGAIN THAT WOULD DEPEND ON
HOW MUCH YOU WANTED TO RESOURCE
IT.
pTHAT'S NOT LIKE THE INITIAL
COSTS TO PAY YOU KNOW ALL THE
SYSTEMS TO LIKE BE INVOLVED IN
FIGURING OUT WHAT ARE WE
ACTUALLY GOING TO DO HERE AND
WHAT PIECES OF DATA ARE GOING TO
GO IN IT AND HOW DO WE DEVELOP
OUR PRIVACY.
AND SECURITY PROTOCOLS AND ALL
OF THAT KIND OF STUFF THAT'S AN
INITIAL COST BUT IT'S AN
IMPORTANT VERY VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE I MEAN I DON'T KNOW HOW WE
MEASURE.
AND EVALUATE WHAT WE DO.
ACROSS THE BOARD AND AT THE END
WE DON'T HAVE DATA TO PERMIT THE
ANALYSIS TO HELP SO.
RIGHT VERY INTERESTING
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MA'AM.
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON --
AGAIN MY NAME IS VALERIE LINDSAY
WAGNER AND I'M HERE WITH --
CALIFORNIA COMPETES I'M A SENIOR
ANALYST THERE --
APPRECIATE BEING INVITED --
TO BY THE COMMITTEE --
AND YOUR STAFF --
AND I APPRECIATE THAT FINANCE
AND SENDING --
CALIFORNIA COMPETES WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND TEN
RECOGNIZING THAT HIGHER
EDUCATION CAN BE BOTH AN
ANTIDOTE AND A VACCINE. TO
INCOME INEQUALITY WE ARE AN
INDEPENDENT NONPARTISAN
NONPROFIT.
ODJICK THAT FOCUSES ON MAKING
THE ECONOMIC IN EQUITY DRIVEN
CASE FOR INCREASING DEGREE
ATTAINMENT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
TO SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS WITH A
POST SECONDARY DEGREE OR
CERTIFICATE OUR STATE NEEDS A
STRONGER GRASP OF NOT ONLY WHAT
STUDENTS EXPERIENCES ARE IN
HIGHER ED.
BUT THEIR EXPERIENCES WITH EARLY
A. K. TWELVE AND THE WORK FORCE
WE'RE EXCITED FOR CALIFORNIA TO
CATCH UP WITH THE PROGRESS THAT
MANY OTHER STATES HAVE MADE BY
MORE SYSTEMATICALLY INTEGRATING.
DATA TO BETTER SERVE
POLICYMAKERS THE PUBLIC AND
STUDENTS BOTH YOUTH AND ADULTS.
I'LL START BY SHARING A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WHAT I THINK IN
EDUCATION WORK AND WORK FORCE OR
P. WORKFORCE THE TO SYSTEM
SHOULD DO IN CALIFORNIA AND WHY
ONE IS NEEDED.
HOPEFULLY ADDRESS SOME OF YOUR
EARLIER QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT WE
COULD GET IF WE HAD THE SYSTEM --
AND THEN I'LL CLOSE WITH
DESCRIBING SOME.
OF WHAT I THINK WE BELIEVE OUR
NEAR TERM IMPLEMENTATION STEPS
THAT CAN SET THE STATE ON A PATH
FOR EFFECTIVENESS COST SAVINGS
AND ULTIMATELY INDIVIDUAL AND
SHARED PROSPERITY.
SO A P. WORKFORCE DATA SYSTEM I
THINK CONCEPTUALLY SHOULD DO
FOUR THINGS ONE DRIVE IN SUPPORT
STATE LEVEL EDUCATION AND
ECONOMIC GOALS. TO CONNECT
EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE DATA AT
THE INDIVIDUAL LEVEL.
IRV AS THE PRIMARY REPOSITORY
FOR UP TO DATE AND HISTORICAL
EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE DATA.
AND OVERCOME HISTORICAL
INDEPENDENCE CHALLENGES THAT
LIMIT THE STATE'S ABILITY TO USE
EXISTING DATA.
THERE ARE FEW WIDELY AGREED UPON
CONSIDERATIONS THAT EMPATH.
EMPHASIZE WHY THE STATE'S
CURRENT DATA COLLECTION AND
REPORTING NOTHING METHODS ARE
INADEQUATE --
I APPRECIATE WHAT ALL MY
COLLEAGUES OF SAY IN IN GENERAL
SORT OF WE SUPPORT THEM I THINK
WE HAVE A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
TAKE ON THEM.
SO I THINK FIRST THE LACK OF
COORDINATION LANDSCAPE IS KEY
AND THAT REALLY CAME UP I THINK
IN THIS LAST --
PANEL.
AS COLIN NOTED AS DETAILED IN
YOUR AGENDA FOR THIS HEARING WE
SAW CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC ENTITIES
MAINTAIN THEIR OWN DATA SYSTEMS
PRIVATE SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES
AS THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION --
AS DOES THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT RATE.
THE WHILE EACH INDEPENDENT EACH
ENTITY INDEPENDENTLY HOLDS RICH
DATA I THINK IT'S CALLING
SUGGESTED --
IN HER SORT OF OPENING RIGHT
THERE ARE SOME GOOD THINGS
HAPPENING THIS SEGMENTED
APPROACH LIMITS UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW THE EDUCATION AND WORK FOR
SYSTEMS COMPLEMENT EACH OHER.
AND REALLY WHAT THAT DOES IS IT
REDUCES POLICY MAKERS ABILITY TO
MAKE FACT BASED DECISIONS.
AND PREVENT STUDENTS FROM BEING
INFORMED CONSUMERS.
SECOND THE CAPACITY IN COSTS
REQUIRED TO CONNECT THE SILO
DATA ARE WHAT I WOULD CALL HER
TO LEAN.
I'M COLLEEN TALKED ABOUT THE
NATIONAL STUDENT CLEARINGHOUSE
AND THAT'S CERTAINLY AN
IMPORTANT PLACE WHERE LOTS THEY
GET A LOT OF BUSINESS FROM
CALIFORNIA.
THE STATE SPENDS TENS OF
MILLIONS EACH YEAR TO DIRECTLY
AND INDIRECTLY SUPPORT MARY A
DATA SYSTEMS AND I'M GONNA ALSO
THROWING PORTALS AND DASHBOARDS --
ONLY SOME OF WHICH ARE EVEN
PRESENTED IN THAT AGENDA TODAY
[inaudible]
THERE'S MORE.
MY THIRD POINT CENTERS ON EQUITY.
SO THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA HAS.
YOU KNOW VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
AND SOME EVEN MORE SO LIKE THAN
WHAT I THINK PEOPLE GENERALLY
START WITH.
IS LIKE A FACT THE STATE NEEDS
DATA ON WHERE STUDENTS AND
WORKERS ARE STRUGGLING AND WHICH
INVESTMENTS CAN ALLEVIATE THE
STRUGGLES AND MAXIMIZE SUCCESS.
THE ABSENCE OF AN INDEPENDENT
DATA SYSTEM PREVENTS
COMPREHENSIVE UNDERSTANDING OF
OPPORTUNITY.
PROGRESS MONITORING AND INFORMED
DECISION MAKING.
IN FACT THE STATE'S MAJOR
INVESTMENTS AND CROSS SECTOR AND
CROSS ARMS.
SECTOR IN SEGMENT COLLABORATION
OF SUCH A SYSTEM IN A PREVIOUS
ROLE A LEAD SOME RESEARCH --
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S
CAREER PATH FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS AND THEN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CANCERS OFFICE STRONG
WORK FORCE PROGRAM.
EACH REGION.
CONSIDER DEVELOPING THEIR OWN
NEW REGIONAL DATA SYSTEM AND ALL
HAD THE SAME STRUGGLES SUCH AS
WHICH DATA SYSTEMS ARE THE BEST.
FOR UNDERSTANDING REGIONAL
PATHWAYS WHO HAD ACCESS TO THOSE
DATA AND OF THOSE WITH ACCESS.
WHO ALSO HAD THE CAPACITY IN THE
INTERPRETERS DATA?
THEIR PROGRESS VERY BASED ON
LARGELY ON RESOURCES AND THAT
ALONE I BELIEVE SHOULD NOT
DETERMINE HOW I'M LEADERS ARE
INDIVIDUALS ARE ABLE TO USE
INFORMATION.
A P. WORKFORCE DATA SYSTEM COULD
HELP DEMOCRATIZE HOW DID ARE
ACCESSED AND USED BY VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING STUDENTS.
THE GIVEN THIS INFORMATION WHERE
DOES THE STATE GO FROM HERE.
FIRST AND FOREMOST THE STATE
MUST DECIDE ON SOME FUNDAMENTALS
THAT I THINK.
MY COLLEAGUES.
MOST OF THE SECOND ISSUE TODAY
THAT WE'VE COVERED --
HAVE MENTIONED SO WHAT WILL THE
SYSTEM BE USED.
FOR WHAT WILL THIS HOW WILL THE
STATE LOOK DIFFERENT AFTER WE
HAVE THE SYSTEM.
WHICH SECTORS WILL BE INVOLVED.
WHO WOULD BE THE CONSUMERS OF
THESE DATA?
THE NEXT STEP IS TO RESEARCH
DATA POLICIES AND PRACTICES
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ASSESS HOW POLICY
HAS BEEN USED TO FRAME PLAN.
AND IMPLEMENT P. WORKFORCE DATA
SYSTEMS ACROSS THE NATION.
I PROVIDED YOU WITH THE HAND OUT
ATTACHMENT A THAT YOU COULD LOOK
AT T COMPARES IT REALLY JUST
SUMMARIZES VERY BRIEFLY --
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN MARYLAND
KENTUCKY --
IN WASHINGTON STATE.
UNDERSTANDING THE WORK OF OTHER
STATE AND IMPORTANTLY HOW THAT
WORK CAN BE APPLIED TO OUR
POLICY CONTEXT IS CRITICAL THE
TYPE OF POLICY LETTERS I THINK
WE SORT OF HIGHLIGHT --
ON THAT DOCUMENT.
AND THIS BRINGS US REALLY TO MY
NEXT RECOMMENDATION THE STATE
SHOULD PLAN TO DEVELOP THE
CENTRAL DEPOSITORY REPOSITORY
FOR DATA.
THE VARIOUS SYSTEMS PORTALS AND
DASHBOARDS AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS
WORKERS RESEARCHERS AND LEADERS
IS A LITTLE BIT MIND BOGGLING.
A CENTRALIZED REPOSITORY WOULD
BE MORE WOULD MORE EQUITABLY
PROVIDE STAKEHOLDERS WITH ACCESS
TO CONSISTENT AND COMPREHENSIVE
INFORMATION.
IT WOULD ALSO HELP LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD SIX AND REALITIES
OF WHAT WE CALL ZIP CODE DESTINY.
FINALLY THE QUESTION OF WHERE
THIS -- P.
WORK FIRST DATA SYSTEM SHOULD BE
HOUSE IS CLOSELY LINKED TO THIS
ISSUE OF COORDINATION. TO GAIN
TRUST IN BY IN OF ALL
PARTICIPANTS THE STATE MUST
STORE THE DATA IN A WAY THAT IS
POLITICALLY NEUTRAL SECURE AND
ENSURE THE BALANCE OF POWER IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE STATE'S GOALS.
WE ARE GLAD THAT THERE ARE OTHER
POLICY CONVERSATIONS UNDER WAY
TO ESTABLISH AN INDEPENDENT
AGENCY THAT COULD OVERSEE DATA
AS ITS MAIN CHARGE.
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS I THINK
THAT YOU SORT OF ASKED WHAT WHAT
WHAT DO WE GET OUT OF THIS THOSE.
QUESTIONS WE COULD PROBABLY
ANSWER ARE HOW MANY HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES ENROLLED IN COLLEGE
THE NEXT FALL.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT RIGHT NOW.
HOW MANY OF THE STUDENTS GOING
TO COMPLETE COLLEGE?
WE ARE NOT THAT RIGHT NOW.
HOW DO JOB PLACEMENT RATES AND
WAGES LOOK ACROSS INSTITUTIONS
IN MAJORS?
WATER WORKFORCE OUTCOMES FOR
STUDENTS DEPENDING ON THEIR TIME
TO DEGREE.
THOSE ARE JUST A FEW EXAMPLES
BUT REALLY IN CLOSING I'D LIKE
TO SUGGEST WHAT.
WE BELIEVE ARE CRITICAL SERVE
NEAR TERM IMPLEMENTATION STEPS
THE FIRST THE STATE COULD MAP
OUT EXISTING DATA INFRASTRUCTURE
IDENTIFYING WHICH SYSTEMS ARE IN
USE WHERE THERE ARE GAPS IN WITH
SCALING UP STATEWIDE MEANS.
MAPPING CAN CLARIFY AND HELP
ENSURE THAT THE DATA SYSTEM
GOALS ARE MET.
THE STATE SHOULD IDENTIFY THE
DEED IN METRICS NEED TO MEET
SYSTEM GOALS.
WE SHOULD ALSO DETERMINE WHO
WILL COMPRISE THE COMMITTEE
CHARGED WITH PLANNING AND
LAUNCHING THE DATA SYSTEM.
SEVERAL ENTITIES.
WANT TO AND PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE
A VOICE IT INDEPENDENCE IS KEY
TO ENSURING A SENT A STUDENT
CENTERED APPROACH.
FINALLY THE STATE SHOULD
CONSIDER MORE THAN ONE PROTOTYPE
OF THE P. WORK FOR SYSTEM.
THESE PROTOTYPE SHOULD ADDRESS
HOW DATA WOULD FLOW FROM THE
LOCAL AND STATE LEVEL AND BACK.
EVERYBODY GET SOMETHING AND
IDENTIFY INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED
TO CONNECT TO OTHER STATE AGENCY
DATA.
OF COURSE IT SHOULD ALSO
DELINEATE COSTS --
ON BECAUSE I THINK ONE THING
THAT I THINK IS IMPORTANT.
IS REALLY ABOUT UNDERSTANDING
THE BIG PICTURE AND WHAT WE WANT.
RIGHT IF I WANNA GO GET A CAR.
I COULD GET IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN HONDA CIVIC OR I COULD GET
A TESLA RATE SO DECIDING COST A
FRIEND I THINK SOMETIMES CAN BE
A LITTLE BIT PREMATURE FOR NOT
REALLY CLEAR ON WHAT IT IS WE
THINK WE WANT.
FUNDAMENTALLY IT'S AN EXCITING
TIME. TO CONSIDER THE POTENTIAL
OF A P. WORK FIRST DATA SYSTEM
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE EAGER
TO SUPPORT YOUR EFFORTS TO
DEVELOP SUCH A SYSTEM IN OFFER
EXPERTISE AS YOU REFINE A
STRATEGY THAT MORE EQUITABLY
EXPANDS OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS.
AS WELL AS FAR STATES BROADER
ECONOMY.
EXCELLENT DOCTOR THANK YOU I'VE
REALLY APPRECIATED AND BUT IN
BOTH CASES OF THE THE RESPONSE
TO WHAT WE GET OUT OF THIS THAT
WAS VERY INFORMATIVE. FOR ME
FINANCE ANY QUESTIONS
PARTICULARLY.
AGAIN NO QUESTIONS --
BUT JUST A STATEMENT --
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION COULD
DOES CONTINUE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
IN ORDER FOR THIS DATA SYSTEM TO
REALLY REACH ITS FULL POTENTIAL
I'M IS DEVELOPMENT IS GOING TO
HAVE TO INVOLVE A REAL
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT AND FROM
THE VERY STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
ROOM AS WELL AS THE RESEARCHERS
SOME OF FROM WE'VE.
HEARD FROM TODAY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ENGAGING IN THAT
CONVERSATION EXCELLENT THANK YOU
BOTH VERY MUCH.
PUBLIC COMMENT TO ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE
[inaudible]
WHILE OKAY.
LOC.
AND PRETTY.
THERE ARE OFTEN RESERVATIONS
YOUR FIRST HEARING HI BRIAN HOW
WITH CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS I GUESS.
ASK ME IN A FEW WEEKS --
WITH THAT THE GOVERNOR FOR A
VERY POSITIVE K. TWELVE BUDGET
AND IS SUPPORT FOR PUBLIC
EDUCATION.
I WE SUPPORTED APPRECIATE OF THE
THREE BILLION DOLLARS CAL STARS
CONTRIBUTION --
SUPPORTED APPRECIATE THE THREE
POINT FOUR SIX COLA --
SUPPORT THE FIERY SEVENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
BUT AFTER THE SEARCH ABOUT THE
DISTRIBUTION MODEL --
AND LASTLY WHERE STILL ANALYZING
THE EARLY HOW TO PROPOSALS BUT
THAT SUPPORT EXPANSION OF ACCESS
AND IN TERMS OF COMMITTEE
COLLEGES --
WE ARE LOOKING FOR INCREASED
FUNDING TO THE CALIFORNIA PART
TIME FACULTY OFFICE PROGRAMS AS
WELL AS THE FULL TIME.
PROGRAM THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU NEXT THIS SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE EDUCATION TRUST WEST.
I WANTED TO EXPRESS SUPPORT AND
GRATITUDE TO THE GOVERNOR FOR
INCLUDING IN THE PROPOSAL FOR
THE INTEGRATED LONGITUDINAL
STUDENT DATA SYSTEM.
MANY OF US HAVE BEEN HOPING FOR
THIS FOR A LONG TIME.
AND I WANT TO REITERATE THAT --
TO US THIS IS ABOUT
FUNDAMENTALLYSEEN THE TRUTH AND
SEEN HOW OUR EDUCATION SYSTEMS
AND POLICIES IMPACTS STUDENTS.
AS THEY GO FROM GRADE TO GRADE
BUT ALSO AS THE TRANSITION FOR
AT KEY POINTS LIKE GOING FROM
HIGH SCHOOL TO COLLEGE.
SO WE THINK THIS IS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPACTFUL AND MADE AN
IMPORTANT THINGS YOU CAN DO THIS
YEAR IS APPROVED THIS PROPOSAL
WHEN IT COMES TO LOOKING AT THE
CONDITIONS OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS.
AND STUDENTS OF COLOR AND I WANT
TO EXPRESS APPRECIATION FOR THE
COMMENTS ABOUT STAKEHOLDER INPUT
THAT WOULD BE GREATLY
APPRECIATED AND WE THINK YOU'LL.
END UP BUILDING A BETTER SYSTEM
WITH LOTS OF INPUTTING CONSENSUS
ON THE IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES
THAT YOU DISCUSSED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS FOR
COMING SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS WESLEY
SAVER AND I'M HERE REPRESENTING
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH.
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL SPONSORED BY
SENATORS PORTANTINO AND ROTH
INVEST TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS
AMONG COLLEGE STUDENTS.
WE'VE ALREADY HEARD FROM SOME
STUDENTS AND STAFF ON THE ISSUE
BUT I WON UNDERSCORES IMPORTANCE
IN TODAY'S ECONOMY WE KNOW TO
THE POST SECONDARY CREDENTIALS
ESSENTIAL IN A HUGE DISPARITIES
REMAIN IN WHO HAS ACCESS TO A
COLLEGE DEGREE.
CONTRIBUTING TO THE SEVERITY
CALIFORNIA IS IN THE MIDST OF A
MOUNTAIN CRISIS OF HOMELESSNESS
MIKE COLLEGE STUDENTS.
AS NOTED BY ONE OF THE EARLIER
PANELS CLOSE 220% OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS.
AND THE SAME IS TRUE 411% OF CSU
STUDENT.
HOMELESSNESS SERIOUSLY IMPACT
THE STUDENT'S ABILITY TO REMAIN
IN SCHOOL BE SUCCESSFUL DESPITE
THIS CALIFORNIA LACKS ANY
TARGETED INTERVENTION TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE.
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
RECEIVING FUNDING FOR THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD BE CRIED.
TO ONE PARTNER WITH LOCAL
HOMELESS SERVICE AGENCIES TO IT
FOCUS RAPID RE HOUSING PROGRAM.
TO FACILITATE STUDENT ACCESS TO
LOCAL HOUSING RESOURCES AND
THREE ENSURE THAT HOMELESS
STUDENTS ARE RECEIVING ALL
AVAILABLE FINANCIAL AID.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE I
STRONGLY URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT THIS REQUEST.
THANK YOU FOR COMING DOWN TODAY
YES MA'AM.
HI MY NAME IS KEY STERN I'M FROM
THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
I JUST WANTED --
TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR SB
FIVE SIXTY AS WELL I A SAY THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BECAUSE I WE HAVE
BEEN HOMELESS AND FOSTER AND IN
FOSTER CARE IN MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT COUNTY THROUGHOUT THE
REGION OVER THERE SO.
I JUST WANTED TO EXPLAIN --
HOW IMPORTANT THIS WOULD MEAN TO
ME IT'S BEEN A HUGE DISTRACTION
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT HOUSING --
AND SUPPORT WHEN IT COMES TO
GETTING THROUGH SCHOOL SO.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I CAME
AND EXPLAIN MYSELF.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR DOING SO
[inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
BUT AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR STAFF
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY MY NAME IS
PAMELA GUESTS AND I REPRESENT A
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF ISSUES THAT
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS TODAY AND IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME NOT JUST
PICK ON THE COUPLE OF THE ITEMS
THAT WE THINK ARE.
HIGHLY IMPORTANT AND OF INTEREST --
TO OUR OFFICE SPECIFICALLY ONE
OF THEM BEING THE FIFTY TWO
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS OF THE
GOVERNOR HAS PROVIDED FOR COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION FOR
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE.
ON WE ARE FIRST OF ALL VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ON A NUMBER OF FRONTS
INCLUDING EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION ON THE ACE FUNDING FOR
CHILDREN WITH ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES.
A LOT OF THE CHILDREN WE SERVE
ARE EITHER INCARCERATED OR
TENDING COUNTY COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
WE ALSO SERVE CHILDREN WHO ARE
FOSTER YOUTH AND HOMELESS YOUTH
AND THEY ARE OF A PRIORITY FOR
US --
REGARDING THE DIFFERENTIATED
ASSISTANCE FUNDING LAKE CO AS
YOU MAY KNOW HAS EIGHTY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WITH THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTY.
AND INCLUDING OUR OWN
EDUCATIONAL BUT FOR THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT WERE IDENTIFIED AS
NEEDING ASSISTANCE LAST YEAR
THERE WAS.
NINETEEN THIS YEAR THERE'S
THIRTY FIVE AND SO WE THINK THAT
THIS FUNDING IS CRITICAL FOR US
TO CONTINUE TO HELP SCHOOL
DISTRICTS MANY OF WHOM WHICH
WE'VE PARTNERED WITH HAVE GOTTEN
THEMSELVES OFF.
OF DIFFERENT JT ASSISTANCE LAST
YEAR BUT AGAIN WE HAVE MORE ON
THIS YEAR --
IN ADDITION I WANTED --
TO RAISE THE ISSUE OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION WE DO
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
APPROACH THERE IN LA COUNTY WE
ARE PROVIDING SERVICES TO
THIRTEEN THOUSAND CHILDREN WE
HAVE THE LARGEST HEAD START
AGENCY IN THE STATE.
POSSIBLY THE NATION AND SO AGAIN
WE WANT TO WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH WITH THE GOVERNOR AND THE
ADMINISTRATION WE ALSO HAVE A
GREAT DEAL OF EDUCATIONAL --
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAMS INCLUDING
THE EDUCATIONAL PASSPORTS SYSTEM
WHICH ALLOWS US TO TRACK
STUDENTS WHO ARE IN AND OUT OF
OUR JUVENILE COURT SCHOOLS AND
THEN GOING BACK TO THEIR
TRADITIONAL SCHOOLS.
AND SO WE CAN TRACK THEM COMING
IN AND OUT AND THE EIGHTY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CAN OBTAIN RECORDS
FROM THOSE STUDENTS AND WE'VE
ALSO LINK THAT PROGRAM TO OUR
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
PROGRAM SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM THANKS FOR
COMING DOWN NEXT PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHERINE ARE
GONNA ON BEHALF OF THE EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION COALITION WE
ARE EXCITED BY THE BULL
PROPOSALS FOR EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION IN THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL.
THAT PRIORITIZE OUR STATE'S
YOUNGEST CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION TO FURTHER
SHAPE THESE PROPOSALS.
PARTICULARLY WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS THE STATE'S BIFURCATED
EAZY E. RATE SYSTEM THIS YEAR
THE CREATE A SINGLE REGION
WE ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER TO
COMPANION BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
INTRODUCED SB ONE SEVENTY FOUR
BEING CARRIED BY SENATOR LEYVA.
AND THE COMPANION LEGISLATION ON
THE ASSEMBLY SIDE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY AB ONE TWENTY
FIVE THAT ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
WE ARE ALSO GRATEFUL THAT THE
GOVERNOR PROVIDES A HOWEVER
THERE CONTINUES TO BE AN ACUTE
SHORTAGE OF CARE FOR STATE'S
INFANTS AND TODDLERS.
WE REQUEST THAT YOU CONSIDER AB
ONE NINE FOUR BEING CARRIED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAY AS THE INVEST
ONE BILLION OVER THREE YEARS TO
CREATE MORE CHILD CARE SPACES
FOR CHILDREN.
ZERO TO THREE AND PUTTING ON A
DIFFERENT HOT --
ON BEHALF OF FIRST I'VE
CALIFORNIA AND THIS IS FOR THE
SECOND ISSUE ON THE STATE Y. LAS
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM.
I WOULD LIKE TO STATE OR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR INCLUDING EARLY
EDUCATION AND THE LONGITUDINAL
DATA SYSTEM THAT STARTS WHEN A
CHILD ENTERS CHILD CARE AND
PRESCHOOL.
AS THIS COMMITTEE SOURCE THROUGH
WHAT THE LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEM SHOULD INCLUDE AND LOOK
LIKE.
WE WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THAT THEIR
RD BEST PRACTICES IN THE FIELD
THAT WE CAN LEARN FROM. FOR
INSTANCE THERE ARE TWO PROMISING
PILOT PROGRAMS OCCURRING IN
SANTA CLARA AND SAN DIEGO WITH
DATA SYSTEMS THAT LINK EARLY
EDUCATION DATA AND IN SOME CASES
SOCIAL SERVICES DATA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
KEEP IN MIND THAT WE WILL BE --
THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING
SO WILL BE BREAKING DOWN THIS
BUDGET WILL HAVE OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES.
TO HAVE MORE DETAILED
CONVERSATIONS ON THESE POINTS
I'M NOT TRYING TO CUT YOU OFF
[inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
IT'S A GREAT START I COULD HAVE
BEEN ERIN --
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND I'LL TRY
TO MAKE THIS QUICK LIKE YOU SAID
WILL BE BREAKING THIS DOWN
FURTHER.
OF FACT GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNMENT'S DECISION TO PAUSE
THE STUDENT ALLOCATION PORTION
OF THE STUDENT SUCCESS FUNDING
FORMULA AND LIMIT ITS GROWTH.
WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN OPPOSED TO
PERFORMANCE BASED FUNDING
ULTIMATELY IT CREATES SYSTEM OF
WINNERS AND LOSERS --
REGARDING THE PROMPT COLLEGE
PROMISE PROGRAM IN THE EXPANSION
OF IT.
WE GENERALLY SUPPORT STATE BY
DOWNS -- BUT
THIS SHOULD BE EXPANDED BEYOND
FULL TIME FIRST TIME STUDENTS
THE CHANCE OAKLEY SAID HIMSELF
THAT MOST OF OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE NOT FIRST
TIME FULL TIME.
AND THEN PRIORITY IS OF COURSE I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE FUNDING
FOR FULL TIME HIRING AS WELL AS
PART TIME OFFICER HOURS.
RIGHT NOW OF LIKE SHE SAID
PUTTING ON MY OTHER HAD --
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ASSOCIATION OF OCCUPATIONAL
EDUCATORS HAS SOME CONCERN ABOUT
THE STRONG WORK FORCE FINDINGS --
AND THE FACT THAT SOME OF IT'S
GOING TO COME FROM ONE TIME
SETTLE UP FUNDING COMPARED OF
THE STRONG WORK FORCE FUNDING --
BE IT CONTINUE ON THANK YOU NO
PROBLEM THANKS FOR COMING TO SEE
THIS OF SEE YOU NEXT.
THANK YOU CHAIR FOR HOLDEN THIS
HOLDING THIS HEARING --
MARK MCDONALD MCCALLUM GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES SAN
DIEGO KERN.
PERALTA IN SAN FRANCISCO
COMMUNITY KERR --
WE ARE APPRECIATIVE AND
GENERALLY SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET COAL --
GROWTH EXPANSION OF THE COLLEGE
PROMISE PROGRAM --
WE UNDERSTAND THE SOME OF THE
CONSTRAINTS UNDER PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT THIS YEAR AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THAT -- WE
SUPPORT THE FINANCIAL AID
EXPANSION AND THE BILL THAT --
STE --
CHANCELLOR OAKLEY MENTIONED --
BEING AUTHORED BY SENATOR LEYVA.
I JUST WANTED TO MENTION A
COUPLE THINGS NUMBER ONE THE
PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE FACILITIES
PROJECTS.
DOES GO THROUGH A STANDING A
STRENUOUS PROCESS THAT THE BOARD
OF GOVERNORS AND WE SAID WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE THIS COMMITTEE.
TO TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT SOME OF
THOSE FACILITY PROJECTS THAT
WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
THE OTHER THING AS AT THE FIRST
PROPERTY TAXES ARE DOWN FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
UNLIKE K. TWELVE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BACK FILL IS NOT
AUTOMATIC.
SO IF THIS CONTINUES AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WE WOULD LIKE THIS
COMMITTEE TO TAKE KEEP AN EYE ON
THAT LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SIR NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN --
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TODAY IS A
RICH DISCUSSIONS THERE ARE SEE
WITH THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY FIRST WE WANTED --
TO I WANTED TO KIND OF SPEAK ON
IN SUPPORT OF TWO CORE AREAS
THAT WERE DISCUSSED TODAY SO
FIRST WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED INVESTMENT IN THE
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM.
THAT TRACKS THE STUDENTS FROM
EARLY EDUCATION FOR THE WORK
FORCE WITHOUT SUCH A SYSTEM AS
YOU HEARD EARLIER.
WERE REALLY EIGHT UNABLE TO
ANSWER CRITICAL QUESTIONS TO
STUDENT PROGRESSION AND I'M
IDENTIFY HOW SYSTEMS ARE MEETING
OUR WORK FORCE NEEDS --
WHERE CALIFORNIA'S HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES APPLYING TO ENROLLING
IN COLLEGE ONCE THEY'RE THERE
HOW LONG DO THEY TAKE TO
COMPLETE AND HOW DO THEY USE
THEIR FINANCIAL AID --
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THE DISCUSSION ON THAT AND WOULD
ASK THAT YOU --
INSURE A SYSTEM THAT IS
CENTRALIZED INDEPENDENT AND THAT
DATA IS TRANSPARENT TRANSPARENT
ACCESSIBLE AND ACTIONABLE.
ADDITIONALLY WHILE WE APPRECIATE
THE INCREASE IN ENROLLMENT SEATS
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR OF AT
THE CSU WE WOULD URGE YOU TO
FURTHER STRENGTHEN.
THE FUNDING FOR TO SERVE MORE
STUDENTS AT THE CSU AND TO PAIR
THAT WITH ADDITIONAL ENROLLMENT
SLOTS AT THE UC IN ORDER TO MEET
THE GROWING STUDENT DEMAND --
AND OUR FUTURE WORKFORCE NEEDS
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT.
THE AFTERNOON ALEX GRAVES OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES REPRESENTING OVER
EIGHTY OF THE NONPROFIT
ACCREDITED INSTITUTIONS IN THE
STATE.
I JUST LIKE TO MAKE TWO BRIEF
POINTS FIRST ON THE CONVERSATION
A LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM --
WE ARE REALLY HAPPY TO SEE IN
MONEY -- TO
MOVE FORWARD ON THAT --
WE BELIEVE LUNCH TILL DATA
SYSTEM WILL BE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR HELPING
POLICYMAKERS --
CRAFTED POLICY FOR HELPING
INSTITUTIONS CRAP BETTER POLICY
THE BETTER SERVE STUDENTS AND
ALSO WILL PROVIDE.
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT PERMISSION
TO STUDENTS FAMILIES ADVOCATES
IN THE PUBLIC --
COLLECTVELY OUR SECTOR PRODUCES
ABOUT 20% BACHELOR'S DEGREES
OVER HALF OF THE MASTER'S
DEGREES IN OVER HALF OF THE
DOCTOR DEGREES.
AND SO IT'S CONVERSATIONS MOVE
FORWARD WE WON'T BE HERE TO SAY
THAT WE BELIEVE IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT ARE SECTORS INCLUDED
IN CONVERSATIONS AROUND A
LOGICAL DATA SYSTEM.
WE WANT TO BE PART OF THAT WE
WANT TO WORK WITH YOU ALL MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN INTEGRATE OUR
IN SECTOR INTO THAT SO THAT
FOLKS HAVE A FULL PICTURE --
OF OF ALL OUTCOMES ACROSS ALL
INSTITUTIONS.
AND I APOLOGIZE IF THIS WAS
MENTIONED DURING THE PANEL I WAS
OUT IN THE HALLWAY BUT WE HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN INVOLVED --
WITH OUR PUBLIC COUNTERPARTS
THROUGH A GRANT FROM THE BILL
MELINDA GATES FOUNDATION AND
HAVE BEEN WORKING THROUGH FOR
OVER A YEAR NOW --
MANY OF THE SAME QUESTIONS THAT
WERE OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS
AROUND HOW THIS WOULD LOOK AT
HOW WOULD FUNCTION.
SO WE VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD --
TO TO WORKING WITH YOU ALL.
VERY BRIEFLY ON THE OTHER POINT.
EARLIER THERE WAS MENTION OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AROND
SUPPLEMENTAL CAL GRANT DOLLARS
PER STUDENT PARENTS --
AS IT'S PROPOSED THAT WOULD ONLY
BE AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS PARENTS
ATTENDING PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS
AND WE FEEL THAT SHOULD THAT
PROPOSAL MOVE FORWARD WE'D LIKE
TO SEE LOW INCOME STUDENT
PARENTS ATTENDING OUR
INSTITUTIONS TREATED EQUITABLY.
SO THAT IF YOU'RE A STUDENT --
IN THAT SITUATION WE KNOW THAT
THE BARRIERS YOU FACED A
FINISHING YOUR DEGREE OR SIMILAR
REGARDLESS OF THE INSTITUTION
YOU GO TO JAIL AND SO WETHER
YOU GO TO UC RIVERSIDE OR
UNIVERSITY OF REDLANDS.
I WE WANNA MAKE SURE THOSE
STUDENTS ARE SUPPORTED EQUALLY
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT YES MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON SERRA LOIS TO
TEACH PLUS AND WE WORK WITH
EXCELLENT TEACHERS FROM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN HELPING TO SHAPE
THE SYSTEM THEY WORK AND AND SO
YOU HAVE A LETTER FROM OUR
TEACHERS BUT WE FIRST WANT TO
THANK YOU. FOR THIS HEARING FOR
THIS ROBUST HEARING FOR THAT FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S INVESTMENT ON
FULL DATA SYSTEM AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM ADDRESS WEST HAS SAID IT'S
IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME COMING ARE
REALLY EAGER. FOR THE
CONVERSATION BUT ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS WE NEED PART OF THAT
PROCESS AND AND OFFER OUR
ASSISTANCE IN IN MAKING SURE
THEY ARE --
I ALSO WANT TO THANK MS BECAUSE
EMMA'S FROM THE CALIFORNIA PART
OF EDUCATION FOR RAISING THE
ISSUE OF NOT HAVING THE CTC THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING DATA AS PART OF
THIS CONVERSATION WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WORKFORCE OUR TEACHER
WORKFORCE IS A PRETTY IMPORTANT
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE.
PARTICULARLY ARE LOOKING AT
SHORTAGE AREAS LIKE BILINGUAL
EDUCATION AND AND SPECIAL ED AND
SOME OF THE EFFORTS THAT WE'RE
MAKING TO TO TO FILL THOSE GAPS --
JUST I WON'T WELL I'LL BE BACK
TO TALK MORE ABOUT OUR LETTER
BUT JUST A AN OVER ARCHING THEME
FROM WHAT WE'RE HEARING FROM OUR
TEACHERS.
THE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THAT
THE POLICY FRAMEWORK THAT YOU
OFTEN BUILDING OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL REELS SEVERAL YEARS BUT
WHERE WE SEE GAPS IN INVESTING
IN MAKING SURE THAT THESE THINGS
ARE IMPLEMENTED LIKE.
THAT LIMITATION OF THE ENGLISH
LEARN A ROADMAP AND PROFESSIONAL
SUPPORTS FOR TEACHERS WHO ARE
WHO ARE LEADING OUR CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT EFFORTS SO YOU HAVE
TO WORK WITH YOU ON THAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
SHARE ROTH.
MY NAME IS SEASONAL KANSEN --
ASSOCIATE VICE PRESIDENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND A PROFESSOR OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AT CAL STATE SACRAMENTO.
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION SUPPORTS THE OVERALL
FUNDING LEVELS FOR THE CSU.
HOWEVER WE REQUEST THAT --
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS BE
SET ASIDE TO HIRE NEW TENURE
TRACK FACULTY IN THE CSU.
THIS MONEY WOULD RESULT IN A PRO
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED NEW
FACULTY.
THIS REQUEST WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
THE CSU TO PROVIDE AN ALLOCATION
PLAN BY OCTOBER OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WE HAVE PROVIDED
COMMITTEE STAFF WITH BUDGET
LANGUAGE FOR THIS REQUEST.
THE LACK OF ACCESS TO FULL TIME
TENURE TRACK PROFESSES HARMS THE
STUDENTS WHO RELY ON CSU FOR
QUALITY PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION.
TURNOVER AMONG LECTURE FACULTY
AS HIGH AS THE MOST.
NATURALLY SEARCH FOR LONG TERM
STABLE TEACHING POSITIONS.
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE
APPROPRIATED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO HIRE TENURE TRACK
FACULTY FOR APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED NEW FACTORIES.
SYSTEM WIDE.
THIS WAS A GREAT STEP FORWARD
BUT NOT ENOUGH.
THE REQUESTED THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS REFLECTS A
PROPORTIONAL INCREASE BASED ON
LAST YEAR'S.
A NEW ONGOING FUNDING SO WE HOPE
THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT THAT AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US COME
BACK AND SEE IS WHEN WE DO THE
SPECIFIC ITEMS.
YES SIR GOOD AFTERNOON MARIO
GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
WE DO HAVE THREE PROPOSALS TO OF
THE OF WHICH HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED
AND AND STUFF DOES HAVE THE
SPECIFICS ON THAT. ONE IS ON
TENURE TRACK ONE IS ON MENTAL
HEALTH AND ONE IS ON AND ROLL
MEANT -- I
DID WANT TO COVER THE ENROLLMENT
PIECE VERY BRIEFLY WE SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
SIXTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS. 42%
ENROLLMENT INCREASE HOWEVER
GROWTH BE MEASURED BY HEAD COUNT
INSTEAD OF FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
STUDENTS TO ENSURE THAT FUNDING
IS ACTUALLY SPENT ON ACCESS WHY
DO WE ASK THAT.
LAST YEAR CSU TURNED AWAY THIRTY
THOUSAND QUALIFIED STUDENTS THIS
FUNDING WOULD ENSURE --
MORE QUALIFIED STUDENTS GET A
SEAT AND THE CSU --
WITH THESE FUNDS THE CSU COULD
PAY FOR EITHER SEVEN THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED F. T. E. STUDENTS OR
EIGHT THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTY ONE STUDENTS BY HEAD
COUNT --
USING OF TEA --
CALCULATIONS ALONE WHICH ARE
BASED ON HOW MANY SEATS ARE
UNITS OR CLASSES STUDENTS TAKE
THE CS YOU CAN USE ENROLLMENT
FUNDS TO GET CURRENT STUDENTS TO
TAKE MORE CLASSES.
INSTEAD OF GIVING STUDENTS WHO
WOULD OTHERWISE BE TURNED AWAY A
SEAT IN THE CSU.
THE CSU IS DOING THIS.
THIS YEAR WITH TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET FUNDING.
WE BELIEVE THAT AND WOMAN GROWTH
FUNDING SHOULD GIVE.
ACCESS TO NEW STUDENTS AND THAT
THERE ARE OTHER FUNDS THAT CAN
BE USED TO PAY FOR CURRENT
STUDENTS TAKING MORE CLASSES --
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE TO GRADUATE AT
GRADUATION STUDENT --
INITIATIVE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US JUST MA'AM.
EMILY ROSENBERGER WAS SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION I
THAT'S WHEN I HIGHLY IS FUTURE
HEARINGS REYES CFA THE TO PURSUE
HEAD COUNT --
I SEE TENURE TRACK OF FUNDING
AND WE ALSO WANT TO SEE AN
EQUITY ON THE CSU SIDE FOR
MENTAL HEALTH WE THOUGHT FOR THE
UC BUT WE DIDN'T SEE IT FOR THE
CSU AND THEY ACTUALLY ARE UNDER
THE RATIO THAT ARE RECOMMENDED.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY WE'RE
HEARING A LOT FROM STUDENTS WE
DON'T THINK THEY SHOULD BEAR THE
COST OF THE RISING --
EXPENSES THAT CS YOU BUT WE ALSO
THINK IT'S UNFAIR FOR OUR
WORKERS TO TAKE THAT COST ON THE
SUPPORT STAFF AT THE CSU HAVE
LOST OR STEPS IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX HAVE NOT RECEIVED THEM AND
WE'RE ASKING FOR A HUNDRED
MILLION. TO MAKE THEM WHOLE AND
BRING THEM UP ON IN VERSION
ISSUE THANK YOU WE'LL LOOK INTO
THE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE I DON'T
KNOW IF THEY REQUESTED IN THE B.
C. PIER NOT BUT WILL CHECK ON
THAT.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON WELL AS THAT
OF THIS MY VALLEY KINCAID WITH
PUBLIC ADVOCATE.
AND WE APPLAUD THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
SPECIFICALLY AROUND BASIC MEANS
WE KNOW THAT IF STUDENTS ARE
HUNGRY OR DON'T HAVE A WARM SAFE
PLACE TO SLEEP IT AFFECTS THEIR
ABILITY TO DO WELL.
AND ULTIMATELY COMPLETE COLLEGE --
AND WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO CREATE A
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM IT WILL
ALLOW EDUCATION OFFICIALS TO
MEASURE STUDENT PERFORMANCE AND%
THE BARRIERS.
OF FROM PRE K. THROUGH COLLEGE
GRADUATION A WORKFORCE
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE HANDFUL
OF STATES WITHOUT A SYSTEM LIKE
THIS IN THE WORKS.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU IN THE ADMINISTRATION
ON THESE ISSUES THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR COMING.
ANY FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT.
WELL I THINK THIS I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR ATTENDING
THIS WAS A GREAT HEARING FINANCE
THANKS FOR PARTICIPATING LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER.
DISCUSSIONS ON THESE SUBJECTS.
HEARING NOTHING ELSE THIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED